Hallo und herzlich willkommen, hier ist die Freak Show und ich hoffe, ich brösel jetzt nicht.
Es hat nämlich die ganze Zeit nicht gebröselt, aber ganz kurz bevor ich jetzt
angefangen habe zu sprechen, gab es kurz einen Bröseler und ich hoffe,
ich brösel jetzt nicht zurück. Oder brösel ich zurück?
Was ist bröseln? Du musst, glaube ich, erstmal eine Definition voranschicken.
Bröseln, das ist das, was du gesagt hast, dass ich gebröselt habe,
letztes Mal als mein durch Zoom zerstörte Audiospur. kaputt gegangen ist.
Also hier hast du nicht gebröselt bisher.
Ich habe nicht gebröselt. Sehr schön. Diesmal haben wir so viele Backup-Recordings,
jetzt kann gar nichts bröseln.
Selbst wenn es wirklich bröselt in unserer Realität, in eurer Realität bröselt da mal gar nichts.
Außer vielleicht euer Hirn, wenn wir unsere tollen Themen eingebracht haben,
die wir hier dediziert oder dezidiert vortragen werden. Je nachdem.
Der Meister der Handmoderation. Hervorragend.
Ihr seht schon, wir haben auch das Feedback gelesen. Es waren ja auch nur 146
Kommentare zu der letzten Sendung.
Es ist knapp unter dem Topscore der Messerfolge von 154.
Oh, wirklich?
Wenn noch 10 Kommentare eintrudeln, dann ist das nur eine Spitzenreiter.
Welch eine Überraschung bei dem Thema, was wir hatten.
Ja, es hat gebröselt, aber vor allen Dingen die Laune der Leute.
Also mancher Leute fanden das irgendwie gar nicht lustig, was sie gesagt haben.
Wir werden noch darauf zurückkommen.
Das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen, dass Leute uns nicht lustig gefunden haben. Oder?
Ja, was haben wir denn jetzt hier überhaupt? Ausgabe Nummer 304.
Und es ist der, was haben wir denn heute für ein Datum? Der 23.
Februar im Jahre des Jahres 2026.
So sieht es aus. Genau. Und wir sind jetzt relativ früh dran mit zwei Wochen Abstand.
Das wollen wir jetzt nicht unbedingt immer machen, aber das hat sich jetzt gerade
mal nicht anders ergeben, wegen all der Reisen, die so anstehen.
Tja, toll, ne? Mehr Content für euch und ja.
Wie geht es dir da unten? Was hast du denn erlebt in den letzten zwei Wochen?
Ach, naja, ich bin ja in Südafrika und habe jetzt so die letzten Wochen damit
verbracht, dieses Land ein bisschen zu begreifen, sagen wir es mal so.
Also ich bin ja hier am Westkap um Kapstadt herum und ja,
ich würde nicht behaupten wollen, dass ich jetzt hier schon alles verstanden
habe, aber die Dinge liegen jetzt schon etwas differenzierter vor, sagen wir es mal so.
Auf jeden Fall kann ich sagen, dass wenig überraschend die europäische Perspektive
auf Südafrika ein bisschen einfach gestrickt ist, wie das ja eigentlich immer so ist,
wenn man ferne Länder aus einer großen Ferne zu bewerten scheint.
Und es ist irgendwie eine interessante Mischung aus Zukunftsland,
also es ist ein Land mit viel potenzieller Zukunft, sagen wir es mal so,
aber es ist natürlich auch ein Land mit einer sehr zerrissenen Vergangenheit,
das kennen wir ja so als Deutsche auch ganz gut und das beschäftigt hier alle.
Auf der einen Seite laufen ja auch eine ganze Menge Sachen nicht so gut,
Und das beklagen auch einige und das beklagen auch einige zu Recht, wie ich finde.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es aber auch einfach ein interessanter und auf so
eine ganz spezielle Art und Weise super internationaler Ort.
Um das mal etwas abstrakt zu formulieren. Ich könnte gerne mal reinfragen.
Was damit gemeint haben. Du meinst ja, dass du jetzt irgendwie so ein paar Widersprüche
aufdeckst von so Erwartungshaltung oder dem Bild, was wir uns über Südafrika
machen. und was du jetzt so langsam aufdeckst.
Du kannst doch irgendwie so einen Finger auf ein, zwei Themen draufsetzen, wo du meinst, so das...
Naja, ich meine, was ist das erste Wort, was dir einfällt, wenn du an Südafrika denkst?
Na, Apartheid.
Genau, ne? Also das ist sozusagen so, das ist ja so die Perspektive und die
ist halt genauso rund, wenn du auf Südafrika schaust, als wenn du irgendwie
auf Deutschland schaust und sagst, ja Nazis.
Fast das Gleiche.
Und damit wäre dann irgendwie alles schon erklärt. Das ist schon noch ein bisschen differenzierter.
Naja, es ist halt einfach durch diese Situation,
dass hier eigentlich erst seit 1990 so ein demokratisches System Einzug gehalten
hat und diese Apartheid als solche erstmal beendet wurde.
Da kann man natürlich jetzt nicht sagen, dass jetzt irgendwie nach 30 Jahren
mal eben alle Probleme, die mit dem Zusammenleben unterschiedlicher Kulturen hier aufgekommen sind,
dann irgendwie erledigt werden. Und dann ist auf einmal alles supi.
Und das hat ja dann auch die ganze Regierung sich komplett geändert. Und manche Sachen...
Haben sich dann sicherlich gut entwickelt und andere Sachen haben sich halt
nicht so gut entwickelt.
Also man beklagt hier einfach die Professionalität und es gibt einfach extrem
viel blatant corruption.
Also es ist halt einfach, jeder weiß es, dass einfach Dinge nicht so gut funktionieren,
und dass man einfach teilweise auch aus seiner Vergangenheit nicht herauskommt.
Also hier am Westkapp ist es ein bisschen besser, um nur so ein Beispiel zu
nennen, diese ganze Energieplanung ist hier irgendwie so vollkommen vergeigt worden.
Also es gab einfach hier noch bis vor zwei Jahren regelmäßig dieses Load-Shedding,
wo also dann immer schon angekündigt wurde, ja wir müssen jetzt hier mal für
sechs Stunden den Strom ausschalten und das dann vielleicht auch zweimal am Tag.
Und es gab so richtig so einen Plan, wann gibt es Strom, wann gibt es keinen
Strom, wo du dich halt fragst, wie lange soll denn das jetzt noch weiterlaufen?
Und es ist im Osten des Landes noch ein größeres Problem.
Und das hat einfach was damit zu tun, dass diese ganze Energieplanung nicht
richtig vorgenommen wurde.
Man hat also einfach das Wachstum des Landes, das Wachstum des Bedarfs für alle
wachsenden Städte und für die Industrie so nicht gesehen.
Und das führt natürlich dann gleich wieder zu anderen Problemen,
dass einfach die Infrastruktur, die Südafrika eigentlich ausmacht,
dann nicht unbedingt zugrunde geht, aber zumindest einfach, das hat ja sofort
auch wirtschaftliche Auswirkungen und reißt da alles mit, wenn du irgendwie
nicht in der Lage bist, erstmal deine Stromversorgung ordentlich zu organisieren.
Und das bessert sich teilweise aber es ist halt auch nach wie vor noch ein Problem
und wenn du auf andere Segmente schaust, dann siehst du halt ähnliche Muster.
Ich habe mal in den Chat reingeworfen, kommt vielleicht auch in die Shownotes,
der Wikipedia-Artikel zum Korruptionswahrnehmungsindex.
Hattet ihr den schon mal irgendwann in irgendeiner Sendung? Das ist ja so ein
Klassiker, ich glaube seit 95 oder sowas wird das erhoben, wie hoch die wahrgenommene
Korruption in einem Land ist. Weil wirklich messen kannst du es ja nicht,
dann wäre es ja auch keine richtige Korruption.
Und das finde ich nach wie vor immer ganz hilfreich, da ab und zu mal drauf
zu gucken, wie steht es denn eigentlich jetzt so in Deutschland und Europa allgemein.
Und wenn man sich jetzt hier Südafrika anguckt, dann ja, ist nicht toll,
ist so im mittleren Wert, also quasi 100 ist korruptionsfrei und 0 ist,
geht gar nichts ohne entsprechendes Geld.
Und da liegt jetzt Südafrika so im Mittelfeld, 40 bis 49 ist es glaube ich von
der Einfärbung, aber innerhalb von Afrika gar nicht so schlecht.
Mittelfeld ist gut, das ist knallorange.
Naja, das ist immer ein bisschen eine Frage, wie du jetzt so eine Skala machst.
Also beispielsweise der Übergang von Blau zu Gelb ist jetzt hier ausgesprochen abrupt.
Ja, an der kanadisch-amerikanischen, US-amerikanischen Grenze zum Beispiel.
Oder an der deutsch-französischen Grenze.
Also da hätte ich jetzt als ehemaliger Sozialwissenschaftler ein bisschen Bedenken,
was diese Farbskala angeht, weil so das Blau als da ist alles gut setzt sich
viel zu deutlich vom Rest irgendwie ab und etwas willkürlich halt hier zwischen
69 und 70 aber das heißt ja nicht,
dass die Zahlen dahinter nicht irgendwie hilfreich sind.
Ja, also was man vielleicht mal so festhalten sollte also wie gesagt ich bin
hier seit vier Wochen ich beschäftige mich zwar viel,
Ich habe nicht Geschichte Südafrikas studiert, ich habe nicht das ganze Land
bereist, ich weiß nicht alles.
Das ist ein rein subjektiver Eindruck, den ich hier so schildern kann.
Aber die erste Wahrnehmung ist vor allem, das ist jetzt hier so First World.
Also du kommst in diese Region und die unmittelbare Wahrnehmung ist erstmal,
hier gibt es irgendwie First World, hier gibt es irgendwie alle Produkte,
hier gibt es Supermärkte, hier gibt es irgendwie Infrastruktur,
hier gibt es Autobahnen, hier fahren Autos, hier gibt es Geschäfte,
hier gibt es Leben, hier ist Kaffee an Kaffee gestaffelt in der City.
Du hast irgendwie Kultur und das Ganze irgendwie in einem wunderschönen Land.
Aber du hast halt dann auch so diese Third-World-Aspekte, die halt einfach dadurch
jetzt entstehen, dass durch die.
Abrupte Auflösung dieser Trennkultur, also dieser Apartheid,
das heißt ja sozusagen, wir trennen die Bereiche und dann das, was man,
was halt das große Problem an dieser Apartheid ist, dass das dann halt einfach irgendwann,
das war irgendwann mal so eine abstrakte Idee, ja wir trennen einfach die Gebiete
und dann haben wir irgendwie keine Probleme miteinander,
das war natürlich nicht zu halten und es ist dann halt in dieser ganzen Phase
seit den 50er Jahren bis 90, also in diesen 40 Jahren, wo das dann wirklich
so dieses Apartheids-Regime war.
Es ist dann natürlich wie immer wenn du solche Machtsysteme hast völlig ausgeufert
und völlig völlig übertrieben gewesen und dann gab es halt irgendwann diese
Rides und irgendwann war es dann halt auch nicht mehr zu halten.
Und dann ist es aber so aufgelöst worden und wie du halt irgendwie so mit Osteuropa,
Ostdeutschland und Westdeutschland auf einmal so Mauer weg, zack bumm,
alles fließt ineinander und natürlich gibt es dann irgendwie Reibung.
Und hier ist es halt genauso, weil natürlich dann vor allem die schwarze Bevölkerung.
Und dann gesagt hat er, jetzt gehen wir auch mal dahin, wo mehr Geld zu verdienen ist.
Und dadurch hatten natürlich alle Städte auf einmal einen unheimlichen Zulauf.
Und so viele Leute waren die Wirtschaft dann auch nicht in der Lage aufzunehmen.
Und dadurch gibt es halt diese Siedlung, wo man halt einfach so ein Meer von
Blechhütten siehst, die dann so mitten in die Dünen gebaut sind.
Dann denkst du halt auch so, wow, das sieht ja jetzt einfach mal super schlimm aus.
Und das ist auch teilweise super schlimm, aber das ist halt auch nicht die ganze Geschichte.
Das ist halt hier sehr abgestuft, es gibt hier irgendwie alles.
Es gibt ja auch irgendwie eine schwarze und eine colored Mittelclass.
Also colored ist ja, Entschuldigung, das Problem ist, man muss immer so viel
Hintergrund eigentlich erzählen, um das irgendwie alles halbwegs richtig reflektieren zu können.
Aber so der Schnelldurchlauf ist ja so, erst kamen irgendwie die Portugiesen vorbei,
dann haben sich da die Holländer in Südafrika eingenistet im Kapstadt und ja
da ihren Gemüsegarten aufgebaut und da war ja dieser ganze Bereich kaum besiedelt.
Da gab es irgendwie so ein paar Buschleute und so weiter und das war es dann im Wesentlichen.
Dann haben die da so ihre Kultur gemacht, dann kamen irgendwann die Briten,
die eigentlich so gerufen waren, weil die irgendwie mal Angst vor den Franzosen hatten.
Und dann haben die Briten sich irgendwie kapstert sozusagen und dann Nagel gerissen
und dann sind halt irgendwie die ganzen deutsch- und holländischstämmigen nach Osten.
Gezogen und dort ist dann wiederum die Nähe mit Sulu und Rosa und diesen ganzen
anderen Tribes, die dort halt vor allem waren,
hergestellt worden und dann hat halt Großbritannien dann irgendwann so ein Land
draus gemacht und hat gesagt, das ist jetzt hier irgendwie Südafrika und daraus
entstanden dann halt die Sachen und vorher haben dann halt die Holländer aus ihrer,
aus den indonesischen und malaysischen Gebieten irgendwie sich ihre Sklaven für die Farm geholt.
Und deswegen hast du heute hier so eine Bevölkerung, die halt einfach sowohl
diese asiatische Abstimmung haben, als auch natürlich die schwarzen Abstimmungen
aus Afrika und dann eben diese Europäer.
Und jetzt müssen halt irgendwie alle miteinander klarkommen und das ist halt
hier irgendwie so ein Battle.
Aber grundsätzlich funktioniert das hier alles,
und es ist super schick hier was.
Mir zum Thema Südafrika noch einfällt ist halt Trevor Noah, weil der ja aus
Südafrika kommt und das ist ganz lustig als du Loadshedding sagtest hatte da neulich,
hatte ich so ein Stück von ihm gesehen, wo er über das Loadshedding in Südafrika spricht,
wie sich das verändert hat und dass er irgendwann plötzlich in einem Supermarkt
war und dann war ungeplantes Load-Shedding und die Security-Leute haben da erstmal
die Tür zugemacht und keinen mal rausgelassen, damit sie nicht geplündert werden.
Also.
Ja, das klingt realistisch. Wobei Load-Shedding ja eigentlich das angekündigte
Ausschalten ist, aber es gibt natürlich sicherlich den Fall auch,
wo einfach der Strom mal so ausgegangen ist. Ich habe jetzt keinen Stromausfall erlebt.
Und es ist natürlich auch so, dass in der Folge dessen hier ganz viele Häuser
natürlich angefangen haben, sich Solar aufs Dach zu packen.
Also diese, wir machen uns unabhängig vom Netz, wird hier weniger aus so Umweltgründen,
sondern eben einfach aus so praktischen Gründen durchgeführt.
Und insgesamt ist es allerdings so ein bisschen schade, dass dieses Land hat
so viel Platz, Und hier ist so viel Sonne.
Da fasst du dir wirklich an den Kopf, warum es nicht einfach riesige Gebiete mit Solarkraft gibt.
Und das ist natürlich dann auch ein Problem, weil dieses Land so reich an allem ist.
Also das ist ja einfach, diese Kap-Region, diese Südafrika-Region,
das ist ja ein Ausnahmegebiet der Welt.
Also abgesehen davon, dass du hier alle Ressourcen hast.
Hier gibt es Kohle, Eisen, Diamanten,
Gold, ja, also die sogenannten seltenen Erden, Mining ist ja einfach ein riesiges
Ding und gerade auch dieses Gold und Diamanten haben natürlich auch dazu geführt,
dass sich hier alle permanent die Köpfe eingehauen haben, so in den letzten 100 Jahren.
Das ist alles da, aber dann hast du halt auch einfach ein super fruchtbares
Land so an dieser Küste entlang wo alles angebaut wird und es gibt hier irgendwie
alles, gehst du in den Supermarkt rein da steht ja so, alles was wir hier verkaufen
kommt so 90, 95% alles aus,
Südafrika, es gibt natürlich alle alle Früchten, alles was du irgendwie essen
kannst, alles ist frisch, alles ist lecker.
Fleischproduktion ist hier ein großes Ding also das ist eigentlich Südafrika
ist ein Füllhorn Und was ich auch nicht wusste ist, Südafrika ist so eine eigene Region in der Welt.
Ich kriege das nicht ganz zusammen, aber im Prinzip, wenn man sich die ganze Welt anschaut,
dann gibt es so vier große Zonen, die man unterscheidet, wo so eine spezifische Flora und Fauna ist.
Und die fünfte ist Südafrika. Das heißt, es gibt hier irgendwie 30 Prozent aller
Arten der Welt und so eine Geschichte. Also es ist einfach crazy.
Letztes Mal habe ich schon die komischen Vögel angesprochen.
Also hier gibt es halt einfach das, was es woanders nicht gibt.
Und davon ganz viel. Und du fährst hier irgendwie rum und dann irgendwelche
Affen und irgendwelche Vogelsträuße und es gibt hier einfach allerlei Getier
und Antilopen und Pipapo.
Ja, mach gucken. Also das ist auf jeden Fall ein aufregendes Land,
was sich lohnt, besucht zu werden. Kann ich sehr empfehlen.
Hast du denn jetzt Pinguine schon gesehen?
Ich habe schon Pinguine gesehen, ja.
Hat er schon in der letzten Sendung gesehen?
Habe ich schon berichtet. Die Pinguine habe ich gleich als erstes abgehakt und
übernächste Woche stehen dann noch ein paar größere Tiermaßnahmen an.
Davon werde ich dann berichten, wenn ich wieder da bin.
Ich war sogar schon im Stadion an der alten Försterei 2.
Was?
Mitten in der Wüste gibt es hier einen verrückten Exil-Unioner,
der irgendwann nach Afrika ausgewandert ist.
Und weil es einen Unioner nicht ohne Fußball aushalten kann,
hat er mitten in der Wüste ein Stadion gebaut.
Das heißt Stadion an der alten Försterei 2.
Okay, das ist wahrscheinlich nicht so groß wie das Original.
Naja, es ist schon ein Fußballplatz. Das Stadion hat jetzt nicht ganz so viel Besucherkapazität.
Das ist im Wesentlichen so eine Tribüne mit so vier, fünf, sechs Stufen.
Das macht aber dann so mit dem Dach in der Sonne eine ganze Menge aus.
Und ja, aber der hat sich halt die Mühe gemacht und da in diesen steinigen Wüstenboden
irgendwie das so glatt planiert.
Und finden dort auch Spiele statt.
Ja, ja. Da spielen halt die Kids. Das ist sozusagen dann für das ganze Einzugsgebiet,
alle Kids, die da sind, die haben irgendwie drei Mannschaften,
drei Jugendmannschaften und treten dann regelmäßig gegen andere Mannschaften
aus der Umgebung an und sind da irgendwie aber auch die Besten,
weil sie natürlich die besten Trainingsbedingungen haben.
Das ist richtig cool.
Heißen die auch Union?
Die heißen auch Union, ja. Die heißen Union Latte ganz fly. Das ist ein Stadtteil
oder ein Teil von der Stadt Auzhorn und Union, da wird richtig eisern Union gerufen und irgendwie.
Also das ist noch ein echter Kulturexport-Schlager von Berlin.
Also da musste ich halt unbedingt hingehen und ich war da.
Jaja, also von daher so an Verrücktheiten hat das Land hier alles zu bieten
und vor allem du fährst halt immer irgendwie 50 genug hin und es gibt einfach hier alles so,
also du hast halt irgendwie Berge und Meer und Grün und Wüste und Dünen und Weinberge,
und es gibt einfach alles und alles innerhalb kürzester Abfolge und,
ja, wie gesagt, ich kenne jetzt nur diesen Westcup-Bereich, der ist schon beeindruckend genug.
Gibt sicherlich noch mehr zu entdecken, aber passt natürlich nicht in einen
kurzen Aufenthalt rein.
Ja, soviel mal zu Südafrika. Finde ich gut. Tolles Land.
So, haben wir noch Themen?
Zwei Wochen kommt ja nicht so viel.
Ja, wir haben ein paar große Themen, aber ich dachte, wir könnten vielleicht
mal mit ein bisschen Apple-Kram anfangen.
Ich wollte mal ein paar auf Kleinigkeiten hinweisen, die so angekündigt sind.
Wir haben ja nächste Woche, steht ja wahrscheinlich, ist das nächste Woche, 8.
März oder übernächste Woche?
Sollte übernächste sein. Ja, ich glaube übernächste Woche wird es wahrscheinlich
wieder so eine Release-Kaskade geben mit neuen MacBook Airs und was weiß ich,
MacBook Pros und Pipapo und allem Möglichen.
Da werden wir dann drüber reden, wenn es soweit ist.
Aber eine nette Sache finde ich, das ist so ein schönes Detail und zwar mit
dem iOS 26.3 Update. Also jetzt das Letzte, was gerade vor kurzem aufschlug.
Das ich zur Sendung gerade installiert habe. Live.
Genau.
Was gibt es da?
Und zwar gibt es für die neuen Telefone von Apple und ich glaube,
das bezieht sich auf das alte 16e und auf das neue 17er.
Also die, die den eigenen Apple-Funk-Chip drin haben, diesen C1, C1X oder C1 und C1X.
Und da, ich habe das aber nicht, muss ich sagen, ich habe es nicht ausprobiert,
da kann man dann aber die Lokalisierung des Telefons über das Mobilfunknetz einschränken.
Also das ist sozusagen ein Privacy-Setting auf Mobilfunk-Modem-Ebene.
Man kennt ja diese Lokalisierungsgeschichten, das Netz muss ja irgendwie wissen,
wo man ist, weil sonst kann man ja keine Telefonanrufe bekommen.
Naja, man meldet sich ja an einer Basisstation an, quasi.
Ja, man meldet sich an einer Basisstation an, also es gibt ja auch noch so Leute,
die noch nicht mal das verinnerlichen, aber das ist klar.
Aber eine Basisstation, das kann ja dann auch immer noch 10,
20 Kilometer entfernt sein in einem großen Kreis um diese Basisstation herum.
Ja, das gibt der Standard her, aber nicht das Netz.
Wie meinst du das?
Naja, realistisch betrachtet, also zumindest, na gut, vielleicht auf dem Land
vielleicht schon, aber in der Stadt sind die Zählen ja viel, viel kleiner.
Ja, in der Regel sind sie kleiner, aber sie können auch groß sein.
So und ich rede ja jetzt auch nicht nur von 5G, sondern auch theoretisch noch von GSM.
Und,
über Triangulationen, weil du ja meistens nicht nur eine Mobilfunkstation siehst,
sondern ja auch noch im Idealfall eine andere,
mit der du eben gerade noch verbunden warst, bevor du mit den nächsten verbunden
wirst, damit es dann auch ein Handover gibt und nicht wieder eine,
oh scheiße, kein Netz und dann erst wieder nach 10 Minuten gibt es wieder Netz.
Das haben wir natürlich in Deutschland auch.
Also es gibt oft den Fall, dass du mehr als eine Zelle siehst,
vor allem natürlich in der Stadt.
Und irgendwie haben sie aber jetzt auf Modem, mit Modem meine ich jetzt diesen
Chip, der in dem Telefon drin ist, der also wirklich die Kommunikation,
die Mobilfunkkommunikation macht.
Das ist ja jetzt in den neuen Telefonen eben mal von Apple der eigenproduzierte
Chip und nicht mehr diese Qualcomm-Chips.
Und dort gibt es halt dieses Feature als Privacy Feature, dass man eben die
präzise, also Limit Precise Location heißt das, mit dem man sozusagen nicht
mehr so genau getrackt werden kann.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, was das genau macht, also wie es das genau
macht, aber irgendwie macht es das.
Okay.
Also C1 oder C1X-Chip, iPhone R, iPhone 16e, das hatte ja als erstes diesen
Stein und das neue M5 iPad Pro.
Das sind derzeit die Devices, wo das ist und wir können davon ausgehen,
dass in absehbarer Zeit, die neuen 17er sind da noch gar nicht mit drin,
sondern nur das iPhone R. Okay, verstehe.
Dann geht das wahrscheinlich erst mit iPhone 18 dann so weiter.
Also ein Upcoming Feature, von dem die meisten von uns jetzt noch nicht viel haben.
Fand ich bemerkenswert, dass es das gibt.
Ich packe auch mal kurz den passenden Link dazu noch in die den Schlag rein.
Ehrlich gesagt wundert mich das ein bisschen, weil da kommt doch bestimmt jemand
an und heult rum, dass sich dann das die iPhones nicht verhalten,
wie der Standard vorgibt.
Weil das ist doch bestimmt ein Hack, den die da machen.
Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ob das ein Hack ist oder ob sie einfach nur
ein paar Kommastellen irgendwo weglassen.
Also es ist ja in gewisser Hinsicht ein Selbstauskunftsfeature.
Ich kenne mich da aber jetzt mit dem Standard so nicht aus, um sagen zu können,
was das jetzt genau für ein Ding ist.
Aber ich habe die Vermutung, dass die Telefone auf jeden Fall den Zellen dabei
helfen können, diese Position genau zu melden.
Oder es ist vielleicht sogar verbunden mit diesem,
vielleicht gibt es sogar mittlerweile auf dem Mobilfunk speziell ein Feature
im Protokoll, mit dem das Telefon einfach seine eigene Position melden kann.
Ich weiß, dass der GSM-Standard dadurch, dass du mehrere Telefone auf einer
Frequenz hast und du dann so eine Art Sharing von der gleichen Frequenz machst, aber in Slots,
kann das Netz dem Telefon sagen,
sende mal früher oder sende mal später, je nachdem wie weit du dich tatsächlich
physisch von der Antenne wegbefindest, damit jeder so in seinen Slot reinfällt.
Und zumindest darüber müsste die Antenne auch relativ genau wissen,
wie weit das Telefon jetzt von der Antenne weg ist, weil die ja sagt, früher oder später.
Gut, vielleicht muss das Telefon nicht sagen, ich bin jetzt so und so weit weg,
sondern da sagt er, soll ich später senden?
Gut, sende ich später, keine Ahnung, aber solche Mechanismen existieren zumindest
bei GSM. Ich weiß nicht, wie es mit den anderen Standards ist.
Das ist nach meinem Studium gewesen, seitdem kenne ich mich da nicht mehr aus.
Ja, okay. Also,
ich weiß es auch nicht ganz genau. Vielleicht kriegen wir das in den Kommentaren,
dann können wir das nächste Mal klären.
Zweite Sache, die ich hier noch im Kleinkram hatte, ist es gibt jetzt YouTube,
für die Apple Vision Pro.
Nach nur zwei Jahren.
Super, jetzt kannst du auch YouTube Werbung gucken.
Werbung, ich gucke ja Premium. Du hast dich freigekauft.
Ich habe mich freigekauft.
Ja, ich auch, allerdings wirklich nur wegen meiner Kinder. Also ich selber hätte
denen kein Geld gegeben.
Aber da ich sowas wie Musiksonntag habe, wo ich mal frühkindliche Erziehung
gemacht habe, so Klassiker der Musikgeschichte, irgendwie denen auf die Orgel
legen und da dann ständig irgendwie Werbung dazwischen, das ging gar nicht.
Also in meiner...
Das geht überhaupt nicht, YouTube ohne, also das ist furchtbar.
Manchmal bin ich so ausgelockt und so, was ist das denn?
Das ist halt so wie Privatfernsehen, schon immer wahr.
Das Schöne ist ja, dass man, also YouTube ist ja auch ein amerikanisches Unternehmen
und man merkt amerikanischen Unternehmen immer sehr genau an.
Also besonders, wenn man mal in einem gearbeitet hat, dass die wirklich von
Quartal zu Quartal denken.
Und dass die Erwartung der Shareholder ist, dass auch jedes Quartal besser ist als das Quartal davor.
Was bei eigentlich fast jedem Geschäft, das so ein bisschen saisonal ist, ein Problem ist.
Weil das erste Quartal im Jahr ist halt auch ein bisschen saure Gurkenzeit.
Man merkt es jetzt bei YouTube mal wieder, momentan ist der Werbedruck echt sehr, sehr hoch.
Also scheinbar müssen sie gerade irgendwie gucken, dass sie mehr Geld reinspielen.
Also du schaust mit Werbung.
Ich schaue mit Werbung, ja.
Wirklich?
Ich kenne alle Werbung.
Ich weiß, was los ist. Tolle Werbung. Welche Spiele man unbedingt spielen sollte,
wenn man noch mehr Werbung gucken möchte.
Wie erträgst du das?
Ja, weiß ich nicht genau. Das ist eine Frage, über die ich gar nicht nachdenken möchte.
Also mal abgesehen vom Inhalt, bin ich ja gar nicht bereit, auch nur die Zeit
bereitzustellen, mir das anzuschauen.
Also das hält mich ja einfach mal davon ab, das zu sehen, was ich sowieso sehen will.
Und ich will ja jetzt nicht noch in der Abspielzeit nochmal 10% draufgerechnet
bekommen, wo ich mir einen Dusselscheiß anschauen muss.
Naja, so viel ist es ja jetzt auch nicht.
Und die zweite kann man dann irgendwie wegklicken und so?
Naja, YouTube ist eh Zeitvertreib mehr.
Also es ist ja jetzt keine wissenschaftliche Recherche, die man bei dem Medium tut.
Was? Selbstverständlich ist es das. Also da muss ich mal wirklich mal eine Lanze
brechen, glaube ich, für die YouTube-Kultur.
Die hat sich dann doch ganz gut entwickelt.
Ich meine, es gibt da natürlich eine ganze Menge Müll, gar keine Frage.
Das ist ja ein sehr universelles Medium. aber es gibt so viel gutes Zeug auf
YouTube also so dermaßen viel gutes Zeug das ist es also allein schon wert für
mich ist das einfach die Meta Subscription,
für unheimlich viel Content, der einfach ja gut ist wäre auch nicht schlecht,
wenn der noch woanders wäre, aber ist halt nun mal da Ja.
Also ich sehe das auch so, also egal welches Nischenthema du findest da immer,
ein paar Kanäle, wo dieser Match zwischen ist total mit Herzblut dabei und hat
aber auch noch Ahnung, wo das doch irgendwo in Deckung kommt und das kriegst
du auf YouTube dann doch sehr zuverlässig.
Also ich erinnere an unsere Messerfolge und was ich da für wunderbare Messerkanäle
habe von wirklich voll Nerds, wo du aber trotzdem noch das Gefühl hast,
ja oh, jetzt habe ich es begriffen.
Er hat mir was beigebracht, was die Gesellschaft, woran die Gesellschaft irgendwie
jahrelang oder jahrzehntelang gescheitert ist.
Den Effekt habe ich doch sehr häufig bei YouTube, dass man denkt so,
oh, jetzt habe ich es kapiert, weil ich es habe gesehen und jemand hat sich
Mühe gegeben, es mir zu erklären. Cool.
Also wenn man einen YouTube-Kanal sucht, der wirklich langsam ist, lang,
ist und wo man in die Wanne gehen kann und ganz gemütlich einweichen und das
Gefühl hat, man wird, ja, dann kann ich den Fall of Civilization empfehlen.
Der Typ, der erzählt einem mal eben fünf Stunden, wie war denn das mit den Mongolen
oder mit den Assyrern oder so.
Also oder dem Fall von Byzanz oder so, das ist schon wirklich großartig.
Aber man muss auch die Muße und die Zeit mitbringen, weil der wirklich.
Wie bei so einem Podcast.
Den gibt es auch als Podcast. Den gibt es auch als Podcast.
Man kann ihn auch gut als Podcast hören, weil sowieso jetzt die Bilder sind,
sind vieles halt auch so Bilder, die einfach nur,
naja man zeigt halt, der siehst halt viel Wüste, manchmal die Ruinen und so
weiter, aber es ist jetzt nicht so wie hier in diesem Bild sehen sie.
Aber Tim, was bringt denn jetzt die App-Version für die Vision Pro daher,
was jetzt die Browser-Version quasi nicht hatte?
Ja, also erstmal ist YouTube im normalen Browser gucken auf der Vision Pro ein echter Schmerz,
also das ist, weil die Controls überhaupt nicht für dieses Tapping ausgelegt
sind und es gibt ja auch nicht mal die iPad App auf YouTube.
Vision OS. Da müsste Google ja eigentlich nur einen Haken dran machen und sagen,
darf auch auf der Vision Pro runtergeladen werden und dann wäre das Problem
ja weitgehend gelöst gewesen, aber das haben sie ja nun zwei Jahre lang nicht
gemacht. for unknown reasons.
Und das haben sie auch jetzt nicht getan, sondern jetzt haben sie halt eine
native App rausgebracht, was auch immer sie jetzt dazu gebracht hat.
Also okay, es gibt einen Grund, warum sie das gemacht haben könnten,
weil der große Unterschied ist natürlich der, du kannst dir jetzt nicht nur
den ganzen YouTube-Kram etwas bequemer anschauen.
Und übrigens mein Quick-Fix, dass es überhaupt erträglich war,
weil ich habe schon jetzt die Zeit über YouTube geguckt, ist,
dass du in den Browsereinstellungen sagst, ich bin, gib mir den Mobile,
die Mobile Version der Webseite.
Und dann ist das schon so ein bisschen mehr so iPad-mäßig und größere Controls und dann, das ging so.
Aber du hast halt immer so dieses Problem mit Backbutton und irgendwie,
weißt du, klickst mal irgendwo falsch hin und irgendwie bist du nicht so in Control.
Naja, jetzt ist die neue Version und die macht das ein bisschen einfacher.
Ich würde nicht sagen, dass das User-Interface besonders cool ist.
Aber es unloggt natürlich jetzt auch den VR-Content. Weil YouTube ist ja auch
voll mit 180 Grad, 360 Grad Videos.
Wo also, was weiß ich, irgendwelche verrückten Basejumper da vom Hochhaus runterfliegen
mit einer 360-Grad-Kamera und das dann halt irgendwie filmen und auf YouTube packen.
Und das habe ich so ein bisschen ausprobiert, weil ich hatte das schon mal versucht
mit irgendwelchen komischen anderen gehackten Apps, die angeblich das irgendwie
ermöglichen sollen, aber das hat hinten und vorne nicht funktioniert.
Und das geht jetzt relativ einfach. Jetzt kannst du halt das Video einfach abspielen
und dann geht er eben in diesen immersiven Modus und dann ist es eben wirklich
um dich herum, je nachdem, 180 Grad, 360 Grad.
Allerdings muss man sagen, die Qualität des Contents ist teilweise doch unterirdisch
und man merkt, was so bisher so das Target war.
Also wahrscheinlich hier so diese ganzen günstigeren Geräte.
Also mit Qualität meinst du jetzt nicht Didaktik, Dramaturgie,
sondern jetzt die rein optische Qualität, also Auflösung, Framerate, Schärfe.
Die optische Qualität, also die Auflösung, da stehen zwar manchmal große Auflösungen
dran, man muss dazu sagen,
ich habe ja noch die ursprüngliche Vision Pro, es gibt ja jetzt die mit dem M5,
die M5 kann angeblich den 8K Content auch in der App abspielen und bei der alten
M2 Version sei es dann nur die 2K Variante.
Aber ich glaube, das macht gar nicht so viel aus. Das ist einfach,
dass diese Videos, die da hochgeladen werden, teilweise wirklich komisch sind.
Also da stimmt irgendwas nicht.
Ja, das ist alles viel zu nah dran und so. Aber es gibt auch gute Beispiele.
Also ich habe jetzt noch nicht zu viel Zeit damit verbracht,
weil diese Immersion ist zwar so ganz nice, aber oft gar nicht jetzt so compelling,
dass du sagen würdest, okay, das habe ich jetzt unbedingt in 360 Grad gebraucht.
Aber das kann natürlich, wenn es gut produziert ist, auch interessant sein.
Also gerade wenn du irgendwo so lang fährst und fährst durch eine Landschaft,
dann kannst du halt bei 360 Grad dich einfach umgucken und sagen,
jetzt gucke ich mal nach links, jetzt gucke ich mal nach rechts,
wenn du so eine Safari-Situation hast oder so.
Ich habe ja meine 360-Grad-Kamera hier auch dabei und Safari steht auch noch an.
Da werde ich das mal versuchen zum Einsatz zu bekommen und hoffe, dass das was bringt.
Und das geht halt jetzt. Abgesehen davon, dass eben das normale Steuern der
YouTube-Videos jetzt auch ein bisschen noch ein bisschen einfacher geworden ist.
Und bedeutet das jetzt irgendwas, dass es jetzt Google auf einmal rausgebracht hat?
Ich weiß es nicht. Vielleicht ist das ja auch nur ein Deal mit Apple.
So nach dem Motto, wir benutzen jetzt euer Gemini und eure Server und kaufen
euren AI-Slob ein, dann müsst ihr jetzt hier irgendwie auch auf der Vision Pro
eine YouTube-App rausbringen.
Würde mich jetzt noch nicht mal wundern.
Sieht sie denn nach zwei Wochen aus? Nach zwei Wochen Arbeit oder sieht sie
nach zwei Jahren Arbeit aus?
Ja, also ich kann mir nicht, also diese 360-Grad-Support, dieser VR-Support,
der könnte etwas aufwendiger gewesen sein.
Weil ich meine, dass die Video-Formate, wie man, also wie YouTube,
die erwarten, glaube ich, diese.
Äquidistant, ich bin gerade schwach in den Begriffen, es gibt ja so zwei Arten
und Weisen, wie du so 360 Grad in das Video reinbringen kannst.
Ob du sozusagen so zweimal 180 Grad Fischaugeln nebeneinander hast,
wie das zum Beispiel roh von den Kameras kommt, oder ob du das dann halt in
so einen equidistanten Gesamtrundumview umrechnest.
Und so legt das, glaube ich, YouTube ab. und ich weiß halt jetzt nicht ganz
genau, was jetzt wiederum die Vision Pro braucht.
Also ich kann mir vorstellen, dass da ein gewisser Konversionsvorgang erforderlich
war, den sicherlich jetzt nicht die App in Realtime leistet.
Vielleicht ist es auch so, dass YouTube diese Videos auf YouTube nochmal anders
hat rechnen müssen, um sie auch auf der Vision Pro auszuspielen.
Kann auch sein. Ich habe mich jetzt gerade so ein bisschen überfragt.
Müssen wir mal hinterher recherchieren, ob es da noch andere Leute gibt,
die sich das mal genauer angeschaut haben.
Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall, die App ist jetzt da. Das ändert jetzt nicht
viel auf der Vision Pro, muss man sagen, weil die Zahl von beeindruckenden Apps,
die so auf der Plattform aufschlagen, ist dann doch sehr gering.
Also es gibt einfach wenig Ereignisse. Für mich ist die Brille nach wie vor
praktisch, weil sie halt einfach ein super Reisemonitor ist.
Und ich denke, das ist immer noch die beste Anwendung, auch wenn ich das anfangs
gar nicht so erwartet hatte.
Und es ist halt cool, um Filme zu gucken und das wird jetzt immer so ein bisschen einfacher.
Apple haut nebenbei dann immer noch so ein paar neue Beispielfilmchen raus,
die so, naja, ganz nett, aber deswegen braucht man es jetzt irgendwie auch nicht.
Und ich bin mir noch nicht so ganz so sicher, was sich da für ein Markt, wenn überhaupt,
jemals entwickeln wird, um diesen ganzen VR oder Immersions Video Bereich. Unklar.
Ja, das dazu. Und dann,
hatte ich in der letzten Sendung kam dieser Helium-Browser auf,
der mir ehrlich gesagt in dem Moment neu war und ich habe den jetzt mal benutzt,
und ich bin ja wirklich kein,
Freund des permanenten Browserwechsels, aber ich habe mich einfach,
ganz ehrlich, Safari hat mich so angekotzt in den letzten Releases,
weil es einfach so buggy war und,
crashes und weiß ich nicht, auch so eine Zähigkeit in allem und ich habe diesen
Helium-Browser aufgemacht und abgesehen davon, dass der der beste Adblocker aller Zeiten ist,
Also ich habe das Gefühl, du schaust durch alle Werbung durch mit diesem Internet.
Also wenn du ins Web guckst, mit diesem Helium-Browser, auf einmal ist jede Webseite zu ertragen.
Wobei man sagen muss, das ist jetzt nichts, was Helium erfunden hat.
Da wurden wir nämlich dankenswerterweise auch von Hörerinnen und Hörern darauf
hingewiesen, sondern das ist einfach nur dieses U-Block Origin Plugin,
was du exakt so beispielsweise im Firefox installieren kannst.
Und dann sieht der Firefox pixelgenau exakt genauso gefiltert aus.
Es gibt für Safari eine Lite-Version davon.
Die habe ich auch mal ausprobiert, aber wie bei Safari leider nicht anders zu
erwarten, Fällt das dann wieder zu einer Kaskade von sonderbaren Nebeneffekten.
Aber wer also auf dem Firefox unterwegs sein möchte, der kann quasi das U-Block
Origin genauso anklicken und hat das exakt dieselbe Experience.
Ja, okay, gut. Das mag sein, dass es sozusagen genau derselbe Effekt ist. Also auf jeden Fall gut.
Ich mag aber einfach, wie schnell das Ding ist und wie schlank das Ding ist.
Also es ist halt einfach, weiß ich nicht, kommt mir gerade irgendwie sehr entgegen.
Ich teste mal das Fühl, weil ich einfach so frustriert bin von der Gesamtperformance.
Da muss irgendwie Apple einfach mal nachliefern. Aber dann nerven mich halt
gleich wieder so Sachen, wie dass man irgendwie keinen Anti-Auto-Play für Videos machen kann.
Ja, machst du wie so eine YouTube-Seite auf und dann guckt das Video sofort los.
Das sind dann schon so Sachen, wenn ich da keine Lösung für finde,
dann ist es dann auch bald wieder vorbei mit dem Browser-Glück.
Und ja, mal gucken, ich schaue mir das jetzt einfach mal an,
finde ich also auf jeden Fall nochmal wert, den zu erwähnen.
Und außerdem gab es noch Feedback, ich hatte mich ja beklagt,
dass es irgendwie Du hattest geschrieben.
Dass es auch eine Keychain-Integration gäbe, die habe ich nicht gefunden.
Naja, die brauche es,
Und es geht so mit 1Password.
Also mit 1Password hast du schon so eine, aber das ist halt eigentlich...
So 1Password als Bridge dann Richtung Keychain, oder?
Naja, das 1Password hat ja so Plugins und kann sich in die Browser irgendwie
reinklinken. Und das funktioniert auch bei dem Helium.
Aber es ist dann nicht die Apple Keychain, sondern es ist dann die 1Password.
Genau, aber das wäre, sagen wir mal, etwas, was ich gerne sehen würde.
Und die für mich am Ende auch recht wichtig ist jetzt wirklich für so einen,
das ist mein Default-Browser.
Ich finde gerade, dass die Passwort-Geschichte unter macOS ja wirklich jetzt
im letzten Release oder sogar schon im vorletzten, ist auf jeden Fall sehr viel besser geworden.
Und mittlerweile würde ich jetzt keinem unbedingt, also wenn man jetzt sieht,
der totale Power-User ist, dann ist glaube ich so One Password nicht unbedingt erforderlich mehr.
Das war früher mal anders. Die Standard-Passwort-Lösung
im macOS finde ich mittlerweile richtig ordentlich.
Und funktioniert auch super und hat eigentlich wenig zu wünschen übrig.
Aber wenn man halt so Power-User-mäßig unterwegs ist, ich benutze halt One Password
schon sehr lange und da sind halt einfach ein paar Sachen drin,
die jetzt die normale Password-Integration halt so nicht hat und die für mich
einfach praktisch sind.
Also vor allem diese Secure Notes, die da drin sind, wo man halt so eine Notiz
anlegen kann, wo man sich Abschnitte einrichten kann und für jeden Abschnitt einzelne Werte.
Und ich benutze das zum Beispiel für meine ganzen API-Keys, die ich jetzt brauche,
um auf irgendwelche Webseiten oder APIs, eben Web-APIs zuzugreifen.
Und dann hast du halt auch eine Integration auf der Kommandozeile.
Du kannst also mit One Password ja auch so eine CLI installieren und dann bin
ich zum Beispiel in der Lage, das heißt, wenn ich jetzt hier so eine.
Webseite jetzt zusammenprogrammiere, irgendwie mit Elixir und ich benutze halt
irgendwie Zugriffe auf Beispiele, AWS oder sowas,
dann kann ich die alle in OnePassword ablegen, weil du hast ja immer dieses
Problem, du willst ja im Software Development nicht deine Keys irgendwie mit auf Git einchecken.
Ja, das willst du nicht.
Aber du willst ja auch nicht unbedingt jetzt nur in so Punktfiles auf einem
Rechner, in einem Directory rumliegen lassen und dann bist du mal an einem anderen
Rechner und dann willst du irgendwie,
willst du das da auch mal compilen oder willst du das irgendwo anders nochmal
auschecken, wo kriegst du jetzt deine Keys her,
ohne sie einfach in irgendwelchen Textdateilen einfach so rumfliegen zu lassen.
Und dann mache ich das jetzt mittlerweile so, dass ich,
also wenn ich das jetzt mit Elixier mache, das kann man natürlich genauso auch
in anderen Bildsystemen machen, aber ich benutze dann dieses Mix-Kommando und
dieses Mix-Kommando ruft dann irgendwie One Password auf,
holt sich aus einer Secure Note mit einem bestimmten Namen eben diese ganzen
Keys raus und baut mir dann eben lokal so ein kleines Elixier-File zusammen,
wo dann irgendwie diese ganzen Settings drin sind.
Das heißt, ich generiere mir die einmal, hole mir die aus dieser Keychain raus
und dann liegen die lokal auf dem Rechner und dann kann ich sagen,
okay, jetzt deploy mal das Programm, hier sind deine Keys und jetzt weißt du auch, was zu tun ist.
Aber ich habe zu keinem Zeitpunkt diese Keys jetzt in irgendwelchen Unsecure-Files
außer jetzt in dem Development-Directorie rumliegen.
Und vor allem syncht sich das dann eben gleich auch auf andere Systeme und wenn
ich da halt dann woanders mir das aufbauen will und ich brauche diese Keys,
dann brauche ich halt einfach nur dieses Skript starten und dann baut er mir
das irgendwie wieder neu zusammen.
Also das ist so my way und deswegen ist One Password für mich so ein bisschen
der Development und komplexere Scheißekram.
Aber so für den Daily Use finde ich ist so für das normale Einloggen auf Webseiten
und Passkeys und so weiter ist das Standard Passwortsystem von macOS einfach
vollkommen ausreichend für wahrscheinlich 99 Prozent der User.
Also ich habe beim letzten Digital Independence Day, bin ich mal umgestiegen
von 1Password auf diesen Bitwarden Spin-off Foldwarden,
den ich jetzt auf meiner Cloud-Round-Instanz laufen habe und den ich von allen Devices aus ansteuere.
Aber das ist von der UX her ist das auch schon so One Password ist halt auch
schon ziemlich sleek, muss man sagen.
Das ist schon ganz gut designt.
Orientiert sich halt einfach jeder dran und wird halt überall unterstützt. Aber ja, die,
Die Apple-Sachen sind auch dramatisch besser geworden. Das würde ich auch so
sehen. Wenn sie da noch ein bisschen länger und mehr Liebe drauf werfen.
Ja, da haben sie auch, sagen wir mal, so den Pace, wo ich finde,
jetzt ganz gut getroffen.
Also ich meine, Apple waren die Ersten, die überhaupt so einen Passwortmanager
in die Welt gebracht haben. Das gab es ja schon auf dem alten macOS.
Das haben wenig Leute benutzt, aber das hat funktioniert.
Und dann haben sie da ganz lange daran nichts gemacht. Das gab es zwar dann
weiterhin auf macOS 10, dann kam irgendwie One Pass und hat gesagt,
ja guck mal, das geht auch alles noch viel toller und hier Feature hier,
Feature da und Walls und Sync und was nicht alles und dann hat es irgendwie
lange Zeit gedauert und dann hat Apple gesagt,
okay, jetzt machen wir das mal auch hier den ganzen neuen Kram,
weil es ist ja auch wichtig,
gerade um so Passkeys einzuführen und so und jetzt haben sie es so auf so einen okayen Stand gebracht.
Aber wenn man halt so den Luxus haben will mit so Family Sharing,
mit verschiedenen Walls und alles schön unterscheiden und dann haben sie noch
dieses Watchtower Feature,
wobei das hat Apple jetzt glaube ich auch, dass sie dich warnen,
wenn irgendwelche Passwords geleakt sind auf irgendwelchen Sites,
dass du das dann mal schnell mal änderst und so, das ist schon ganz gut.
Naja, also es ist eigentlich ein ziemlicher Luxus, den man da jetzt derzeit
hat so auf macOS und One Password läuft ja auch auf Windows, oder?
Okay, genau. Und letzter Kram zum Thema macOS.
Letztes Mal hatte ich mich beschwert, dass man ja auf diesen blöden macOS nicht
einfach mal mit einer Geste ein Fenster verschieben kann,
ohne irgendwo an irgendeinen blöden Pixel zu klicken, um es dann festzuhalten und dann zu schieben.
Und dann wurde ich auf zwei verschiedene Dinge hingewiesen, nämlich erstens
einen Kommandozeilentrick, wo man also tatsächlich mit Bordmitteln,
also mit so einem Standard-Default-Kommando,
zumindest das so einschalten kann, dass wenn man Control und Command drückt,
dass man irgendwo ins Fenster klicken kann und dann kann man es verschieben.
Das fand ich schon mal ganz gut.
Und außerdem gab es dann nochmal den Hinweis auf das Tool.
MOM das ist so ein macOS Utility, was halt noch so ein paar andere Features
macht, da kann man dann auch,
irgendwelche Modifier drücken und dann reicht es schon nur die Maus zu bewegen
und man kann ein Fenster verschieben hat noch ein paar andere Tricks drauf eigentlich
wollte ich halt wie einfach vier Fingergeste drauflegen.
Das finde ich am einfachsten. Einfach vier Finger nehmen, auf Fenster drauf, hin und her schieben.
So einfach könnte die Welt sein. Aber offensichtlich darf die Welt nicht so
leicht sein. Das wäre ja noch schöner.
Genau.
Ja, das dazu und dann habe ich mir noch AirTags gekauft.
Ja, ich auch.
Du hast ja auch schon ausprobiert.
Nee, die liegen noch bei mir, was natürlich total sinnvoll ist,
damit meine Fahrräder abzusichern, sie dann erstmal einen Monat zu Hause liegen zu lassen.
Und ich habe mir so ein Dreierset, Viererset, Vierersets sind es glaube ich,
ein neues geholt, um meine alten dann irgendwie durchzurotieren und auf weniger
wichtige Sachen drauf zu plöppen und die neuen dann wieder in unsere Fahrräder
rein, weil es wird ja immer noch viel geklaut, aber uns wurde jetzt schon lange nichts mehr geklaut,
toi toi toi, auch weil unsere Schlösser glaube ich dramatisch besser geworden
sind jetzt die wir dran haben.
Aber sobald ich das mal umgebaut habe, mal gucken zur nächsten Sendung,
schaffe ich das vielleicht mal, dann kann ich da vielleicht schon den einen
oder anderen Praxishinweis geben.
Ich glaube, so rasend groß ist der Unterschied da einfach mal nicht.
Nee, das einzige Feature ist, dass du jetzt, wenn du eine halbwegs moderne Apple
Watch hast, dass du die neuen Tags halt auch mit der Uhr finden kannst.
Falls du gerade dein Telefon nicht dabei hast.
Über dieses Millimeter Wave, oder wie das heißt, ne?
Ultra Wideband.
Ultra Wideband, ja.
Genau, und das ist ja jetzt das Upgrade im neuen AirTag, dass das Ding halt,
also die eigentlichen Änderungen sind ja, das Ding ist ein bisschen lauter,
das Ding strahlt Bluetooth weiter ab und lässt sich auch über größere Distanzen
mit Ultra Wideband finden.
Und was ich so gesehen habe an Tests dazu, scheint das auch zu bestätigen.
Es reißt nicht mehr so ab und kannst da so wirklich aus 6, 7,
8 Metern irgendwie die Dinger genau lokalisieren.
Das kann schon behilflich sein, weil manchmal, als ich es mal wirklich so gebraucht
habe, war das dann doch immer schon ganz schön so rumgeeiert.
Also so, ja, irgendwo ist das hier, aber wo kann ich dir jetzt nicht sagen.
Und dann rennst du erstmal wie so ein Bekloppter, wie so ein Wünschelrutenläufer,
durch die Wohnung, um überhaupt erstmal so in den ja wo ist es denn nun zu kommen?
Und ja, dann sollte das jetzt mit den Neuen etwas einfacher gehen.
Wenn man so wie ich zwei Etagen hat, dann sagt er einem auch nicht, ist unter dir.
Sondern er gibt dir einen Pfeil sechs Meter in die Richtung,
Aber wenn es halt nur ein Meter in die Richtung ist, aber dann,
weiß ich nicht, so und so viele Meter unter dir, das nervt auch unglaublich. Aber ja, gut.
Wie ist denn mit der Batterielaufzeit? Kann man natürlich noch nichts zu sagen, ne?
Keine Ahnung. Also sie sagen, glaube ich, genauso wie vorher auch, wie ein Jahr.
Okay.
Da muss man immer so ein paar 2032 haben.
Ich habe so das Gefühl, dass ich inzwischen irgendwie nur noch die Großpackungen
von diesen Batterien kaufe und ständig die in diese AirTags reinsetze.
Es gab doch da eine Erklärung, warum die Eingebauten am Anfang so irre lang gehalten haben.
Also meiner irgendwie deutlich über eineinhalb Jahre. Und dann ist halt dann
doch irgendwann mal leer die Batterie und du tauschst sie aus gegen neu gekaufte,
frische und dann halten sie nur noch ein Dreivierteljahr. Und man denkt sich, warum das?
Und es gab irgendeinen Grund, den ich mal irgendwo nachgelesen hatte.
Aber schon wieder vergessen. Naja.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das so bestätigen kann. Also ich glaube,
bei mir haben die auch wirklich alle so nach einem Jahr schlapp gemacht.
Die Frage ist nur, wie schlapp sind die eigentlich wirklich,
wenn dir die App anzeigt, dass sie jetzt schlapp ist?
Du kriegst ja keinen Wert.
Vorher ist immer alles okay und dann so rot. Und dann habe ich auch mal eins
mal lange, lange, lange drin gelassen und das hat dann auch schon nochmal ein,
zwei, drei Monate gehalten.
Also ich glaube so dieser Threshold, ab dem sie dich warnen,
der ist doch sehr im Safe Space.
Also bei mir ist es so, dass ich die Batterien, die ich da raushole,
dann nochmal in anderen Geräten recycle.
Die halten zwar dann nicht mehr so lange in anderen Geräten,
aber sie tun noch ein bisschen.
Aha. Was hast du denn noch für Geräte mit der gleichen Batterie?
Na ja, so Smart Home Sachen wie Taster und Temperaturanzeige und so ein Gedöns.
Verstehe, die nicht regelmäßig funken.
Außerdem gibt es diese Knopfzellen ja in größer, in noch größer und ich habe
dann ein bisschen gesucht und habe mir dann einen Adapter gedruckt,
sodass man diese AirTag großen, wie heißen die, 2032?
Die größeren 30 irgendwas oder wie die heißen oder 25 irgendwas keine ahnung
dass man die da drin verwenden kann das ist ganz witzig,
Da ist so ein Plastikteil, da drückt man die Batterie rein und die ist dann
halt größer und dann passt sie genau in das andere Ding.
Ja, also ich weiß nicht, wie lange sie jetzt wirklich halten,
aber ich finde, die Nützlichkeit von diesen Teilen ist einfach bewiesen.
Mir hat das schon so viel Angst genommen, vor allem, aber ich habe auch schon
Dinge damit dann wiedergefunden.
Das ist schon ein echter Schritt nach vorne.
Die Mitgelieferten hatten keine Bitrex-Beschichtung.
Das ist eine Bittrex-Beschichtung.
Bittrex-Beschichtung.
Das weiß ich auch nicht.
Denatonium benzoat, sagt die Wikipedia. Bitterste bekannte Substanz.
Auf der Vorderseite der Knopfzelle befindet sich eine ringförmige Beschichtung
mit bitterem Bittrex-Geschmack, um das Verschlucken durch Babys und Kleinkindern zu verhindern.
Ach.
What do you know?
Ich muss zugeben, ich habe noch
keine Batterien abgeleckt. Oder sagen wir schon sehr lange nicht mehr.
Aha.
Okay, und es taucht auch sofort in Debatte mit AirTags auf. Also das scheint
in der Tat ein Thema zu sein.
Apple liefert Batterien aus, die nicht bitter schmecken.
Dafür können, hat man tote Babys.
Apple, was erlaube. Das ist ja quasi Sugarcoating.
Es sollten allerdings auch keine Knopfzellen mit Bittrex-Beschichtung zum Betrieb
von Airtex verwendet werden, wie Apple betont.
Okay, ist hier ein heiser Artikel.
Kann man die runterwaschen, die Bittrex-Beschichtung?
Ja, kann man. Das habe ich gerade auch schon gelesen. Man muss so viel schrubben,
aber es geht angeblich irgendwann. Gott, was ist das wieder für ein Rabbit Hole hier?
Ich glaube auch, ist das nicht sogar derselbe
Bitterstoff, der auch in so Nagelkaustopp-Tinkturen zum Einsatz kommt?
Kann durchaus sein.
Ja, ich bin gerade nicht ganz so sicher, aber dieser Bitterstoff,
der so superbitter ist, der kommt da durchaus zum Einsatz. Naja.
Ja, das zu den AirTags.
Und jetzt kommen wir zu der Zukunft. Vielleicht.
Die wir letzte Sendung angeteasert hatten und ist sie denn jetzt da, Tim, die Zukunft?
Ich weiß nicht, hatten wir das in der letzten Sendung oder in der vorletzten Sendung?
Ich glaube sogar vorletzte, oder?
Ich glaube auch. Vorletzte Sendung war das Thema, dass die Geschichte mit der Wunderbatterie,
von dem verhältnismäßig unbekannten Unternehmen Donut Labs aus Finnland,
die ja auch verbandelt sind mit dieser Motorradfirma aus Estland,
Virch Motorcycles und die ja angekündigt haben,
dass die neue Generation dieser Motorräder mit einer ganz neuen Batterie ausgestattet
werden und so ganz nebenbei ist die Batterie nicht nur sehr langlebig,
sondern angeblich eben auch die tollste Batterie aller Zeiten,
die alle Probleme auf diesem Planeten lösen wird.
Also wir erinnern uns, lädt super schnell bis 100 Prozent, irgendwie mit mehr
als 5C, hat eine unheimliche Energiedichte.
Zigtausend Ladezyklen.
Hunderttausend Ladezyklen, hält sozusagen bis in alle Ewigkeiten,
kann alle Temperaturen von minus 30 bis 100 Grad mühelos aushalten.
Ist auch noch super energiedicht, also 400 Wattstunden pro Kilogramm,
dichter sozusagen als jedes andere, ist safe, benutzt kein Lithium,
sinkt dir regelmäßig Geburtstagsständchen vor bei Bedarf, macht dir den Haushalt und so weiter.
Also sozusagen die absolute Super-Universal-Batterie und dann kam so das Internet
und vor allem dann auch so die ganze Batteriewelt und die haben gesagt so,
ihr habt es ja noch nicht alle irgendwie, ihr könnt doch hier nicht die Physik außer Kraft setzen,
wovon redet ihr überhaupt, wer seid ihr überhaupt, von euch haben wir ja noch nie was gehört.
Kann ja jeder kommen. Und auf einmal wollt ihr hier irgendwie die Batterie,
die man dann auch noch in jede beliebige Form und jede beliebige Spannung bringen kann.
Also die sozusagen alle Benchmarks, die derzeit so existieren,
so komplett in den Schatten stellt.
Und dann wollt ihr das irgendwie auch noch in ein paar Monaten ausliefern und
nicht nur jetzt Kohle einsammeln, damit ihr das vielleicht mal in fünf Jahren
habt, wie das alle anderen normalerweise machen, sondern ihr behauptet auch noch, ihr hättet das.
Und ja, der Verdikt war eigentlich relativ klar.
Alle meinten, Donut Labs ist doof und riecht nach Lulu.
Und das kann ja alles gar nicht wahr sein. Und dann haben sie sich halt irgendwie
Moller zerfetzt darüber, was sie denn dann nun vielleicht dann doch irgendwie
hinterhand haben könnte, wenn denn nun irgendwie was dran ist.
Und da wurde halt alles Mögliche von mit Siebdruck gedruckte Batterien bis irgendwie
Superkondensatoren und Pseudokondensatoren,
wo sozusagen alle Technikkonzepte, die derzeit so im Raum sind und die aber
bisher auch von niemandem noch so richtig in so eine Massenproduktion gebracht
werden konnten, wurden so in den Raum geschmissen.
Und was hat Donutlabs dazu gesagt? Gar nix.
Die haben jetzt erstmal alle reden lassen und dann haben sie letzte Woche irgendwie
ein neues Video rausgebracht unter dem Titel I Donut Believe.
Und dieser Marco, dieser CEO, der ja auch schon dieses erste Video mit angeführt
hat und da pompös diese ganzen Features in den Raum gekippt hat,
der so, ja, jetzt habt ihr euch ja alle schön das Maul zerrissen und meint,
das wäre ja alles nicht so und so,
aber wir sagen euch, das ist doch so und wir werden es euch jetzt beweisen und
jetzt machen wir hier so eine Videoseries und dann werden hier unabhängige Tester euch verkünden,
wie toll das alles ist. Das war so letzte Woche,
woraufhin dann natürlich auch wieder alle gesagt haben, ja, where's the proof,
da war ja wieder nur heiße Luft, wovon redet ihr überhaupt? und irgendwie,
ihr seid doof und das kann ja alles gar nicht sein.
Und ich will da gleich mal vorausstellen, es kann auch immer noch sein,
dass das alles nichts, dass das alles noch auffliegt.
Es beschreibt nur, was passiert gerade.
Und heute, wenige Stunden vor dieser Sendung, haben sie dann das erste angekündigte
Video rausgebracht, wo sie ...
Jemanden von VTT, das ist so ein staatlich getragenes Non-Profit-Prüfungsinstitut.
Technologie-Prüfungsinstitut in Finnland ist.
Und die haben halt von Donut den Auftrag bekommen, so hier, wir geben euch eine
Batterie in die Hand und ihr macht da jetzt mal Fast Charging damit.
Ja, das heißt, da lag also jetzt tatsächlich so eine Pouchzelle,
Also Pouchzelle nennt man, wenn das halt im Wesentlichen so ein flaches Teil ist,
so ein rechteckiges, flaches Zellteil.
Und dann haben sie dort eben Ladetests machen lassen von diesem Prüfungsunternehmen.
Und die haben das halt gemacht und auch dokumentiert.
Da gibt es jetzt auch so ein PDF, wo dann also genau diese Ladekurven drinstehen.
Das beweist jetzt erstmal nichts aus,
woraus diese Batterie besteht oder irgendwelche anderen der Behauptungen,
die sie so gemacht haben, kommen jetzt hier überhaupt gar nicht zur Sprache,
sondern es geht nur ums Fast Charging.
Dann haben sie erstmal diese Batterie genommen und haben sie irgendwie mit 1c geladen,
also mit dieser normalen Ladegeschwindigkeit und haben die Kurve so geplottet
und das Ding wieder entladen und nochmal geladen und zeigen halt,
wie sich das Ding so belädt und entladen lässt und dann eben auch, was die Kapazität ist,
was in dem Fall 26 Amperestunden ist.
Und du laden das mit 4,3 Volt und die normale Betriebsspannung ist irgendwie so 3,6 Volt oder so.
Und dann haben sie das Ding irgendwie mit 5C betankt und dann nochmal mit 11C.
Also das sind sozusagen extrem hohe Ladegeschwindigkeiten.
Also heutzutage die anderen Batterien, die erreichen so 3C, dann ist das schon irgendwie total irre.
Aber die haben einfach diese Batterie mit 5C und dann sogar mit 11C beladen,
beladen, womit das Ding halt irgendwie innerhalb weniger Minuten vollgeladen war.
Ja, und das gibt es jetzt als Video und als PDF mit Linien und Kurven und so.
Und das Irre ist, dass diese Zelle nicht, also erstmal nicht zusammengeklemmt werden muss.
Du hast heutzutage bei so Pouchzellen, musst du die normalerweise halt so fest
in so einen Harness irgendwie einpressen,
damit bei den Lade- und Entladevorgängen durch diese thermischen Entwicklungen
sich nicht irgendwie die Teile voneinander lösen und dass das irgendwie alles
gut beieinander bleibt. Das ist heutzutage so Standard.
Du kaufst ja deine prismatischen Zellen und dann tust du die in so einen Rahmen
rein und dann schraubst du die Dinger aber auch so mal so richtig amtlich zusammen,
damit da sich einfach nichts auseinander bewegen kann.
Und die haben die Zelle da einfach so rumliegen lassen und haben dann nur so
einen Alukühlkörper drunter gemacht,
haben beide Tests in so zwei Varianten gemacht, nämlich der einerseits oben
und unten haben sie diesen Körper so leicht mit so,
Schraubzwingen dran gemacht, ohne aber jetzt, wie sie sagen, nicht.
Auch so einen Druck, so ein Clamping zu machen, sondern nur damit die Dinger
halbwegs Kontakt haben mit der Oberfläche dieser Zelle.
Aber nicht, um sie wirklich zusammen zu pressen. Das ist einfach nur so ein leichtes Quetschen.
Und in der zweiten Variante haben sie dieselbe Batterie nur mit einem dieser Kühlkörper.
Da haben sie einfach nur die Zelle oben auf diesen Kühlkörper draufgelegt und
so ein bisschen mit Klebstoff, mit so einem Tesafilm irgendwie festgemacht,
damit es so halbwegs Kontakt hat.
Genau. Und dann sozusagen sowohl diese 5C als auch diese 11C-Ladegeschichte
mit diesen beiden Konstellationen gemacht und dann halt die Temperatur auch noch gemessen.
Und das Irre ist, dass die Batterie in der weniger gekühlten Variante am Anfang sogar schneller lädt.
Also offensichtlich bringt Temperatur diese Batterie erst noch so richtig auf die Spur.
Spielt aber am Ende alles gar keine Rolle.
Ohne, dass das Ding jetzt irgendwie massiv gekühlt werden muss,
kannst du sie mit einem sehr hohen Ladestrom beladen und auch entsprechend wieder entladen.
Und das ist das Einzige, was sie jetzt in diesem Video zeigen.
Und auf dieser Webseite, die sie dazu haben,
kannst du es auch noch so als PDF runterladen.
Die Zahlen, wenn man da reinguckt in diesen Bericht, die sind ja völlig absurd.
Also der 5C-Test mit 130 Ampere und der 11C-Test mit 286 Ampere.
Also da musst du die Kontakte schon gut festgeschraubt haben,
damit die nicht schmelzen.
Okay, gut, aber vielleicht macht man das so.
Also wenn das alles so stimmt, dann haben die da irgendwie Gold in der Hand.
Ja genau, also das ist halt das Ding, wo halt alle sich fragen,
kann denn das überhaupt wahr sein?
Und wir wissen noch nicht, ob das wahr ist.
Die treten da also wirklich mit breiter Brust auf und sagen einfach so,
ja, das ganze Internet meint, wir sind ein Scam.
Aber wir können euch sagen, it's not a scam and it will change the industry.
Das ist so ihr Bold Claim. Stellen Sie sich da hin und sagen so, ja, hier, guck mal.
Und heute zeigen wir euch Fast Charging. Und dann ist da jetzt so ein Counter
drauf, der läuft jetzt irgendwie eine Woche runter.
Und dann gibt es das nächste Video. Auch wenn noch nicht klar ist,
was jetzt als nächstes demonstriert wird und ob sie jetzt wirklich ein Feature
nach dem anderen immer im Wochenabstand präsentieren wollen oder ob sie das
Tempo ein bisschen anziehen,
weil eigentlich wollten sie ja im März.
Also jetzt quasi so ab in einer Woche, wollten sie irgendwie ausliefern.
Dann kann man auch sagen, okay, März, das kann auch Ende März sein,
geben wir den nochmal dazu.
Also wir haben jetzt quasi so fünf Wochen Zeit.
Keine Ahnung, was jetzt da als nächstes kommt, aber es ist halt so yeah,
also vielleicht wird es total peinlich für die,
vielleicht kommt da eine geile Batterie bei raus, weil wenn das halt irgendwie stimmt, was sie,
sagen und das dann auch endlich mal erklären was sie da haben und sie wirklich
in der Lage sind, diese Batterie auch in nennenswerten Stückzahlen zu produzieren,
dann ist die Welt eine andere.
Ja gut, dann muss man halt sagen, glaubt man jetzt, dass sie mit den VTT Technical
Research Center of Finland unter einer Decke stecken oder nicht?
Ich glaube eher nicht, weil wo waren die her?
Das ist ein sehr angesehenes, unabhängiges, staatlich finanziertes Institut.
Ich meine, das Einzige, wo man jetzt meckern kann, ist, das war jetzt quasi eine Beauftragung.
Die gehen da hin und sagen, ihr testet das jetzt mal für uns,
aber dieses Institut ist sozusagen unabhängig, staatlich getragen,
damit man da eben auch klare Aussagen machen kann.
Aber natürlich haben sie nur genau das getan, was Donut ihnen gesagt hat.
Die haben sich jetzt nicht an dieser Batterie gesessen und gesagt,
was kann man damit jetzt mal machen? Wir chargen die jetzt mal so, wir chargen die mal so.
Vielleicht gibt es irgendwelche anderen Szenarien, wo das so nicht funktioniert hätte.
Die haben jetzt nur genau das demonstriert, was von ihnen beauftragt wurde und
das haben sie dokumentiert und damit ist jetzt erstmal dieser Schritt abgeschlossen.
Naja gut, aber ich meine, dass Ihnen die Batterie bei 11c nicht um die Ohren
geflogen ist, ist ja überhaupt schon mal ein Ergebnis.
Also ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube die meisten Zellchemien würden 11c gar nicht
lustig finden und zumindest irgendwie das Qualmen anfangen.
Also das ist so, keine Ahnung, das spricht schon für sich, dass sie die mit
11c beladen und dann auch entsprechend schnell oder haben sie es entladen?
Ne, das haben sie nicht getestet danach.
Ne, es war nur Charging.
War nur Charging.
Das ist völlig absurde Kurven. Aber gut.
Sie haben auch eine Entladung.
Sie haben am Anfang einen Ladezyklus gemacht mit 24 Ampere.
Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wie viel das entspricht. Wahrscheinlich einem 1C oder 2C.
Also 2C, wenn du heutzutage ein Elektroauto hast, ist 2C ja quasi der Standard.
1,5 bis 2C im Maximum. Aber normalerweise stehst du halt eine halbe Stunde an
der Ladesäule, um von 20 auf 80 aufzuladen.
Das wäre dann so anderthalb bis zwei C.
Und ja, keine Ahnung.
Also das Entladen mit mehr als 1 C ist hier, glaube ich, nicht drin.
Nee, das ist hier nur Charging, Current.
Fast Charge, es ist nur Charging.
Ja gut, also ich meine, dass die jetzt 11C ausgehalten hat, die Zelle,
heißt ja nicht, dass du sie mit 11C benutzen kannst, weil du wirst sicherlich
nicht die Zelle 2000 Ladezyklus mit 11C machen können.
Also das glaube ich nicht, das will ich sehen.
Aber dass sie überhaupt 11C kann, finde ich schon sehr, sehr bemerkenswert, muss ich sagen.
Also ich frage mich so ein bisschen, was bezwecken die jetzt gerade so mit ihrer
PR und Kommunikationsstrategie?
Also sie jetzt mit diesem Häppchenweise und Hype. Ja, das ist mir schon klar.
Aber wenn sie da jetzt den heiligen Gral der Batterietechnik wirklich in den
Händen halten, dann bräuchten sie das doch eigentlich gar nicht.
Dann können sie doch ansonsten wen verkaufen für Milliarden und Abermilliarden.
Also wofür jetzt so diese Öffentlichkeitsarbeit drumherum?
Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht haben die da einfach Bock drauf.
Den Eindruck habe ich auch. Die finden das einfach keine Ahnung.
Okay gut, das ist zumindest mal plausibel.
Und haben so den Spaß ihres Lebens. Komm doch, wir gucken uns erst mal an, wie sich alle aufregen.
Und das, du musst dir das erste Video schon mal anschauen, das ist schon so
frech. Irgendwie so, ja, was hier.
Blenden sie ja da auch diese ganzen Internetkommentare an. Ja,
ja, das habe ich gesehen am Anfang. Und so weiter.
Und dann so, ja ne, wir sind aber kein Scam und jetzt zeigen wir es euch mal
richtig, ich finde das eigentlich wirklich also.
Wir bleiben gehen.
Wir mal davon aus, die Batterien gibt es und dann ist das einfach die geilste,
Produktintroduction ever also ich meine, da kann Apple ja echt einpacken.
Zumal dieser Tage.
Ja gut, dieser Tage kann Apple eh einpacken, aber sind wir uns auch einig, glaube ich.
Naja, also watch the space und ich bin sehr gespannt.
Vielleicht wird das ja noch was mit meinem Traum Motorrad, keine Ahnung.
Ja, die sollen sich mal beeilen. Ich habe so den Wagenplan, mir im Sommer mal
mein erstes Elektroauto zuzulegen.
Bis dahin muss das bitte schön serienreif sein.
Ja, nee.
Das bringe ich dann nochmal in irgendein andere. Oder gar kein Auto,
das ist zumindest so die Alternative. Aber mal gucken.
Alright, dann müssen wir mal über Linux reden.
Weil wir letztes Mal ja schon ganz viel über Linux geredet haben.
Wir werden heute aber nicht so viel über Linux reden, wie wir letztes Mal über
Linux geredet haben, oder? Fast zu viel.
Ich habe schon ein bisschen was zu erzählen.
Okay, gut. Ich zitiere mal einen Kommentar hier von ASDF.
Völlig platte Diskussion der Linux-Desktops. Aber was erwartet man?
Besonders schön die Schranke im Vergleich zur Diskussion ein paar Minuten vorher
zum Liquid-Glas-Desktop und den Mailbox etc. Bei Apple.
Echte Qualität, wie man sie von Fox News kennt.
Okay, also nach hinten raus wird es tatsächlich eine sachliche Diskussion.
Aber diese halbe Stunde dummes Geblöcke kann man sich doch einfach sparen.
Null Unterhaltungswert. Und zeigt einfach, wie er ja auch mehrfach eingesteht,
dass ihr euch mit aktuellem Linux einfach nicht auskennt.
Also das war ja so ein wiederkehrendes Meme in den Kommentaren.
Die Feststellung, dass wir uns mit aktuellem Linux nicht auskennen.
Ja, kennen wir nicht. Das war der ganze Punkt.
Wir haben gesagt, wie ist es denn, wenn man sozusagen jetzt mal das mit diesem Linux ausprobiert.
Wir sind ja kein Linux-Podcast und jetzt stellen wir euch irgendwie die geilste
Distribution mit dem geilsten Desktop und dem geilsten keine Ahnung was vor.
Sondern Ralf hat sich da etwas intensiver mit beschäftigt und mein Berührungspunkt mit Dinox ist so, ja,
ich benutze so ein paar Raspberry Pis, aber ehrlich gesagt viel Zeit in die
Konfiguration dieser Systeme stecke ich nicht. Ich benutze die auch nicht wirklich als Desktop.
Ich habe zwar einen bei mir auch an einem Monitor und kann dann irgendwie so
einen Desktop aufmachen.
Und da klicke ich ein bisschen drin rum und denke mir so, was soll das alles
und das war es dann im Wesentlichen.
Die Frage war, wenn man sich da jetzt mal intensiver mit beschäftigt,
stößt man dann so auf einen Füllhorn toller Erfahrungen und großartiger Erkenntnisse
und die Welt wird schöner.
Und ich würde sagen, wir haben so ein bisschen gezeigt, so ein bisschen schwierig.
Und deswegen ging meiner Auffassung nach viele Kommentare auch so ein bisschen
am Thema vorbei, weil es für mich ehrlich gesagt auch nur gezeigt hat,
was so ein bisschen das Problem ist.
Weil der Großteil der Antworten war, ja, ihr habt ja keine Ahnung und wenn man
sich auskennt, komm mal dann und dann kommt irgendwie so ein riesiger Absatz mit so Details,
mit ja, Distributionen hier und dann muss man ja nur da und wenn man dann irgendwie
diese Schraube hier da durchsteckt, dann kommt da hinten was Schönes mal raus.
Ja, that's the point. Das ist sozusagen der schwierige Teil.
Und auch dieses Argument mit, ja, aber ihr kennt euch ja mit macOS aus und ihr seid ja das gewohnt.
Und wenn ich das nicht gewohnt bin und ich habe ja auch mal Linux benutzt und
dann habe ich mal macOS ausprobiert und dann war ich das auch nicht gewohnt
und dann habe ich nichts wieder gefunden, was ich gerne haben möchte.
Ja, I know, das ist halt immer so.
Die Kernthese war einfach nur, Linux ist ein System, das ist halt einfach als
Körnel geschrieben worden. Und alles andere wächst da drauf.
Und diese ganze Idee mit den Distributionen hat sich halt so entwickelt,
aber das ist halt komplex.
Und wenn man sich dem als User im Sinne von, ich will jetzt einfach nur,
dass dieser Computer für mich da ist, nähert, dann verzweifelt man halt schon
allein an dieser Distributionsfrage.
Und es mag ja sein, dass ihr alle irgendwie alle Distributionen schon ausprobiert
habt und wisst, welche euch jetzt jeweils am besten gefällt.
Nicht, dass jetzt in den Kommentaren irgendein Konsens erzielt worden wäre,
welche das jetzt sei, sondern auch da gibt es ja tausend verschiedene Meinungen.
Genauso ist das auch mit diesem Desktop, was so ein bisschen das Synonym für User-Interface ist.
Während ich zum Beispiel versucht habe, so ein bisschen den Punkt mehr drauf
zu bringen mit Using ist jetzt nicht nur, wie es aussieht und Desktop,
sondern da steckt auch noch so ein bisschen Middleware dazwischen.
Und was genau diese Middleware ist, ist halt sehr schlecht definiert, weil da gibt es halt.
Ja, so ein bisschen wie mit Standards. Jeder sollte einen haben und dementsprechend
gibt es auch viele und man findet halt nicht ein konsistentes System,
auf dem dann möglichst viele Applikationen aufsetzen, sondern die einen verwenden
das, die anderen verwenden das und das ist ja auch okay so.
Ich meine, das kann ja alles so ein freier Wettbewerb sein und Linux ist halt
einfach ein System von Technikern im Wesentlichen für Techniker.
Ist ja auch kein Wunder, Linux ist ja super dominant.
Es beherrscht den Servermarkt, aber das ist halt der Markt, den es beherrscht.
Und es beherrscht nicht den Desktop-Markt. Man kann das da auch benutzen und
es ist mal ein interessantes Experiment, das auch zu machen.
Und das mag für erfahrene Unix-User auch ganz normal sein, sowas mit Linux aufzuziehen
und vielleicht gibt es da auch mehr als für irgendwie BSD-Systeme,
aber es ist halt einfach nicht von der Hand zu weisen, dass das eine komplexe Materie ist.
Das ist nicht mal so eben zu machen und die Auswahl an Big Apps ist halt überschaubar
und auch die Auswahl an Small Apps ist überschaubar.
Das ist auch nichts Schlechtes.
Ich sage da nicht, das ist jetzt total doof, Sondern ich sage einfach nur, das ist so.
Das ist weder gut noch schlecht, sondern es ist einfach so.
Und ja, das vielleicht mal so ein bisschen als Prolog aus meiner Perspektive
zum Feedback. Vielleicht fällt euch da ja auch noch was zu ein.
Dafür, dass du nicht viel zu Linux sagen wolltest, war das jetzt schon ein ziemlich langer Monolog.
Aber gut, Roddy, du noch einen Kommentar, bevor ich nochmal ein bisschen einsteige. oder?
Ich weiß nicht so genau, was ich dazu sagen soll. Also ich habe halt keine Anwendung für Linux.
Also wenn es um Server geht, benutze ich FreeBSD und wenn es um Desktop geht, benutze ich halt macOS.
Und das Linux ist so, das schaue ich mir halt alle paar Jahre mal an,
denke mir, ja, es ist immer noch bunt und es ist immer noch irgendwie, aber warum?
Und dann war es das wieder. Also ja, es bootet und es sieht aus,
aber es tut halt nichts für mich.
Okay, also ich versuche jetzt mal ein paar Brücken zu bauen hier.
In unserer kleinen Linux-Ecke.
Also vielleicht erst mal ein Disclaimer, was aber hoffentlich in der letzten
Sendung auch schon vielleicht klar geworden ist.
Für mich ganz persönlich ist das überhaupt keine Gaudi-Aktion und irgendwie höh, höh, höh.
Wir probieren mal und treten mal irgendwo gegen, sondern ich bin da schon auf
einer Mission unterwegs und ich bin auch nicht gewillt, die nach irgendwie ein
paar Enttäuschungen oder Fragezeichen irgendwie aufzugeben.
Beginnt bei meinen Kindern und aufhörend bei mir auf der Arbeit.
Der zweite Punkt, den man bei mir vielleicht auch einpreisen muss,
so wenn dann in den Kommentaren kommst, die ganzen Mac verseuchten so.
Also wie sieht denn mein täglicher Rechneralltag aus? Ich gucke pro Tag zwei
bis sechs Stunden auf Windows-Desktops, je nachdem wie viele Meetings ich so habe.
Du hast mein Beileid.
Und ich lebe noch. Bis hin zu,
dass manche Sachen da auch einfach besser funktionieren als unter macOS.
Da bin ich also recht emotionslos.
Ja, doch, ist so. Ich sage nur, ja, letzte Dateien.
Jehova.
Letzte Dateien.
Ich habe Jehova gesagt.
So, und dann habe ich bisher so im Schnitt pro Tag, weiß ich nicht,
drei bis vier Stunden auf macOS-Desktops gestarrt.
Start, sprich einfach Freizeitrechner.
So und jetzt bin ich halt hingegangen und habe von diesen drei bis vier Stunden,
zwei bis drei Stunden abgeknapst und starre stattdessen jetzt auf Linux-Desktops.
Das heißt, es vergeht also kein Tag,
an dem ich nicht wirklich alle drei Betriebssysteme parallel betreibe.
So, das kann man vielleicht auch erstmal mal so hinnehmen, wenn es heißt,
so hat immer von nichts eine Ahnung und so.
Also ich bin da wahrscheinlich doch ein bisschen breiter aufgestellt als die
meisten anderen da draußen.
So, ich würde Ich habe alle Kommentare gelesen und etliches davon war wirklich
hilfreich und ich komme gleich zu ein paar nächsten Eskalationsstufen,
die ich auf Grundlage der Kommentare zünden konnte, also vielen Dank schon mal dafür.
Ich möchte aber starten mit einem Kommentar, der finde ich an vielen Stellen
der beste war, weil er den Finger so auf so ein paar Punkte bei mir gelegt hat.
Und zwar von dev-urandom, was auch immer, wo sich der Name her leitet.
Naja, slash dev-urandom ist halt
ein Device auf Linux, was eine unsigned Integer-Random-Zahl generiert.
Ah, siehst du. Guck mal, gut, dass wir dich dabei haben.
Ja, das sind so viele geheimen Codes sozusagen. Daran erkennst du, I'm a real nerd.
Okay, gut, dann bin ich hier schon aus der Kurve geflogen, sei es drum.
So, er fängt an mit, ich hatte mich auf die Linux-Folge, die Ralf hier angekündigt hatte, gefreut.
Ich hatte mir eine positivere Einschätzung gewünscht, aber eine schlechtere erwartet.
Das ist ja schon immer der Moment, wo ich sage, alles richtig gemacht,
ist man ja schon mal ganz gut gelandet.
Aber einen echten Nerv hat er bei mir mit seinem Schlussstatement getroffen.
Ich finde, man sollte Linux als für sich stehend betrachten.
Ich denke, dass Ralf sich mit seinem Ansatz, den er hat, Power-User mit zu viel
Wissen um die Füße stillzuhalten,
aber zu wenig handfestem technischen Hintergrund, um manche Dinge selbst in
die Hand zu nehmen, zum Beispiel die absurde Idee an LLM um Hilfe beim Konfigurieren
helfen zu lassen, hier auch etwas selbst im Wege steht.
Vielleicht einfach mal Linux wirken lassen, statt direkt alles umzubauen.
Was bedeutet denn wirken lassen in dem Zusammenhang?
Ich komme gleich dazu.
Und von den Kommentaren gab es ein paar, die in die Richtung gegangen sind.
Nach dem Motto, was soll denn das mit diesem ganzen Umgeskinne und Austauschen von Schriften und so.
Es ist doch jetzt gerade mal so, dass man was anderes ausprobieren wollte.
Das würde ich ja auch nicht tun. Wenn der Desktop gut gebaut ist,
dann benutze ich ihn wie er ist und fertig.
Also ich finde es auch wirklich interessant, dass man auf der einen Seite ja
viel Spaß da am rumfrickeln hat, aber wenn jemand mal rumfrickeln will,
dann ist es irgendwie auch falsch.
Das ist auch wieder falsch, ja. Aber das habe ich ja eigentlich in der Sendung
selber schon abgeräumt, diese ganzen Experimente waren ja alle relativ fruchtlos.
Und der Plan war dann also schon, okay, ja, dann lassen wir halt Linux mal wirken.
Und es gab dann ja wirklich einen ganzen Zoo an Empfehlungen,
ja, du musst halt nur Distribution XY ausprobieren.
Also ich glaube 10 oder 12 wurden insgesamt genannt.
Und dann habe ich einen Kommentar gefunden von M.H.M.
Joe. Keine Ahnung, worauf das nun wiederum referenziert.
Tim, kannst du das auflösen? M.H.M. Joe.
Das hat, glaube ich, nichts mit Linux zu tun.
Wir können so ein Gesellschaftsspiel, so ist es random oder ist es ein Linux?
Für die Usernames mal durch. Ich kann auch noch mal was schreiben. Und zwar ventoy.net.
Was ist das denn? Ich hatte in der Sendung schon ein Framework vorgestellt,
mit dem man unter macOS, aber auch unter Windows sehr einfach sich so einen
Linux-Boot-USB-Stick bauen kann.
Und dieses Ventoy geht jetzt zwei, drei Schritte weiter.
Und zwar kann man dort auf einem einzigen USB-Stick beliebig viele Linux-Distributionen
nebeneinander platzieren.
Dann in dem Bootloader quasi sich entscheiden, welchen von denen möchte ich jetzt nehmen.
Also sprich, man wählt dann einfach Gibt es einen Random-Modus?
Plus Quiz so, in welchen Wo haben wir dich gerade reingebootet?
Linux für 300.
Man drückt beim Booten halt irgendwie F12 oder worauf auch immer die EDI-Taste
belegt ist, dass man halt in diesen Bootloader reinkommt Und kann dann sagen,
hier bute mal vom USB-C Stick und dann kann man sich das dort aussuchen.
Und man muss dafür nicht mehr machen, als einfach nur das ISO der jeweiligen
Distribution auf diesen Stick in einen Ordner reinschmeißen.
So und schon automagisch wird das Ganze einem beim Buten angezeigt und man kann
dort reinladen und das funktioniert dann deshalb ganz interessant,
weil die meisten Linux-Distributionen, das hatte ich so vorher auch nicht auf dem Schirm,
dann eben nicht direkt in einen Installationsmodus reinschalten und sagen,
so wähl mal deine Partition aus und ich mach mal alles andere Platz,
sondern die starten immer erstmal in so einem Demo-Modus.
Dass man also eine Distribution, ohne was installiert zu haben,
zur Laufzeit vom USB-Stick aus erstmal so ein bisschen antesten kann.
So und damit, das ist natürlich dann nicht ganz so performant,
wie wenn es von der internen Platte kommt und das mag noch die eine oder andere
Einschränkung haben, aber zum mal eben so reinschnuppern ist das schon mal gar nicht so verkehrt.
Und was Ventoil dann auch noch bietet, und da wird es dann doch ziemlich interessant,
ist eine Persistenzschicht.
Das heißt, man kann sich dann auf diesem Stick noch einen zweiten Ordner anlegen,
Persistency oder sowas, was jetzt aus dem Kopf wieder hieß, wo dann jede Distribution
auch noch einen Speicherbereich hat.
So dass wenn du dich dann also ins WLAN reinlädst oder irgendwelche Settings
umänderst oder auch mal das ein oder andere Programm runterlädst,
auch die Sachen bootresistent bleiben.
Das heißt also man kann dann, erscheint noch ein zweiter Eintrag dann im Boot
Screen und dann kann man sich also dann entscheiden, okay will ich jetzt hier
Mint nur im normalen Modus oder auch im Persistent Modus hochfahren.
So, und was habe ich dann also gemacht?
Ich habe mir einen dann doch ganz brauchbaren USB-Stick zugelegt,
USB-C, 256 GB und habe den mit einer toll von mir patentierten Funktion mit Klettband.
Ach, nicht doppelseitiges Klebeband.
Nein, mit Klett, ich mache mal diesen schönen Sound.
Doppelseitiges Klettband.
So, ich werfe euch mal Bilder in den Chat rein.
Da ist auch noch ein Pinguin draufgeklebt.
Da ist auch noch ein Pinguin draufgeklebt, ganz genau. Show, downtown.
Wir haben ihn schon verloren.
Ja, ich sag euch, das wird jetzt sehr anstrengend, die nächsten Sendung für euch.
So, also so sieht der Stick aus. Der ist ganz schön schnell.
Dafür, dass er irgendwie nur 40 Euro gekostet hat, kommt er also immerhin schon
mal auf, ich glaube, irgendwie so 600 MB pro Sekunde Schreiben lesen.
Damit läuft also jede Distribution schon ganz gut.
Da habe ich dann noch so ein fancy USB-C-Kabel mit so einem 90 Grad abknickenden Stecker dran gebaut.
Und hier sieht man das Ganze dann auf dem nächsten Bild, wie ich es vorne an
das Display dran pappe mit Kleppband.
Sodass man also dann immer, wenn man es mal braucht, sich dann einfach diesen
Stick dran pappen kann und dann
die ganzen Distributionen zum Ausprobieren parallel nebeneinander hat.
So und das Ergebnis alleine dieser einen Aktion ist, dass ich jetzt nebeneinander
teste Ubuntu 25, Elementary OS, Endeavor OS, Fedora KDE, KDE Neon, Sorin OS, Linux Mint.
So, das heißt also, das sind wie viel? 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 plus ein Achtes,
zu dem komme ich gleich noch.
Kein Pop-OS, was dir so empfohlen wurde?
Ja, jetzt hast du es schon ein bisschen gespoilert.
Ja, Entschuldigung.
Das ist nämlich, da komme ich gleich zu. Also Ziel ist es jetzt,
die leben jetzt alle friedlich nebeneinander auf diesem USB-Stick.
Und ich baue jetzt gerade so eine vereinheitliche Test-Suite,
in der ich versuche dann irgendwie in einer zentralen Tabelle mal ein bisschen
abzudecken, so was geht und was geht nicht.
Und wo entstehen da so die Probleme, um das für mich mal einfach so ein bisschen
sortiert zu kriegen, weil das kann sich ansonsten ja kein Mensch mehr merken.
Und da möchte ich aber eben beispielsweise solche Dimensionen drin haben,
wie eben dieses Fractional Scaling, über das wir in der letzten Sendung schon
ein bisschen gesprochen hatten.
Sprich, dass ich den Screen hochskalieren kann und nicht nur eine 1 zu 1 Abbildung habe,
sondern was eben auf High DPI, Bildschirm oder in der Apple-Welt würden wir
sagen Retina-Screens, kann das ja kein Mensch lesen, wenn das dann so winzig
klein ist, die Schrift, das muss man halt hochskalieren.
Das macht man auf Linux halt mit Fractional Scaling. Auch dafür habe ich irgendwie
schwer auf die Mütze bekommen, nach dem Motto, das ist doch alles Exoten-Kram
und du da mit deinen High-End-Rechnern und Normalsterbliche nutzen das doch nicht.
Ja, also als ich das erste Mal einen Linux auf einem Retina Display Mac ausprobiert habe,
da war nicht nur aus irgendeinem Grund das Display ganz unten links in der Ecke,
ein Textdisplay, es war lustigerweise auch ziemlich genauso groß wie die Escape-Taste.
Also man hatte so einen VGA-Screen-Inhalt in der Größe der Escape-Taste,
direkt über der Escape-Taste, sah super aus.
Naja, da gibt es halt ein Mittel und das ist halt Fractional Scaling,
läuft dann unter Wayland wieder anders als unter X11, wo das meistens einfach
nur hochgesoomt wird und dann wird der Text unscharf und alle solche Dimensionen so icht.
Selbst jetzt für die Laptops meiner beiden Kiddies, die ja nur 1080p können,
habe ich Fractional Scaling aktiviert, weil, eigentlich ist es wahrscheinlich
Quatsch, weil die viel bessere Augen haben als ich noch, aber trotzdem,
das ist einfach auf so einem 14 Zoll, ist das schon klein und fizzelig so.
Und ich dachte so, gerade für Kinder ist das eigentlich netter,
wenn die etwas größere Trefflächen haben und so.
Und der zweite Punkt ist, ich habe mal angefangen ein bisschen Statistik rauszusuchen,
was eigentlich im Jahr 2025 so an Monitoren und Laptops so im Windows-Segment verkauft worden ist.
Und da kommst du dazu, ungefähr 50 Prozent der Displays sind schon im Bereich von High DPI,
also so ab 1440 Vertikalzeilen und die willst du auf einem 14 Zoller nicht mehr
ohne irgendeinen Zoom-Faktor anzeigen.
Hot Take, ich finde, wenn selbst Windows ein Feature beherrscht,
dann ist es nicht zu viel verlangt, dass auch alle anderen Betriebssysteme das können.
Irgendwann auch mal können. Windows kann das in der Tat mittlerweile ganz gut.
Da kann man eigentlich nicht meckern.
Das kann ja sogar Windows.
Genau das. Ich finde, das ist ein Totschlag-Argument.
Und die Unterstützung unter Linux ist da eben sehr, sehr uneinheitlich.
Also KDE kann es grundsätzlich einen Tucken besser als so die ganzen Gnorm-Derivate,
aber auch auf Ubuntu Gnorm kriegt man das durchaus hin, aber da gibt es auch
immer einzelne Programme, wo es dann wieder nicht funkt.
So und sowas möchte ich alles mal ein bisschen systematisieren,
damit man sich da mal ein realistisches Bild machen kann.
So, also Testparcours. So, und bei dieser ganzen Testung bin ich dann aber dann
doch nochmal hängen geblieben.
Ihr erinnert euch noch an diese Test, diese Frage-Antwort-App,
die wir letztes Mal hatten?
Dieses Finde eine Distribution, die für dich passt.
Finde deine Distribution, ganz genau. Und auf,
Platz 1 war da, Tim hat es ja gerade eben schon gesagt, PopOS,
was auch ein paar Mal in den Kommentaren auftauchte.
Und wir haben uns da ja in der Sitzung, Sitzung sag ich schon,
in der letzten Sendung ein bisschen drüber lustig gemacht.
Der Name, da kann man sich schon mal lustig machen, finde ich.
Was für ein Name? Leute, was soll ich sagen? Wir haben dieser Distribution böse, böse Unrecht getan.
Das ist von allen, die ich bisher hier auf dem Stick hatte, und das sind ja
jetzt gar nicht mal so wenige, die mit Abstand geilste.
Dieses Teil ist interessant. So, und da möchte ich jetzt ein bisschen ausführen, warum das so ist.
Jetzt entfachst du wahrscheinlich den nächsten.
Zielmarke für Kommentare 200 für die nächste Sendung.
Und zwar möchte ich mal drei Dinge ins Feld führen, die ich an denen bemerkenswert
finde, warum ich schon so in so einem, ja aber es geht doch,
warum schaffen die anderen das nicht Modus irgendwie reinkommen.
Fractional Scaling läuft über alle Apps völlig schmerzfrei.
Das heißt also, egal was ich dort starte, der Text ist einfach mal knackscharf,
egal in welchem Zoom-Level ich habe.
Also da unten drunter haben sie ein Ubuntu, das ist ein LTS24.
Warum schafft Gnome das nicht auf quasi ihrem eigenen Heimatsystem,
wenn das so eine Bude, die glaube ich gar nicht so groß ist, was dahinter.
Kannst du mal kurz erklären, was du sagst mit, da ist ein LTS24 drunter? Was heißt das?
Also Ubuntu, so eine der großen Kerndistributionen, hat die Philosophie,
dass sie alle zwei Jahre eine Long-Term-Support-Version rausgeben.
Das sind die sogenannten LTS.
Also alle vier Versionen.
Alle vier.
Alle Halbjahre gibt es eine, ne?
Ja. Das ist, glaube ich, richtig.
Und dann alle zwei Jahre, beziehungsweise vier Versionen, ist eine Long-Term-Support-Version.
So, und da ist halt die Philosophie dahinter, wenn du halt irgendwie was Stabiles
suchst und keinen Stress haben willst, dann nimmst du halt lieber eine LTS-Version.
Die letzte ist jetzt halt die 24, die man halt nehmen kann.
Das heißt also, jetzt im April kommt die 26 raus, so denn alles gut geht.
Das heißt also kurz vor dem nächsten, was dann auch einer der Gründe war,
dass ich gesagt habe, ich nehme jetzt schon mal die von Oktober 2025,
also die 202510 habe ich bei mir überall drauf.
Ja doch, überall, so auf den Kinderrechnern und jetzt auch bei meinem noch als Hauptsystem.
Demnächst kommt also dann die 26 LTS von Ubuntu und PopOS baut da halt einen
Desktop oben drüber, so wie Gnome beispielsweise eben ein Desktop ist oder KDE.
Und das, was die haben, nennt sich also Cosmic Desktop und der ist jetzt relativ frisch.
Der ist also erst vor ein paar Monaten, glaube ich, jetzt wirklich so in einer
Release-Version rausgekommen. Und dem schrauben die schon relativ lange.
Und wie gesagt, das Erste, was der kann, ist Fractional Scaling.
Das Zweite, was der kann, ist runde Ecken. Überall.
Die gleichen Buttons. Überall.
Okay, runde Ecken ist jetzt...
Aber ihr wisst ja, das war so einer dieser Punkte, wo die Leute die Augen verdreht haben.
Ich finde, es ist mir völlig egal am Ende, welches Design ihr jetzt irgendwie
cool findet und passend.
Aber so ein bisschen Konsistenz wäre ja doch irgendwie ganz schön.
Apple hat es verkackt in der letzten Version.
Apple hat es auch schon.
Die Latte hängt da jetzt echt tief gerade. Und Popo, es springt da ziemlich
elegant rüber. Ich habe keine andere Distribution gesehen, die auch nur ansatzweise
so eine Konsistenz in der UX hatte.
Also es gibt noch so ein, zwei Ecken, über die ich stolpere,
aber selbst da kannst du mit einem Klick dann sagen, lass auch das hier jetzt
durch das normale Fenstermanagement quasi overriden und dann sieht auch das
konsistent aus. Also das ist schon mal ganz spannend.
Wenn die das hinkriegen, warum kriegen die anderen das eigentlich nicht hin?
Antwort wahrscheinlich Prioritäten, das interessiert sie halt nicht.
Aber das, was mich bis hierhin, würde ich sagen, das war aber alles irgendwie
so Pflicht. Aber jetzt kommt der interessante Part.
Ihr erinnert euch vielleicht, dass ich ja etwas hadere damit,
dass so in Sachen Bedienkonzepten überhaupt nichts mehr passiert,
was irgendwie so den Desktop angeht.
Und dass ich beispielsweise wahrscheinlich der einzige Mensch auf der ganzen
Welt bin, der Stage Manager auf macOS standardmäßig installiert hat.
Also diesen iPad-Fenster.
Wirklich?
Ja.
Das benutzt du?
Seit drei oder vier Jahren und ich liebe es.
Auf dem Mac?
Auf dem Mac, auf dem Laptop, ja. Du musst bedenken, es ist was anderes,
ob ich so einen riesen Screen ja hätte wie bei dir im Studio oder halt nur so einen Laptop-Screen.
Und für den Laptop-Screen finde ich diese Kombination aus, ich sehe immer,
was meine letzten fünf Programme waren, auch mit Vorschaufenster und nicht nur
irgendeinem abstrakten Icon.
Ich sehe live den Inhalt, wenn sich darin was ändert. Das heißt,
wenn ich irgendwo was aktualisiere und das an die Seite schicke,
behalte ich es trotzdem im Blick
und habe aber vorne immer Fokus auf eine einzige App zur gleichen Zeit.
Damit konnte ich sehr lange sehr gut leben. Das hat mich viel weniger gestresst
als so diese 50 Kaskaden von Fenstern hintereinander, die sich alle überlappen.
Und da muss man ständig hin und her schalten und gucken, wo war jetzt was und so.
Oder in Exposé reingehen und dann wieder suchen, welches 20 Fenster dort war
jetzt das, was ich haben wollte.
Also Stage Manager hat mich im Alltag ganz gut begleitet.
Aber ich dachte immer so, das ist jetzt auch schon echt lange her und was ist
denn da so das nächste große Ding und gibt es da nicht nochmal irgendwie schlauere Konzepte?
Und was soll ich sagen, ich habe das Licht gesehen.
Habt ihr schon mal Tiling ausprobiert?
Oder ist das überhaupt ein Begriff?
Naja, ich habe eine Vorstellung davon, was es sein könnte, was du jetzt meinst.
Also, was ist Tiling? Der Vorteil ist jetzt glaube ich mal für die Hörerinnen.
Soll ich erst mal raten? Ja, ja, rate mal.
Genau.
Also unter Tiling verstehe ich halt einfach so die Aufsplittung des Bildschirms in Tiles.
Wo man halt einfach Programme, so ein Rechteck zuweist und alle stoßen direkt
aneinander und nichts überlappt, sondern es spaltet sich halt einfach so auf.
Ja, genau.
So wie Tiles halt, also so wie Fliesen ebenso.
Ich benutze das nicht, aber gut.
Ja, also lustig ist, Tim, du hast es heute schon erwähnt und reingeworfen.
Hier dieses Moom-Tool, was du gefeatured hast, das versucht sowas.
Ich habe es gerade eben mal schnell runterinstalliert und muss dem sicherlich
noch eine Chance geben und muss nochmal gucken.
Aber ich glaube, das ist nicht so zu Ende gedacht, wie PopOS das tut.
Also wieder Disclaimer, ich weiß, es gibt auch andere Distros,
die Tiling unterstützen und beherrschen.
Ich glaube im KDE gibt es auch so ein, zwei Derivate.
Es scheint aber nach meiner etwas oberflächlichen, aber doch Recherche so zu sein, dass Popo ist,
das am stringentesten und weitesten treibt das ganze Prinzip und von daher bin
ich da jetzt glaube ich nicht so schlecht aufgestellt, das mal intensiver zu gucken.
Also was macht dieses Tiling?
Der Unterschied zu dem, wie beispielsweise Apple das interpretiert,
da kannst du ja auch sagen, so schicke diese App jetzt in die linke Hälfte des
Screens und die andere in die rechte Hälfte des Screens.
Der Grundgedanke von Tiling bei PopOS ist, alle Fenster müssen sich ihren Platz teilen.
Und du musst selber aber gar nichts dafür tun, sondern das passiert automagisch.
Das heißt, wenn du eine App nur gestartet hast, hat die den ganzen Screen.
Du startest die nächste App.
Die erste App kriegt nur noch die Hälfte des Screens. Die andere Hälfte des
Screens kriegt die zweite App.
Du startest die dritte App, eine, nämlich meistens die erste,
die du als erst gestartet hast, teilt sich horizontal in der Hälfte durch und
teilt sich den Platz mit der dritten App und so weiter.
Das heißt also, je mehr App du startest, desto mehr quasi teilen sich diese
Teils auf, aber eben nicht so, dass du vorher irgendeinen Raster vorgibst und
sagst so, du bist jetzt immer links und du bist irgendwie rechts,
sondern das ist also ein hochdynamischer Prozess.
Du kannst aber, die Philosophie ist, dass das Ganze komplett tastaturgesteuert
ist, kannst du jederzeit eingreifen und sagen, ja, das war eine nette Idee,
ich will es aber jetzt doch gerade anders haben.
Und es geht also einfach nur mit der Windows-Taste jetzt in dem Fall hier,
auf Mac wäre es dann Command, aber da gibt es das, glaube ich,
so einfach mal schlicht nicht.
Also sprich Windows-Taste und dann die Pfeiltasten. Und dann kannst du also
sowohl sagen, so was ist jetzt eigentlich gerade mein aktives Fenster,
als auch das aktive Fenster dann wiederum mit Shift als Modifier woanders hinschicken
und sagen, nee, du kriegst jetzt die linke Hälfte.
So und die anderen beiden sollen sich in der Mitte durchteilen.
Und das ist erstmal ein bisschen anstrengend, weil man halt...
Von den bisherigen Konzepten sich verabschieden muss, dass alles so seinen klaren Platz hat.
Ständig können sich die Dinge ein bisschen ändern, aber du kannst es auch sehr
schnell wieder korrigieren.
Und der zweite Faktor, der reinspielt, ist, dass du halt noch sogenannte Workspaces hast.
Das ist das, was wir von macOS auch kennen. Diese Spaces, die ich persönlich
zum Beispiel exakt nie genutzt habe für irgendwas, um irgendwie so Apps zu orchestrieren.
Das macht jetzt plötzlich im Pop-OS auch mehr Sinn, weil du auch mit einem Shortcut
jedes App-Fenster auf einen der Arbeitsflächen der Workplaces hinschicken kannst
und sagen, nee, dich will ich hier gar nicht haben, du hau mal ab.
Und der letzte Shortcut, den man noch braucht, ist die gerade aktive App mit
Windows M quasi in Fullscreen nach vorne holen und auch wieder zurückschicken
können an den Ort, wo sie hergekommen ist.
Und diese Kombination von Tools komplett nur über die Tastatur,
du brauchst überhaupt nicht die Maus dafür und hast trotzdem vom App-Starten
her, quasi mit so einem Quick-App-Starter,
kannst du dir, also auch das Wechseln zwischen den Workplaces läuft auch nur
über die Tastatur, das ist dann quasi Windows rauf, runter.
Innerhalb von Minuten kommst du da so in so einen Flow rein, der saukool ist.
Ich muss noch gucken, wann so richtig das Muscle Memory reinkickt,
aber ich glaube, ich bin kurz davor nach drei Tagen.
Und das ist das Coolste, was ich seit langer Zeit irgendwie so an Computer Experience
hatte, weil es so eine Präzision hat.
Wir kommen hinterher noch irgendwie dazu, wenn es so um Taster und Schalter
geht. Das hat so eine Präzision von so einem Bankterminal.
Plötzlich ist alles so robust und klar irgendwo verortet und du kannst es exakt
irgendwie so haben, wie du es möchtest.
Und alles nur über super schnelle Tastatur-Shortcuts.
Keine Animation, nichts fließt irgendwo, sondern es ist also richtig metallisch
scharf und schnell und präzise das Ganze und du denkst dir nur so, oah, cool.
Beispielsweise jetzt die Vorbereitung für die Sendung habe ich in diesem Modus
gemacht und hatte jetzt also auf der linken Seite unsere Notizen und in der
rechten Seite habe ich dann also ständig die.
Einzelnen Teils quasi hin und her geschaltet, so will ich jetzt gerade was im
Internet recherchieren oder frage ich noch irgendwie eine LLM und alles machst
du super schnell und effizient über die Tastatur.
So und wem das noch nicht genug ist, der kann auch den absoluten Nerd und Profi
Modus aktivieren und sagen so, dein einzelnes Teil kann auch Tabs haben und
in diese Tabs kannst du wiederum beliebige Programme reinschieben.
Das heißt also, stell dir vor, du hättest also jetzt den Apple Finder,
der kann ja auch Tabs oder Safari oder alle Browser können Tabs,
ja, nur dass du dann nicht nur Tabs derselben Programmes dort reinhängen kannst
und auch andere Programme.
Und die kannst du auch mit der Tastatur ganz einfach durchschalten.
Das heißt, du kannst auch sagen, das ist mir alles zu hektisch,
dass sie sich ständig den Platz gegenseitig wegnehmen.
Ich will nur zwei große Bereiche haben. Der linke ist mein Main-Arbeitsbereich
und rechts hast du dann alle anderen Programme, aber über Tabs direkt quasi
mit einer Taste durchschaltbar.
Kannst du mir mal drei oder vier Beispiele nennen von Programmen,
die dann in diesen Teils dann so laufen, wenn du sie benutzt?
Alle.
Nein, nicht alle. Welche? Welche konkret? Welche Programme laufen in diesen
Teils? Was rufst du da auf?
Also was habe ich?
Welche Programme? Reden wir vom Terminal?
Also wir reden natürlich vom Terminal, wir sind auf Linux. Ich rede von Signal,
ich rede von meinem Passwortmanager Bitwarden.
Ich habe einen Browser. Ich habe die Apple-Notizen als Web-App installiert, weil es ja kein Apple.
Ich habe Cursor. Ich habe meine Open-Router-Instanz als Web-App installiert.
Und ich habe mein Chat-GPT-Fenster. Ich habe die Settings. Ich habe das Filesystem.
Da sind sie, glaube ich, zehn. Und die habe ich aufgeteilt jetzt im Moment auf vier Workplaces.
Okay, also das sind alles, ich sag mal, Programme mit eher,
unter komplexen User-Interfaces.
Also auf jeden Fall sind die alle so, dass sie sich dynamisch halt mit wenig
Platz auch gut zufrieden geben.
Die haben fast alle ein gutes, responsives Design.
Darauf halte ich nämlich hinaus. Also es sind sozusagen alles Programme,
die leicht raumeingeschränkt funktionieren können.
Der Chat macht dann einfach, nicht die Seitenleiste weg.
Textumbruch und so weiter blendet vielleicht nochmal was aus, wenn es dann zu eng wird.
Terminal ist ja genau das gleiche Ding. Das Web funktioniert ohnehin so,
dass man das Fenster so klein machen kann.
Das ist ja etwas, womit das Web schon immer gearbeitet hat und dann passen sich
halt die Webseiten mehr oder weniger gut an.
Aber es ist jetzt kein einziges Programm dabei wie Photoshop oder so.
Wo du so Paletten, Raumaufteilung hast wo sozusagen der raum auch irgendwie
genutzt wird meine these wäre jetzt ein bisschen es gibt schon apps die,
So eine permanente Einschränkung des Spaces so nicht überleben.
Also dann kannst du damit nichts anfangen.
Es gibt einfach Programme, die wollen den Bildschirm haben oder zumindest einen
festen Bereich präsentieren und brauchen auch so ein bisschen so eine Mindestfläche
und sind nicht unbedingt dafür geeignet,
jetzt die ganze Zeit dynamisch in so einen super variablen Raum eingesperrt
zu werden, der sich permanent ändert.
Genau, das ist so. Die schickst du dann aber halt mit einem Tastatur-Shortcut
auf einen eigenen Workspace und lässt sie da in Frieden in Fullscreen laufen.
Verstehe.
Wenn du dann Drag & Drop beispielsweise brauchst dazu, gehst du hin und sagst so,
kurzfristig schicke ich jetzt mal den Finder daneben,
dann teilen die sich das mal eben 50-50, ich ziehe die Datei rüber und danach
schicke ich den Finder einfach wieder zurück und die Photoshop,
was auch immer, gibt es natürlich nicht, Gimp, das Pendant hat danach wieder
den kompletten Platz für sich.
Du musst halt nicht mit diesem ständig so, wo ist jetzt welches Fenster,
sondern dein Gehirn, also zumindest meins,
hat sich da relativ schnell reingegroovt, so die Vorteile von,
ich kann Dinge sehr schnell nebeneinander stellen, aber auch sofort wieder wegschicken,
ohne die ganze Zeit halt irgendwie die Maus schubsen zu müssen.
Mir kommt da noch sehr entgegen, dass ich diese Trackpads halt scheiße finde von Lenovo.
Die Tastaturen sind auch scheiße, aber dann hat man zumindest nur ein Übel,
mit dem man sich irgendwie so abkämpfen muss.
Was ist denn da so scheiße dran?
Also erstmal, Claudia hat es auch gesagt, weil die jetzt auch häufig an den
Laptops zu den Kindern ist.
Es ist jetzt nicht nur ein Ding von mir, sie sagte auch nur meine Güte,
wenn man von einem MacBook kommt, ist das schon eine Strafe irgendwie und dafür,
dass sie die Novos so einen guten Ruf haben, finde ich das schon ein bisschen schrill.
Aber was kann man denn einem Trackpad falsch machen?
Das ist jetzt ein bisschen eine naive Frage, oder? Also erstmal sind die viel kleiner.
Nein, wieso? Ich meine, ein Trackpad ist doch einfach nur so ein XY-Bereich.
Aber du weißt doch beispielsweise, dass die von Apple aus Glas sind.
Die haben eine Glasoberfläche, nicht so eine Bioplastik-Oberfläche.
Dann weißt du, dass sie so eine Taptic-Engine drunter haben und nicht wirklich
irgendwie runtergeklickt werden.
Die von Lenovo, zumindest jetzt hier von meinen Geräten, werden physisch real
noch einfach runtergedrückt.
Oh, wirklich? Das ist bemerkenswert. Ich dachte, das ist, ja okay.
Nee, das ist nicht Standard. Und wenn ihr jetzt wieder kommt,
so ja, ich habe auch ein sehr, sehr teures Lenovo, das ist nämlich mein Arbeitswindows-Gerät,
was ich von der Arbeit habe.
Das hat, glaube ich, irgendwie 1800 Euro gekostet.
Irgendwie viel zu teuer eigentlich, aber nun ist es mal da.
So, da ist es ein bisschen besser, aber geil ist es auch nicht.
Wenn ich das vergleiche, dass ich für 999 Euro einen Air kriege,
mit einem fantastischen Trackpad, ist das schon so ein Punkt,
wo ich frage so, hallo, nicht Apple-Welt, was macht ihr da im Jahr 2026?
Das ist eine gute Frage, Ralf.
Aber das macht ja das Tiling nicht schlechter. Also im Gegensatz,
es ist halt eben eine Befreiung, nicht auf diesem Trackpad irgendwie rummurksen
zu müssen, sondern wirklich alles halt über Shortcuts einfach regeln zu können.
Und mag sein, dass es gerade ein bisschen Honeymoon ist und dass ich das irgendwie,
nach einer Woche dann doch wieder nervig finde, aber im Moment ist es so,
dass geilste, hey, da hat mal jemand konsequent so eine Idee wirklich mal zu
Ende gedacht, Moment, den ich seit Jahren hatte und das habe ich Popo es zu verdanken.
Okay, ich will da mal was zu sagen, weil,
Okay, gut, kann man so machen. Ich hätte, glaube ich, mit vielen Programmen,
die ich so benutze, dann schon eher so dieses Problem, dass die sich nicht unbedingt
alle so den Raum einfach jederzeit einschränken lassen.
Aber sagen wir mal, man benutzt halt die Programme so.
Ist ja jetzt aber auch nicht so, ich will jetzt gar nicht so eine Mac versus
Linux Sache aufkommen lassen, aber ich finde jetzt diese Feststellung,
man könnte jetzt zum Beispiel mit den Spaces nicht gut arbeiten,
auf dem Mac finde ich eigentlich auch falsch.
Also das mache ich die ganze Zeit.
Wie kriegst du ein Fenster von einem Space mal in den anderen, wenn du musst?
Ich ziehe es da hin?
Genau, du ziehst es da hin. Du musst es also erstmal greifen,
Dann musst du darauf achten, dass es dir bloß nicht weghaut.
Dann musst du nach oben an die Oberkante damit, musst warten,
bis ich das aufgebaut hast, musst mit den kleinen Thumbnails gucken,
wo will ich denn jetzt eigentlich hin?
Und dann musst du es dort reinsetzen und dann musst du es am Zielort noch an
die richtige Stelle schieben.
Ja, ich weiß, was du meinst. Ich benutze das aber gar nicht so.
Also für mich ist dieses Space, ist es halt sozusagen die Fullscreen-World.
Also du erzeugst ja diesen Space in dem Moment, wo du so ein Programm Fullscreen machst,
kriegt es seinen eigenen Space und dann kann ich irgendwie so mit vier Fingern
nach oben und sehe irgendwie alle meine,
Spaces sozusagen auf den ersten Blick, kann die anklicken, kann da schnell irgendwie
mit Control Cursor hin und her und das geht auch alles super fix und ich weiß
überhaupt nicht, was das Problem ist. Also das ist eine reine,
Frage, wie gut der eigene Workflow letzten Endes dazu passt.
Wenn du mit diesem Stage Manager gut klarkommst, ich weiß nicht,
bei mir funktioniert das zum Beispiel nicht.
Insofern gibt es ja da auch verschiedenste Möglichkeiten.
Aber mach ruhig weiter, wir wollen jetzt nicht über MacOS reden.
Also das war jetzt auch schon fast so der aktuelle,
Forschungsstand. Also Tiling, Daumen hoch. Ich gucke mal, ob sich das festtritt
oder ob dann doch irgendwo auch noch mit starke Nachteile um die Ohren fliegen.
Also beispielsweise musst du natürlich das Problem lösen, welches Fenster ist
denn eigentlich gerade aktiv, wenn du irgendwie fünf oder sechs Fenster bei dir hast.
Und das, was der Pop-OS macht, ist halt, dass dann ein einstellbarer,
konfigurierbarer, bunter Rahmen dann um das gerade aktive Fenster rumgezeichnet wird.
Darum muss man sich auch erst mal ein bisschen gewöhnen. So funktioniert das
aber, finde ich, auch ganz gut.
Also ich finde das so vom UX-Konzept her ist das echt gut implementiert.
Also wenn ihr mal was Neues erleben wollt, probiert das mal aus.
Man muss es lustigerweise irgendwie wirklich erstmal finden und aktivieren.
Das ist also nicht der Standardmodus, der bei Pop-OS irgendwie eingeschaltet ist.
Das trauen sie sich offensichtlich noch nicht. Man muss es also dann erstmal
über die Settings einmal als Standard setzen und auch würde ich den Standard
bringen, so jedes neue Fenster hält sich sofort dran.
Du kannst auch einzelne Fenster davon komplett ausschließen.
Du kannst auch sagen, so dieses Programm wird nie im Tiling-Modus gestartet,
sondern hängt dann immer als Floating nochmal oben drüber. Also auch die Flexibilität hast du.
Also das ist schon alles gut durchdacht.
Daumen hoch erstmal dafür. Pop-OS.
Und,
Nochmal zurückkommt auf dieses Feedback, gibt Linux hier auch mal eine Chance.
Wie gesagt, ich habe da wirklich ein bisschen, genau, das Video,
was du hier geschickt hast, das ist gut. Damit habe ich es quasi gelernt.
Da kann man sich das so in 20, 30 Minuten, erklärt der Bursche mal,
wie die verschiedenen Features sind.
Und das Einzige, was er nicht zeigt, weil es zu dem Zeitpunkt,
als er das Video gemacht hat, glaube ich, noch nicht released war,
ist der Shortcut, wie man einzelne Fenster in andere Workplaces reinschiebt einfach so.
Das fehlte in dem Video, aber müsst ihr einfach nur gucken, dass es dann Windows,
Shift und dann die Taste, also die Zahl des Workplaces, auf dem man das Ganze
haben will und dann ist es sofort darüber geschoben.
So, dieses so, gib doch Linux mal eine Chance und häng dich immer so an deinen macOS-Vorgaben.
Das habe ich auf zwei anderen Ebenen noch beherzigt und bin damit auch ganz glücklich drauf.
Das erste ist, ich habe nicht mehr die San Francisco-Schrift drauf,
sondern jetzt die Noto-Schrift.
Um dort auch ein bisschen Abstand zu schaffen. Noto ist ja so ein...
Drauf wo?
Auf all meinen Linux-Kisten hier.
Wo man es dann irgendwie einigermaßen konsistent einstellen kann.
Also selbst da schwächeln etliche...
Auf deinem ganzen Stick sind es endlich.
Auf meinen Stick, genau. So, da gehe ich jetzt also nicht mehr hin und hole
mir da irgendwie von GitHub die San Francisco, sondern meistens ist die Noto auch auswählbar.
Und das ist eine sehr schöne Open-Source-Schrift. Ist von Google.
Ist ein bisschen uncool, dass sie von Google ist, aber in 800 Sprachen verfügbar
und alle Zeichen der Welt sind da gut abgebildet und das ist einfach eine sehr
geschmackvolle, saubere, nüchterne Schrift.
Also die kann man gut ausprobieren, wenn man es nicht mit diesem Apple-Universum
hat und trotzdem beispielsweise, wie ich große Schmerzen mit der Gnome-Schrift
hatte, hatten wir letztes Mal mit dem Front, komme ich einfach nicht klar.
Also dann nochmal in die Note reinschauen, dann muss man es trotzdem nicht wie bei Apple haben.
Und das Letzte, was ich jetzt auch ausprobiere, ist konsequent Dark Theme-Modus
fahren, um also auch möglichst viel Kontrast wirklich zu meinem Mac zu haben.
Das heißt also bei mir jetzt auf meinen Linux-Distros ist immer alles schwarz
und auf meinem Mac ist alles weiß.
Dann weiß man gleich, man ist in einer komplett anderen Welt unterwegs.
Und ich glaube, da steckt schon was hinter, dass man ein bisschen Abstand und
ein bisschen Kontrast irgendwie braucht, um überhaupt irgendwie sich für neue
Varianten ein bisschen stärker zu öffnen.
Das probiere ich jetzt damit aus. Naja, und ein Kommentar kam noch,
den fand ich auch ganz treffend.
Das ist ja nicht so, dass das jetzt bei uns in der macOS-Welt auch alles irgendwie
so super einfach und konsistent wäre.
Und ich hatte ja das Beispiel, Programme installieren.
Und das ist natürlich auf macOS halt auch schon ein bisschen weird.
Da hast du halt auch die Varianten. Naja, du hast entweder den Store,
da ist aber kaum was drin.
Da hast du es natürlich mit einer Einglick-Install. Aber ansonsten musst du
dann halt irgendwie erst mal so ein Container-Ding sie runterladen.
Disk-Image.
Genau, und dann musst du das irgendwie starten und dann musst du irgendwie was
in so einem Fenster, was aufpoppt, von A nach B rüberziehen und so.
Und dann gibt es nochmal welche.
Kopierst das in deinen Applications-Ordner. Ja, das ist die Installation.
Ja, also ich weiß nicht, keine Ahnung.
Dann gibt es noch Installer-Programme. Also da kann ich schon nachvollziehen,
dass wenn du halt irgendwie von einem anderen System kommst,
dass dir sowas dann auch ein bisschen befremdlich vorkommt.
Kann ich schon nachvollziehen. Windows-Style-Installer, das ist immer ein bisschen schwierig.
Also wenn es einfach nur ein Programm ist, dann hat die Firma,
die das Software gemacht hat, schon mal einen schlechten Stand,
dann machen sie irgendwas falsch.
Was meinst du mit Windows-Style-Installer?
Naja, wo du dann irgendein Installationsprogramm anklickst und dann geht da
so ein Fenster auf und dann muss man da Dinge durchklicken.
Das ist okay für Kernel Extensions oder irgendwelchen anderen Kram,
der wirklich jetzt etwas an wichtige Stellen muss, aber auch das wird ja weniger,
sondern eigentlich ist ja das der Normalfall,
du hast einen Application Bundle, da ist alles drin und das schmeißt du dann
in deine Applications und damit ist die Installation fertig.
Also kein Installer rotzt dir das System voll.
Ich meine bei Windows ist halt eine niedrige Hürde, wie ich bereits sagte,
wenn selbst Windows etwas besser kann, aber das können sie halt gar nicht.
Und es gibt halt so einige wenige Firmen, die bauen dann Software so,
dass du halt unbedingt einen Installer brauchst.
Und das ist halt, das geht halt eigentlich nicht.
Ja, kann man machen.
Ich weiß auch nicht mehr, wozu das jetzt überhaupt noch gut sein soll.
Also im Prinzip so diese, also ein Installer, es gibt ja den Apple Installer,
wo ja dann diese Packages eigentlich drin geöffnet werden.
Also eigentlich ist es ja ein Install Package, was dann im Standard Apple Installer,
den es ja schon lange gab, gestartet wurde.
Das haben auch nicht alle unbedingt alle Programme immer gemacht.
Also viele hatten so einen eigenen Installer.
Das habe ich jetzt schon lange nicht mehr gesehen. Das gibt es hier und da noch.
Irgendwie so mein Scansnap irgendwie hat noch so einen Scheiß und so.
Ich glaube Fusion hatte das auch.
AutoCut Fusion. Aber du hast recht. Manchmal ist es halt Disk-Image.
Dann wird das Programm als Zip ausgeliefert.
Ich meine, am Ende ist es eigentlich eh nur das Ding.
Und dass es immer noch keinen definierten Weg gibt,
wo man speziell aus dem Web heraus so einen Installationsvorgang in einer einheitlichen
Art und Weise durchführen kann, das ist in der Tat echt eine große Lücke vom
App Store mal ganz abgesehen.
Also eine Stichwort Installation.
Es gibt dann auch auf PopOS dann natürlich relativ schnell irgendwie so die
wackelige Wand, die irgendwie einklappt, wenn du irgendwie gegen hustest.
Und was ich gerade gestern hatte, du hast dann auch im PopOS dann den obligatorischen
App Store, den irgendwie jede Distribution halt irgendwie so mit sich bringt.
Wo du dann richtig klick mich bunty, schön suchen kannst und hast vernünftig
deine Kategorien, so wie die jetzt halt alle einfach so sind.
Und das, was du, Tim, letztes Mal gesagt hast, das fand ich dann ein bisschen
polemisch, da hätte ich eigentlich in der Sendung schon reingrätschen müssen.
Die sind ganz schön voll, dieses Tors. Ja, wenn du die startest,
dann starten, sind da erstmal häufig dieselben sechs Apps zu sehen,
aber dahinter sind schon noch ein paar tausend andere.
Und alles große und bekannte findet man da eigentlich, wofür es halt irgendwo
Dienungsversionen gibt.
Wenn ich jetzt aus diesem Store mit dieser schönen Klick mich bunty Oberfläche auf Download gehe,
um Thunderbird zu installieren, so den großen bekannten Mail Open Source Programm
und es dann die Distro nicht schafft, das so zu installieren,
dass es unten in meiner Dockleiste, die ich nicht konfiguriert und kaputt gespielt
habe, sondern die einfach nur out of the box geschaltet war,
dass es dort mit dem richtigen Thunderbird Icon erscheint und nicht mit einem
Zahnrad Icon. Wo Thunderbird drüber steht.
Und ich als zweites nicht die Möglichkeit habe, mit der rechten Maustasse drauf
zu klicken und zu sagen, so pin diese App jetzt hier im Dock an,
damit ich da immer schnell drankomme.
Das finde ich schon schwach.
Und das ist eine Ebene.
Da sind wir wieder bei, wenn selbst Microsoft mit Windows das hinkriegt.
So, das ist dann eine Ebene, da fehlt mir dann auch echt ein bisschen die Geduld und die Nachsicht.
Wenn also die basalste Klickstrecke, ich möchte aus dem offiziellen Store,
nicht von der Kommandozeile oder sonst was, da kann ich das alles nachvollziehen,
aber aus dem offiziellen Store will ich doch bitteschön einen Workflow haben,
dass ich das Viech dann danach auch irgendwie in dem Dock, was dafür vorgesehen
ist, vernünftig anschauen und starten und festpinnen kann.
Also das ist das ist halt echt irgendwie wie fractional scaling,
also sowas muss im Jahr 2026 einfach funktionieren naja, ich sammle jetzt solche
pain points und mal gucken, vielleicht verstehe ich, mag sein,
dass alles you're holding it wrong ist,
aber you're.
Expecting it wrong wahrscheinlich eher.
Das finde ich jetzt echt nicht zu viel verlangt, dass wenn ich eine App installiere,
ich die auch sehe und finde und die so aussieht wie im Store Nun gut, wir bleiben dran.
Ich bleibe bei meinem Windows-Low-Bar-Expectation-Kriterium.
Wenn selbst Windows das hinkriegt, dann muss das gehen.
Vielleicht findet man auch bei macOS etwas, wo man sagen würde,
wenn selbst Windows das hinkriegt, dann muss das auch bei macOS gehen. Ich weiß es nicht.
Das ist ja diese letzte Datei. Hatte ich ja schon ein, zwei Mal in der Sendung.
Dass macOS es nicht schafft, mir, wenn ich eine Datei gerade gespeichert habe,
die unterletzte Dateien anzuzeigen.
Du meinst unter Benutzobjekte?
Genau, solange ich sie nämlich nicht nochmal geöffnet habe danach.
Erst dann kriegt sie den Start. Ich habe mich da nochmal tiefer reingenördert,
was da eigentlich die Logik dahinter ist.
Oh Gott.
Es gibt drei verschiedene quasi Filter, die darauf wirken. Nämlich angelegt,
zuletzt geöffnet und was war das dritte?
Zuletzt runtergeladen oder sowas glaube ich irgendwie oder gespeichert oder so.
Und der Finder ist halt nur in der Lage, eins dieser drei Kriterien umzusetzen,
aber nicht eine Kombination davon. Ich habe dann einmal was selber coden lassen,
sowas als Kron im Hintergrund, das versucht zu simulieren.
Es war so semi-okayisch, aber auch nicht so, dass ich damit dann täglich arbeiten wollte.
Und man kann noch so einen Kompromiss machen. Also irgendwann kann ich das nochmal
publizieren, was ich da rausgefunden habe, viel zu viel Zeit da rein versenkt.
Aber ich dachte, wenn das selbst Windows kann.
Wenn selbst Windows das kann, das ist jetzt.
So, aber auch fürs Protokoll, dass wenn ich in einer Mac-App eine Datei speicher
und die dann nicht unter letzte Objekte auftaucht, habe ich dafür auch genauso
wenig Verständnis wie gerade eben hier mit den Apps unter Linux.
Es gibt einfach so, manche Dinge sollen verdammt nochmal funktionieren.
Punkt. Kommen später noch dazu.
Mit dem nächsten Design-Chef von Apple wird das alles in Ordnung kommen.
Ja, wer ist das denn? Weiß man das schon?
Ja, hatten wir ja schon besprochen. Das ist der Name, den ich die ganze Zeit
vergesse. Okay, Adea. Ja, ist ein Nachfolger.
Lass mich kurz Steven irgendwas...
Das müssen wir jetzt nochmal ins Blut reinkriegen, weil der Alte,
das weiß ich, der heißt irgendwie Alan Dye.
Der quasi Geschaste.
Nee, der ist nicht geschasst worden. Der ist selber gegangen.
Naja, du weißt ja nicht, wie viel Druck dahinter stand.
Wenig. Also der ist wirklich selber gegangen und hat sich ja von Meta da rauskaufen
lassen. Den hat keiner rausgeschmissen.
Stephen Lee May heißt ja neue Mensch.
Und der ist jetzt Head of Apples User Interface Design Team.
Und das müsste dann hoffentlich bald Früchte tragen. Das werden wir dann im Mai sehen.
Gut, lass uns zu einem anderen Dauerthema kommen. Da müssen wir jetzt noch ein
paar Sachen nachreichen.
Na, ihr wisst es schon. Was könnte es sein? Es ist AI.
Oh Gott, ich glaube, ich hänge auch schon irgendwie die Themen schon so langsam
zum Hals raus. Aber es passiert da einfach so viel.
Ja, aber das ist doch hier Staffel 3 Dauerthema.
Ja, in der Tat.
Wenn AI kein Thema ist, müssen wir das eine neue Staffel nennen.
Zeit froh, dass wir uns nicht über Bitcoin unterhalten.
Ja, aber da können wir bei Bitcoin gibt es immerhin die gute Nachricht,
dass man da bald, glaube ich, den Abgesang mal einleiten kann.
Aber bei AI wird es noch eine Weile dauern.
Da wollte ich eigentlich eine schöne Überleitung bauen, die aber durch mein
Bierholen gerade zerstört worden ist, weil da gab es ja auch Kritik,
ob berechtigt oder nicht, lasse ich jetzt fast mal dahingestellt,
so, oh mein Gott, wie konnte er denn dann irgendwie anfangen mit einer LLM, seine Linux,
Konfiguration machen zu lassen.
Das habe ich sehr stark runtergefahren.
Weil einfach die Präzision gerade in dem Bereich nicht so geil war.
Und so der Unterschied, das wieder alles wegzureparieren, was man da Copy and
Paste mäßig vorher angerichtet hat,
dann netto deutlich mehr Zeit gekostet hat, als das, was es in den Fällen,
wo es der richtige erste Ansatz war vom LLM.
Und ich habe da eher die teuren drauf geworfen auf dem Bereich.
Das habe ich fast komplett eingestellt und gegen die gute alte Google-Suche ersetzt.
Also von daher, der Teil des Experimentes, würde ich mal sagen,
ist einigermaßen gescheitert.
Das hat mir mehr Probleme eingebracht, als es gelöst hat.
Naja, auf der anderen Seite, es ist, wenn man überhaupt nicht weiß,
wo man anfangen soll, dann ist es meiner Erfahrung nach immer ganz gut,
die AI mal so zu fragen, wie würdest du denn das machen?
Was sind denn so die drei Strategien, wie ich das hinkriege?
Und dann nennt er dir Tools und Dinge und Zeug, die du machen kannst.
Und an der Stelle kannst du dann echte Literatur weiterlesen und rausfinden,
ja, das funktioniert jetzt so oder das ist nur Version so und so und die habe
ich aber nicht und solche Sachen.
Ja, also meine Arbeitsthese ist, dass hier dieser ganze Zoo-an-Distro-Kombinationen,
was ist irgendwie deine Grundrestribution, was ist irgendwie jetzt obendrauf
wieder Desktop und was hast du noch für Spitzereien und was für eine Hardware und,
dass das einfach so ein innendimensionaler Raum ist, dass,
Und eigentlich der beste Ansatz wäre, und das habe ich auch mehr oder weniger
versucht, immer zu sagen, schau mal nach, was hier wirklich Phase ist eigentlich
bei dieser Installation.
Das sind die Rahmendaten, von denen ich weiß, dass sie da sind,
aber schau jetzt bitte mal selber so.
Das wird dann, glaube ich, zu schnell ignoriert und dann wird halt wieder irgendein
Pseudowissen aus, naja, aber unter Ubuntu, er hat gesagt, er ist unter Ubuntu,
ja dann wird es ja so und so sein, ja, aber PopOS hat das halt verändert und
dafür hat dann wieder zu wenig Trainingsdaten und dann passieren wieder schrückliche Dinge.
Also ich musste nur kurz googeln,
um gleich eine ganze Reihe von passenden Projekten zu finden,
wo man dann halt einfach einen MCP-Server für das jeweilige Linux-System installiert
und dann kann dein Klot sich direkt mit deinem Betriebssystem über seine Details unterhalten.
Dann koppelst du einfach die ganzen Manual-Pages und die ganzen Info-Pages.
All das Wissen, was man sich selber nicht durchlesen will und keine Lust hat,
das kannst du einfach dann direkt in dein Desktop-Chatbot reinklinken und dann
fragt die AI dein Betriebssystem, wie es funktioniert und erzählst dir dann.
Das ist doch die Zukunft. Wir werden alle so dumm werden.
Naja, aber ich meine, bei dieser Komplexität dieser Systeme,
mal ehrlich, also du kannst, also ich meine, ich habe ja noch, ich habe ja Unix,
wann habe ich mit Unix angefangen?
Tja.
88 irgendwie so, wo man irgendwie.
Weißt du, alles rausfinden musste, um das überhaupt irgendwie zum Laufen zu bekommen.
Das war alles noch so rudimentär und so.
Und da wusste ich irgendwie gefühlt vielleicht 50 bis 60 Prozent aller vorhandenen
Tools, wusste ich irgendwie, wie die Kommandozeile funktioniert.
Nicht alle, aber viel. Heute ist das ein Riesensee von Optionen und Commandline-Sachen
und Skriptsprachen und was nicht alles.
Und um das wirklich richtig zu verstehen, muss man schon einen gewissen Teil
seiner Jugend da reinopfern.
Das macht halt einfach nicht jeder.
Aber wenn du dir trotzdem diese Komplexität erschließen lassen willst,
finde ich ehrlich gesagt gar nichts falsch daran, dass zum Beispiel,
das muss jetzt nicht der einzige Weg sein, über so einen MCP-Server das zu machen.
Dass halt einfach man irgendwie eine LLM benutzt, um die Frage zu formulieren.
Weil manchmal weiß man ja gar nicht, manchmal weiß man ja gar nicht, was man fragen soll.
Also dieses Ganze musst du nachschlagen, musst du lernen.
Du weißt ja gar nicht, wo du anfangen sollst. Und überhaupt erstmal eine Hilfe
zu bekommen, wo man anfangen kann und was so der Einstieg wäre,
um dieses spezifische Problem zu lösen. Dafür ist es wunderbar.
Und da macht so ein MCP-Server meiner Meinung nach total Sinn,
der sich halt einfach reinkoppelt und einfach dem Teil die entsprechenden Informationen liefert.
Aber wir wollten uns ja eigentlich über andere Sachen unterhalten.
Roddy, du hast Experimente gemacht.
Ich habe, ich weiß jetzt nicht, worauf du hinaus willst?
Ich will darauf hinaus, dass du dir Cloud Desktop Extensions angeschaut hast.
Ja, das ist ein Artikel, der auf so einer Security-Seite,
gepostet wurde, wo jemand mal nachgeguckt hat, was denn diese ganzen Extensions,
die man so runterladen und installieren kann,
was das denn alles so ist und es stellt sich heraus, ja der Löwenanteil ist
einfach nur Leute, die einem irgendwie an die Security wollen und.
Was ist denn das überhaupt, Cloud Desktop Extensions? Ich kenne das gar nicht.
Plugins für Cloud Desktop, ja?
Ja, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, ja.
Okay. Unlike traditional browser extensions, Cloud Desktop extensions run unsandboxed
with full system privileges.
What could possibly go wrong?
Also Vorsicht vor Cloud Extensions, Desktop Extensions.
Ja, was ist denn das überhaupt? Achso, das ist ein kleiner MCP-Server.
Guck mal, das Thema hatten wir ja gerade.
Aha, okay.
Interessant. Und in was läuft das irgendwie?
Man hat so das Gefühl, jetzt ist da wieder eine Generation von IT-Leuten unterwegs,
die alle Fehler nochmal selber machen müssen,
um sie zu lernen, weil Sandboxing ist ja jetzt nun auch kein neues Thema, ne, naja.
Ja, okay, gut.
Ich wollte es nochmal erwähnt haben, dass man da wirklich aufpassen muss und
dass nicht alles Tolles.
Ich finde in diesem Artikel den Comic recht schön, weil der Typ ganz offensichtlich
auf einem Mac arbeitet und dann wird er gehackt und dann gehen plötzlich Windows-XT-Dialogboxen
auf und das ist natürlich schon bitter.
Okay, und diese andere Sache?
Diese andere Sache war dieses da hat jemand ein Paper geschrieben wo ähm,
wo sie herausgefunden haben, dass sie bessere Antworten kriegen,
wenn sie den Prompt zweimal hintereinander genau gleich an die LLM schicken.
Und das fand ich auch irgendwie so interessant. Erstens, wie kommt man auf die Idee?
Und zweitens, dann funktioniert das auch noch. Also das fand ich ganz witzig.
Es hat wahrscheinlich nicht wirklich Wert.
Keine Ahnung, kann man ja mal ausprobieren. Ich habe es selber jetzt nicht ausprobiert.
Also es gibt ja so eine ganze Snake Oil Industrie, auch auf Insta relativ prominent.
Wo sonst?
Wo du immer die letzten Prompt-Geheimnisse verraten bekommst oder zumindest
angeteasert, um dann übers Abo dann noch viel mehr Geheimnisse zu haben.
Und interessanterweise so vieles davon funktionierten aber doch wirklich ganz
gut, weil also selbst diese Snake Oil Produzenten sich meistens an irgendwelchen
Papern orientieren und das ist glaube ich in der Tat auch eins von denen,
die ich gelesen hatte hier mit dem Doppelprompt.
Genau, da gibt es halt so ein paar gerade wieder hippe Geschichten,
dass das Problem ist, die funktionieren dann meistens wieder nur auf einer Generation
von LLMs und irgendwie in zwei, drei Monaten, wenn die nächste Generation draußen
ist, da muss man sich schon wieder seinen Werkzeugkasten anpassen.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, weil die Leute, die die LMMs bauen, den Artikel auch lesen
und dann merken, es gibt da noch Optimierungspotenzial, sagen wir mal so.
Und wenn sie das dann heben, dann ist das halt weg.
Das ist doch mal wirklich sehr kurz, dieser Artikel hier.
Ja, und schöne bunte Grafiken.
Lustiger Effekt. Wobei, das gilt jetzt für Non-Reasoning-LLMs.
Also, wo nicht sich die LLM nochmal mit sich selbst unterhält.
Ja, okay. Ich fand's nur interessant.
Okay. Ja, okay, ist auch interessant.
Ja, talking about Claude und Anthropik. Also Anthropik finde ich,
Ich kann jetzt über die wirkliche ethische Bedeutung von Anthropic nicht so
viele Feststellungen machen.
Wenn wir auch gleich nochmal im Kontext von OpenClaw kurz drüber reden.
Auf jeden Fall sind die sehr aufskunftsfreudig, was so ihr Blog und ihre Projektberichte betrifft.
Dann wollte ich mal so auf zwei Sachen eingehen, die sie jetzt gerade,
beziehungsweise eines schon ein bisschen länger her, eingegangen sind.
Und zwar, was ich auch noch nicht wusste, ist,
dass sie mit der NASA zusammenarbeiten und jetzt zumindest mal für eine längere
Mission von zwei Marstagen die Routenplanung für den Perseverance-Roboter,
der da gerade rumfährt, vorgenommen haben.
Also das Problem mit dem Mars ist ja, der ist ja ganz schön weit weg.
Und du kannst jetzt diesen Roboter nicht einfach mal mit dem Tipet irgendwie
steuern und da durch die Gegend fahren, weil du halt einfach mehrere Minuten
Latenz hast und würdest du jetzt immer wieder... Mindestens 20.
Genau, mindestens bis zu was?
Nee, bis zu 20 Minuten.
Bis zu 20. Also je nachdem, wo gerade der Mars und die Erde so stehen,
kann das ganz schön lange dauern.
Und dann ist natürlich so ein schnelles um einen Stein herumfahren sowieso nicht zu denken.
Und dementsprechend läuft das derzeit vor allem so,
dass sie also aufgrund des Fotomaterials, was sie haben, Also das ist natürlich
einerseits das, was der Rover selber sieht, plus das, was sie jetzt vielleicht
mit dieser Flugmission,
wie hieß das Ding nochmal,
der kleine Flieger, den er mitgemacht hat, der jetzt irgendwie kaputt gegangen
ist, weiß ich jetzt gerade nicht mehr, ähm.
Und natürlich, was sie auch von ihren Mars-Orbiter-Satelliten,
also sie haben ja diverse Orbiter, auch die ESA und so weiter,
die halt die ganze Zeit den Mars kartografieren.
Da gibt es ja schon ein relativ umfangreiches Kartenmaterial und damit versuchen
sie eben herauszufinden, okay, wo soll jetzt der Rover genau langfahren?
Und dafür haben sie so eine XML-basierte Rover-Movement-Language gebaut.
Die sie dann halt so runterladen und dann ist das irgendwie für den nächsten
Tag sozusagen der Reisepfad, dem dieser Rover dann irgendwie folgt und dann
kann man später halt gucken, was dabei rausgekommen ist.
Und da mag es dann auch immer solche Erkennungen geben, was nach dem Motto so,
oh, eine unerwartete Blockade, ich weiß nicht, was ich jetzt tun soll,
ich warte jetzt mal, bis ich Instruktionen bekomme.
Aber man möchte natürlich das so weit reduzieren, wie es irgendwie geht.
Ja und dann haben sie einfach mal Cloth genommen und haben den quasi mit diesem
ganzen Modell, mit den Maßdaten, diesen Lokationsdaten, die sie haben,
aber auch den ganzen Parametern,
die auf diese Reise Einfluss nehmen können bei diesem Rover und das ist sowieso
was wie 500.000 verschiedene Variablen,
das irgendwie alles reingepackt und dann mit Cloth die Reiseplanung gemacht
und das hat wohl ganz gut funktioniert.
Also im Prinzip autonomes Fahren ist jetzt mit AI Wenn nicht bei uns.
Dann zumindest auf dem Mars Genau.
Da ist ein bisschen weniger Verkehr Dafür ist auch die Verkehrsinfrastruktur
nicht so gut ausgebaut Also es funktioniert zumindest schon so ein bisschen Und.
Die Unfälle sind deutlich teurer.
Ja teurer und schwieriger auch wieder zu untangeln und so weiter,
also da spielt schon so einiges mit rein.
Aber ich finde, das ist irgendwie eine geile Anwendung, weil so ähnlich wie
mit den Linux- Konfigurationen hast du es hier mit so mega komplexen Problemen,
mit sehr vielen Variablen zu tun.
Da kann einem dann die AI diese Daten unter Umständen auch gut zusammentragen.
Sagen wir keiner, dass das so nichts, was gut ist.
Und die zweite Sache ist, dass Claude ein CCC gebaut hat.
Nämlich den Claude-C-Compiler. Und das ist jetzt wirklich interessant und das
leitet in gewisser Hinsicht,
achso, wir greifen das gleich nochmal auf, ich erzähle das erstmal weiter.
Also das neueste, tollste Modell von Anthropik ist ja dieses Opus 4.6.
Also Claude ist ja sozusagen der Sammelbegriff für so ihre ganzen AI-Models.
Dann gibt es so verschiedene Varianten und Sonnet war lange Zeit so der heiße Scheiß.
Dann kam sie irgendwie mit Opus und das ist noch ein bisschen toller. Opus 4.
Auch sehr viel teurer, muss man sagen.
Ja, teurer auch, aber halt auch das Beste. und das Opus 4.6 ist so jetzt wieder
der nächste große Schritt, den sie veröffentlicht haben.
Ist ja immer ein bisschen schwierig, da in diesen ganzen Versionsnummern da
mitzukommen, aber das ist so das, was derzeit aktuell ist, mit dem sie gerade rumposen.
Genau, und dann haben sie irgendwie das hergenommen und haben gesagt,
so, jetzt bauen wir mal hier was Richtiges zusammen und das machen wir nicht
von Hand, sondern jetzt gucken wir mal, ob die Maschine in der Lage ist,
uns einen C-Compiler zu programmieren.
Also das Ziel ist ein C-Compiler, also ein Programm, was C-Source-Code nimmt
und den in lauffähigen Code übersetzt.
Und dieser C-Compiler sollte in Rust geschrieben sein, weil C-Compiler,
die in C geschrieben sind, gibt es ja schon eine ganze Menge.
Und dann haben sie also Opus 4.6 genommen und haben das mit sogenannten Agent Teams realisiert.
Das heißt, es ist jetzt nicht mehr so ein Chatbot und man unterhält sich dann
eine halbe Stunde mit dem und erzählt dem, was man gerne so haben möchte,
sondern sie haben da so eine Multitasking-Fähigkeit quasi eingebaut oder so
eine Parallelisierung mit so Sub-Agents.
Und haben einfach gesagt so, ja hier, mach du einfach mal, das Ziel ist ein
C-Compiler, du sollst am Ende den Linux-Kernel übersetzen können.
Und dieses System ist halt so aufgesetzt worden, dass das Ding also selber in
so einzelne Teams, ich weiß gar nicht, inwiefern das automatisch war oder vorgegeben
war, muss ich jetzt noch mal ein bisschen nachdenken, weiß ich glaube ich jetzt gerade nicht.
Auf jeden Fall gab es dann so Agents, die sich halt um den Code-Generierer,
den Parser und so weiter gekümmert haben und andere Teile waren glaube ich so
für das Testing zuständig.
Und das Schöne bei Softwareentwicklung und AI ist ja, dass du dann relativ gut
deine Ergebnisse auch immer überprüfen und wieder korrigieren kannst.
Das heißt, sie haben das System einfach eigenständig machen lassen und am Ende
kamen da aus 2000 Cloud-Sessions, die sie haben laufen lassen,
über einen Zeitraum von zwei Wochen.
Haben sie irgendwie zwei Milliarden Input-Tokens da reingefeuert,
140 Millionen Output-Tokens rausbekommen.
Und hätten sie das jetzt alles selber bezahlen müssen, also hätten wir das jetzt
gemacht, dann hätte uns dieser Lauf 20.000 Dollar gekostet bei Anthropic.
Das hätten wir da überweisen müssen.
Was nicht so viel ist, oder?
Nö, also für so einen C-Compiler. Ja,
also das Ergebnis war 100.000 Zeilen Compiler und der war in der Lage,
den Source-Code von Linux zu nehmen und hat einen lauffähigen,
bootfähigen Linux 6.9-Körnel erzeugt,
der in der Lage war, Code für Intel x86, ARM und RISC-V-Plattformen.
Nicht nur das, sie haben auch noch verschiedene andere Projekte damit übersetzt,
unter anderem QEMO, FFMPEG, SQLite, Postgres, Redis, also alles relativ krasse
Codebasen und Doom, wie sie noch betont haben. Also es läuft auch mit Doom.
Das bedeutet nicht, dass alles sich übersetzen ließ.
Also sie sind wohl auch bei ein paar Projekten irgendwie bei 99 Prozent gestrandet.
Aber das war jetzt hier auch in gewisser Hinsicht der erste Aufschlag.
Der Code war jetzt auch nicht besonders schnell ausreichend.
Wobei ich jetzt nicht weiß, ob er jetzt auffällig langsam war,
aber da ist, sagen wir mal, noch Luft nach oben und auch ihre eigene Einschätzung
bezüglich der erzeugten Code-Qualität,
also wie jetzt der Source-Code so rüberkommt und sozusagen als Rust-Code selber
besteht, sei wohl auch noch verbesserungsfähig.
Aber einer dieser Agenten zum Beispiel war halt auch explizit nur dafür da,
zu schauen, dass auch der Source-Code ordentlich ist.
Also er war sozusagen nur für die Rust-Seite zuständig.
Er hat immer gesagt, ja hier kannst du nicht hier Pöpscher schreiben.
Und so haben sich einfach diese ganzen einzelnen Agenten untereinander unterhalten
und haben einfach losgelegt und keiner hat mir die Finger geregt von Anthropik.
Und sie haben einfach nur zwei Wochen gebartet und dann macht die Maschine katsching
und hat gesagt, so fertig, hier C-Compiler.
Und das finde ich erstmal ziemlich bemerkenswert.
Nicht wirklich überraschend, aber trotzdem bemerkenswert. Und ja,
das war jetzt technisch alles noch so ein bisschen so, also sie machen so die
Kommunikation zwischen diesen Agenten so mit Textfiles und irgendwie Logfiles,
also so total Steinzeit mäßig.
Sie haben auch nicht sind es unter anderem so vorgegangen dass sie,
erstmal, also sie haben nicht gleich angefangen so hier immer den ganzen Kernel
zu compilen und zu gucken was dabei am Ende rauskommt,
sondern sie haben das so aufgeteilt dass sie das System hat dann einfach GCC
genommen und hat erstmal den Großteil,
compiled und dann haben sie so einzelne kleine Teile am Rand,
erstmal versucht selber zu übersetzen und umso mehr das alles funktioniert hat
und die Tests bestanden hat,
umso mehr haben sie dann sozusagen von dem GCC in ihren Compiler übernommen
und dabei Schritt für Schritt diesen Compiler immer weiter verbessert.
Ja, und jetzt ist das irgendwie fertig und kann man sich anschauen,
liegt auf GitHub rum und dann hat man so einen C-Compiler. Das ist schon irgendwie ziemlich krass.
Was ich bei GCC spannend finde, also zumindest vor Jahren war das so,
dass ein Teil der Test-Suite war, kann sich der Compiler selber kompilieren.
Und zwar mit erhöhtem Schwierigkeitsgrad in mehreren Generationen.
Also der erste Compiler compilt den zweiten Compiler, der zweite Compiler den dritten,
der dritte Compiler compilt nochmal den vierten Compiler und dann machen sie
einen Binary-Vergleich zwischen dem dritten und dem vierten Compiler und die
müssen übereinstimmen, sonst stimmt was nicht.
Fand ich eine sehr, sehr merkwürdige Herangehensweise, aber gut.
Ja, also ich finde das bemerkenswert und wir reden auch gleich nochmal über
diese ganze Idee mit diesem Agentik-Programmieren, wie das jetzt angeblich heißt.
Aber vielleicht will Ralf erstmal seine AI-Erfahrung der letzten Zeit teilen.
Ja, eine Erkenntnis, die ich auch schon seit ein paar Sendungen so vor mir her trage, ist,
dass sich so in meiner Wahrnehmung der schlafende Riese gerade erhoben hat, nämlich Google.
Die ja bisher mit ihren Gemini-Modellen so 1, 2 eher mal so unter Fernalifen mitgetrottet sind.
Man hatte den Eindruck, so OpenAI und jetzt hier die Cloud-Modelle machen eigentlich
so den Laden eher so unter sich aus.
Und dann, ich glaube Ende November ungefähr muss das gewesen sein,
hat Google die Gemini 3 Produktfamilie herausgegeben.
Und wisst ihr ja, ich habe so ein paar Standardtests, die ich da immer so durchlaufen
lasse und das, was ich mal vor Urzeiten gemacht hatte, so,
Trickfragen, irgendwie 14 Stück, die werden standardmäßig immer von allen aktuellen
Reasoning-Modellen so mit Nullfehlern laufen die durch, das ist überhaupt kein Challenge mehr,
aber trotzdem habe ich immer so ein paar Standardaufgaben, wo ich gucke,
sowas geht und ich hatte gelesen, auch irgendwo im Internet ist es mir mir vorbeigerauscht, dass...
Dass Gemini 3-Modell erstaunlich gut sei in Handschriftenerkennung.
Dazu muss man wissen, meine Handschrift ist der totale Endgegner für jegliche
Art von Schriftenerkennung.
Du bist ein verkammter Arzt.
So ungefähr der Level, genau. Das heißt also, meine Schrift zeichnet sich zum
Beispiel dadurch aus, dass innerhalb eines derselben Wortes,
ein und derselbe Buchstabe in drei verschiedenen Variationen gezeichnet wird.
Ich habe wirklich das, was man so gemeinhin eine totale Sauklaue nennt.
Und habe darum aber eigentlich immer mal wieder so den Drang,
das wäre schon schön, um auch das Ganze, was ich so schreibe,
in der Restwelt kommunizierbar zu machen, wenn man da mal irgendwie so eine
OCR drüber laufen lassen würde, also eine automatische Schriftenerkennung.
Und ich habe ja in meinem Digitalisierungszentrum gearbeitet,
da haben wir auch mit mittelalterlichen Handschriften und Trainings da drauf
und OCR von mittelalterlichen Handschriften auch und das war alles gar nicht so schlecht,
aber bei meiner Handschrift war da immer Hopfen und Malz verloren,
weil sie halt so komplett erratisch ist.
Schlimmer als Mittelalter, ja?
Schlimmer als Mittelalter. Schriftgeschrift. So, oder wie sagte damals mein
erster Deutschlehrer, Ralf, ab einem gewissen Abstraktionsgrad verliert die
Schrift ihre kommunikative Wirkung.
So war es. So, ich also hin und wieder eine meiner Notizseiten.
Ich habe vor einem Jahr umgestellt wieder mal auf handschriftliche Notizen von
Meetings, weil ich so versuche, Laptops aus Meetings komplett rauszuhalten.
Das, finde ich, lenkt dann doch immer zu sehr ab. Und man hat zu viel anderen
Kram und konzentriert sich nicht auf die Sitzung selber.
Ein Grund, glaube ich, für schlechte Meetings. und schreibe halt den Kram in
meine Kladde, den aber niemand außer mir und auch ich selber zunehmend schwerer
irgendwie entziffern kann.
Habe also einfach ein wackeliges iPhone-Foto davon gemacht und in Gemina 3 hochgeladen.
Was soll ich sagen? 100% perfekte Erkennung. Von einer Schrift,
die de facto eigentlich nicht korrekt ist.
Und dann guckt man sich an.
Konkret mache ich das in Open Router. Habe ich ja schon ein paar Mal hier gedroppt,
das Tool, wo man ja beliebige,
auch wirklich top aktuelle Sprachmodelle einfach mal so ausprobieren kann und
alle paar Monate mal so ein Geld von 10 Euro draufwirft und dann aber eben kein
Dauerabo hat, sondern immer gerade das probieren kann, was man gerade cool findet.
Und da kann man den Reasoning-Prozess ja nachlesen, wie er angeblich passiert.
Das wissen wir ja bis heute nicht, ob das wirklich echt ist oder was davon noch
irgendwie gefiltert ist, wie auch immer.
Aber wie saukool das ist, zu sehen, wie er sich an meiner Schrift abarbeitet
und versucht herzuleiten, was wohl das wahrscheinlichste Wort ist, was da steht.
Das heißt also, er macht quasi erstmal eine normale, in Anführungszeichen,
OCR, bekommt totales Spaghetti raus und versucht dann aber auch aus dem Kontext
dessen, was quasi insgesamt eigentlich dort ungefähr wohl steht auf der Seite,
sich herzuleiten, so was für ein Begriff ist da wohl gerade gemeint.
Und kriegt dann eben mit, okay, hat offensichtlich irgendwas mit Bibliotheken
zu tun und irgendwie mit, was weiß ich, Thema XY.
Und aus dieser Kombination, aus einer grundsätzlich schon mal sehr guten OCR
plus diesem Reasoning oben drüber, was ist der wahrscheinlichste Ablauf dieses
Wortes und des Satzes und des Abschnitts, der da geschrieben ist.
Kriegt das nur bei meiner Schrift hundertprozentige Erkennungsquote hin.
Und dann dachte ich, hm, das ist ganz schön eindrucksvoll, vielleicht kann man
das mal für was noch nützlicheres einsetzen als für meine Handschrift.
So und das, was wer so im mittleren Management irgendwie unterwegs ist, kennt ihr vielleicht,
ja so Workshops und wir machen eine Brainstorming Session und wir machen ein
World Café und schreiben eine Tischdecke voll.
Und wir machen ganz, ganz viele Post-its, die wir irgendwo dran an Metaplanwände packen.
So, was ist also passiert?
Wir hatten am 4.12. in der ZLB so einen internen Strategie-Workshop,
wo wir irgendwie 120 Leute auf irgendwie 20 verschiedene Stationen aufgeteilt
haben und wo Metaplanwände mit Post-its beschrieben wurden, mit Handschriftmarkern, was auch immer.
Ja, 120 Leute, 120 Handschriften, einzelne Metaplanwände mit 60,
70 Zetteln mit sehr unterschiedlichen Methodiken.
Das heißt also jeder Stand konnte
sich aussuchen, so wie strukturieren wir jetzt irgendwie die Aufgabe.
Aber dann waren irgendwie Cluster dabei, wo dann also irgendwie fünf Themenfelder
in der Mitte waren und wo sich dann die Zettel drumherum arretierten oder es
gab so eine Ideenexplosion,
wo du in der ersten Runde irgendwie eine Idee aufmachst und in der zweiten Runde
iteriert dann eine andere Gruppe drüber
und dann hast du quasi so ein Wasserfallmodell, was sich daraus ergibt.
Also 20 sehr unterschiedliche auch Kreativmethoden quasi, die da zum Einsatz
kamen oder ob du einfach nur so einen Raster XY machst.
120 Leute, 120 Handschriften und ich habe einfach jede Metaplanwand abfotografiert
und Gemini 3 vorgeworfen und das Ganze dann ein bisschen Liebe mal in einen
Prompt rein entwickelt und den kann ich mal in die Shownotes reinwerfen.
Um daraus Markdown zu machen. Das heißt also, das ist ein mehrstufiger Prompt,
der im Wesentlichen in drei Phasen vorangeht.
In der ersten Phase ist quasi erstmal die reine Deskription,
was ist hier wirklich zu sehen.
Die zweite Phase und zwar schon entlang von auch wie ist die Struktur dieses Boards eigentlich.
Erkenn erstmal, bevor du anfängst, irgendeinen Text zu lesen,
mach dir erstmal den Kopf darüber, wie ist diese Metaplanwand eigentlich strukturiert.
Ist die in Zeilen und Spalten oder in Sternen oder was auch immer.
Und dann fangen alle in dem zweiten Schritt, die ganzen Einzelzettel zu lesen.
Krieg raus, ob beispielsweise die Farbe der Zettel eine Semantik abbildet.
Also rote Zettel stehen für Gefahr, grüne Zettel stehen für Chancen, was auch immer.
Gibt es Klebepunkte, also in etlichen Stationen war es so, dass man dann hinterher
quasi so voten konnte, so was sind ja wie besonders gute Ideen.
All das hat halt in einen Prompt reingegossen und diesen Prompt dann einfach
0815 mäßig auf die 20 JPEG-Bilder aus meiner Kamera drüber geworfen und das
Ergebnis ist fantastisch.
Du kriegst dann also Markdown-Dateien sauber durchstrukturiert dieser Metaplanwende,
wo normalerweise irgendein armer Hiwi irgendwie zwei Wochen dran sitzt,
den ganzen Kram irgendwie nachzubereiten.
Und das hast du dann plötzlich innerhalb von zwei Minuten einfach verfügbar.
Ich werfe den mal die URL zum Prompt mal rein.
Hier steht ja trotzdem keiner, aber wenigstens hat kein Hiwi zwei Wochen dran gepuzzelt.
Naja, die dritte Phase ist eine strategische Verdichtung. Das heißt,
es entstehen drei Markdown-Dateien.
Das eine ist quasi so die RAW-Datei. Das zweite ist eine,
Schon bereinigte, stark strukturierte Fassung.
Das dritte ist dann der Executive Summary, wo dann nur nochmal die quasi Hauptergebnisse
oder Erkenntnisse der Metaplanwarn zusammengefasst sind.
In so einem dreistufigen Prozess geht der prompt dadurch. So,
Gemini 3, ohne mit der Wimper zu zucken.
Wenn du dasselbe irgendwie auf Claude Sonnet probierst oder auf JetGPT, totales Desaster.
Kommt überhaupt nichts Sinnvolles bei rum.
Und dann habe ich mich gefragt, naja, geht der Weg denn auch andersrum?
Weil parallel dazu ist ein Teil der Gemini 3 Suite, die sie veröffentlicht haben,
auch das sogenannte Nano Banana 3 Modell.
Das ist der Bildgenerator. Achso, dann tippst du erst eine Markdown-Datei ein
und dann mach mir eine Zettelwand daraus.
Genau, mach mir ein Schaubild daraus.
Achso, ich dachte so eine Zettelwand.
Ja, du kannst auch eine Zettelwandze haben.
Mit schlechter Handschrift und so.
Round Circle, genau. Und dann hast du Ground Truth versus Endergebnis.
Nee, aber da habe ich dann beispielsweise
mal halt einen Acht-Seiten-PDF reingeworfen und habe gesagt so,
mach mir daraus mal eine Whiteboard-Visualisierung, was so die wesentlichen
Elemente so im Sinne von, na wie heißt das, wenn man so Veranstaltungen mit Scribblen lässt.
Tim, du hattest es schon bei Graphic Recording.
Graphic Recording, genau. Mach mal ein Graphic Recording Board daraus.
Oder mach mal eine Visualisierung, damit dich irgendwie das obere Management
für diese Idee begeistern kann, wie auch immer.
Und dann spuckt dieses Modell sauber wirklich dir ein hochaufgelöstes 4K-PNG
raus mit perfektem Text. Ja, weil bis vor irgendwie einem Vierteljahr hieß es
ja auch, naja, die ganzen Bildgenerierungsmodelle, die können alle keinen Text.
Ja, du siehst, da steht irgendwas und ab und zu wird mal im Buchstabe richtig getroffen.
Aber ansonsten ist es einfach mal so AI-Slop.
100% akkurat perfekter Text.
Und dieses Banana-Modell kann deine Handschrift simulieren.
Das heißt, du kannst hingehen und sagen, so, hier die Mathehausaufgabe,
du schreibst oben die Formel hin, die du irgendwie herleiten musst in deiner Handschrift.
Und sagst dem Banana-3-Modell, löse A diese Formel und schreib mir B die Lösung
in derselben Handschrift unten drunter und dann kriegst du ein hoch aufgelöstes
PNG mit der kompletten mathematisch richtigen Auflösung in deiner eigenen Handschrift,
um sie als Hausaufgabe abzugeben.
Kriege ich das dann auch als Stiftplotter-Datei?
Das ist wahrscheinlich dann auch kein Problem mehr.
What a time to be alive.
Übrigens das mit der eigenen Handschrift. Also das hatte Apple ja mit dem iPad
auch, weiß ich nicht, letzte Major-Version oder so, vorletzte Major-Version eingeführt.
Eigentlich ganz nett, wenn er die Worte lesen kann, dann verbessert er so ein
bisschen die Schreibweise, sodass man es besser lesen kann.
Aber es sieht noch so ein bisschen nach der eigenen Handschrift aus.
Problem ist, man kann ihm das nicht richtig abgewöhnen oder man kann auch nicht
sagen, okay, ich zeichne jetzt was, das ist jetzt kein geschriebenes Wort,
versuche nicht dies in ein geschriebenes Wort zu verwandeln.
Geht nicht. Das ist irgendwie, man kann es nur ganz ausschalten oder ganz einschalten.
Ja, mit dem Gemini ist es so ein bisschen The Empire Strikes Back,
habe ich so in den Eindrucken.
Ich meine, Google stand jetzt so ein bisschen im Schatten des Open-Air-Hypes
und gut, Anthropic stand, glaube ich, die ganze Zeit auch so ein bisschen im
Schatten, aber war auf jeden Fall so ein bisschen auch,
in der New Kids on the Block,
Berichterstattung immer ganz vorne, auch nicht zu Unrecht.
Und Google war ja nie schlecht, aber so ein bisschen hinterher.
Und ich habe so den Eindruck, dass sie jetzt ordentlich Gas gegeben haben in
letzter Zeit und dass sie da wirklich gute Ergebnisse erzielen.
Also dieses Schriften erkennen und Schriften schreiben können,
das eröffnet einen so großen Zoo an Use Cases, der jetzt halt vor einem halben
Jahr irgendwie zugeschlossen war.
Das ist schon wild. Also wenn man damit mal ein bisschen rumexperimentiert,
da wird glaube ich einiges gehen.
Sie haben jetzt vor zwei Tagen, glaube ich, nachdem das 3.0 Modell gerade mal
erst im November rausgekommen ist, haben sie jetzt das 3.1er Modell veröffentlicht
und ich habe mal hier gerade in den Chat geworfen,
wie sich das angeblich bei Coding schlägt.
Diese Coding-Benchmark-Graphen sind ja immer irgendwie mit ein bisschen,
take it with a grain of salt, je nachdem, welche Verfahren da wo wie.
Angewandt werden. Ist das mal mehr oder weniger irgendwie aussagekräftig.
Aber dieser Chart an sich ist schon mal ganz spannend. Der ist hier auch von
Open Router, also von deren internen Statistiken und Testläufen,
die sie machen lassen. Das ist jetzt Coding.
Man kann auch noch irgendwie generelle Intelligenz umschalten,
aber bleiben wir mal kurz bei Coding.
Und dann sieht man dort einen XY-Skaterplot, wo verschiedene Modelle abgebildet
sind, und zwar auf den Achsenpreis.
Das heißt, so teuer sind die, um irgendeine Aufgabe X zu erledigen,
von irgendwie 10 Cent bis 5,26 Euro.
Das sind dann nämlich die Claude Opus Modelle.
Und auf der Y-Achse hast du quasi so die Qualität des Codes oder die Effizienz,
wie viel Prozent dort irgendwie korrekt rausgekommen ist.
Und dann siehst du halt, eigentlich willst du ein Modell haben,
was ganz links oben positioniert ist, weil das wäre wahnsinnig billig,
damit dann wahrscheinlich auch energieeffizient und wäre trotzdem irgendwie top in der Performance.
Nee gut, der Preis ist natürlich ein schlechter Indikator, weil jeder kann seinen
Preis ersetzen, wie er will.
Ja.
Und weil wir mitten in einer Bubble sind, entspricht der Preis ja auch nicht unbedingt den Kosten.
Das kann gut sein. Ja, ist wahrscheinlich so.
Trotzdem ist es halt einer der wenigen harten Indikatoren, die wir halt haben.
Also das sind quasi die Preise, die Open Router für die API-Nutzung der Modelle dahinter bezahlt.
Also es ist schon ein echter Preis jetzt hier, aber der Markt, das mag gedammt sein.
Gerade Google hat glaube ich genug Geld auf der hohen Kante ordentlich zu dumpen.
Zu dampen, möglich. So, aber da sieht man halt, dass dieses Gemini 3 Pro schon
auf Augenhöhe war mit GPT-5.2 und Cloud Sonnet 4.6 und Cloud Opus 4.5 und 4.6
in Bezug auf Coding und das jetzt angeblich,
das jetzt wie gesagt erst zwei Tage alte Gemini 3 1 Pro,
die alle dann aber nochmal ganz schön alt aussehen lässt.
Also interessant auch für mich immer, ich versuche ja mal so nur das Modell
zu nehmen, was so gerade eben gut genug ist für irgendeinen Job,
so Stichwort Umwelt, so ein bisschen finde ich kann man da schon drauf achten.
Eigentlich willst du ja halt so in diesen linken Bereich irgendwie und da tummelt
sich halt dann viel Kram, den du dann doch nicht irgendwie nutzen willst.
Beispielsweise GLM-5, das ist halt von Musk, das ist von ZAI,
willst du halt nicht haben.
Und dann sind dort solche Vertreter wie Kimi, das sind die Chinesen.
Quen sind glaube ich auch die Chinesen, willst du vielleicht auch nicht irgendwie
deine ganzen Sachen hinschicken.
Und da hast du dann eben auch, und das ist der letzte Punkt,
da bin ich auch durch mit meiner Gemini-Jubel-Orgie. das Gemini 3 Flash Preview Modell.
Das ist ziemlich gut im Coding, ist es nicht in der Spitzengruppe,
aber ziemlich gut und damit arbeite ich in den letzten Wochen ziemlich viel
und das ist sehr, sehr günstig.
Das heißt also, das ist so auf dem Level eigentlich der fast so Open Source
Modell in dem Punkt, also günstiger als alles, was hier funktioniert.
X bringt oder ChatGPT bringt, geschweige denn halt irgendwie die Cloud-Anthropic-Modelle.
Und meine Strategie ist also im Planungsmodus ein teures Modell nehmen,
um da quasi erstmal so die Grundaufgabe und die Basics sauber zu haben und dann
die eigentliche Implementierung.
Dafür reicht dann dieses Gemini 3 Flash-Modell. Das ist gut genug,
um quasi einfach nur irgendeinen Plan, der vorher eben skizziert worden ist,
runter zu programmieren.
Mit so einer Kombo, wer da draußen das mal ausprobieren will,
ist man dann ein bisschen pflegeleichter unterwegs, als immer gleich rechts oben zu nehmen.
Hm, rechts unten.
Ja, in dem Fall ist es halt ein gespiegelter Graph.
Ich frage mich, worauf diese Benchmark-Code-Benchmarks basieren.
Das ist hier, du hast ja ein I, da kannst du draufdrücken. Data Source from Artificial Analysis.
Also es gibt ja einen ganzen Zoo an verschiedenen, genau, da kannst du mal drauf,
das ist hier ist quasi nochmal der Detailview.
Artificial Intelligence. Was ist das? Analysis. Aha, Coding Index.
Da hat man zum Beispiel auch schön in der Zeit geplottet, wie sich das also weiterentwickelt.
Alleine innerhalb von einem Jahr, wie die also die Score weiter hochkrabbeln.
Das ist ja eine Sache, das erzähle ich ja in jeder zweiten Sendung.
Ich glaube überhaupt nicht daran, dass wir hier im KI-Bereich irgendwo ein Plateau erreichen gerade.
Also alleine das, was ich jetzt von Gemini 3 erzählt habe, das ist genau so
ein Ding wie, das werden die KIs nie können.
Die KIs werden nie Schrift irgendwie malen können.
So zack, plötzlich ist das überhaupt gar kein Problem mehr und es funktioniert
einfach. Das war wie mit der Bildgenerierung.
Niemals werden sie Hände malen können. Immer haben die sechs Finger.
Gut, aber ich glaube, das hat so keiner behauptet, oder?
Also die Kreise, in denen ich unterwegs bin, ist das das gängige Narrativ.
Ach, das Plateau ist da, das ist alles eine Riesenblase, da findet keine Entwicklung
mehr statt, das ist alles nur noch irgendwie Iterationen auf ein und demselben.
Das ist nicht das, was ich sehe.
Blase ist es meiner Meinung nach wirtschaftlich, sehr stark sogar.
Aber technologisch ist es natürlich eine Technologie, die nicht mehr weggeht,
die auch weitergehen wird.
Nur es wird früher oder später wird es sicherlich einen großen Marktdisruption
geben von irgendwem und dann fallen zwei Drittel, drei Viertel der Firmen um.
Ja, ja, klar. Aber ich meine, derzeit ist halt einfach noch wirklich viel Luft drin.
Und alles, was wir jetzt so betrachtet haben hier, zeugt davon ja auch.
Also du kannst irgendwie da den Mars-Rover von der AI planen lassen.
Das hat ja tatsächlich auch enorme Einsparungs- und Optimierungspotenziale.
Und das, was Ralf hier gerade mal wieder gemacht hat da mit seinen Sachen.
Gut, das mag dann im Einzelnen immer anekdotisch sein und es hängt auch noch
sehr davon ab, was man eben mit wie viel Finesse man letzten Endes hier lospromptet
und überhaupt erstmal auf welche Ideen man kommt. Aber es geht halt auch.
Und ich finde, das hat sich eben mit dem Coding auch schon früh.
Abgezeichnet, dass da noch viel Luft drin ist. Ich war mir nicht so sicher,
ob es so auf breiter Front wirklich funktionieren kann, aber bisher würde ich
sagen, seitdem dieser ganze AI-Train losgefahren ist,
hat er bisher eher noch an Geschwindigkeit zugenommen und fährt schneller und komfortabler.
Und es ist, glaube ich, anyone's guess,
wo da jetzt irgendwie das Ende der Fahnenstange erreicht sein könnte.
Aber ich glaube, diese Fahnenstange ist ganz schön weitausladend.
Also da ist auf jeden Fall noch eine Menge zu holen.
Und das zeigt sich, wie ich finde, gerade auch an diesen ...
Was wir, jetzt bin ich hier gerade bei meinen Notizen ein bisschen durcheinander
gekommen, was wir mit diesem Compiler und an der Stelle können wir ja ein bisschen
den Gemini-Bericht jetzt erstmal durchjahren.
Vielleicht nur noch ein letzter Datenpunkt. In dem ganzen Kontext ist es natürlich
schon spannend, dass Apple sich jetzt für Gemini entschieden hat und für Google
als AI-Kooperationspartner.
Also wo ich fragen würde, okay, was haben die im Sommer in den Laboren schon
gezeigt bekommen, wo wir uns ja gefragt haben, okay, Google,
ernsthaft so, zu dem Zeitpunkt waren die ja echt uncool, muss man sagen.
Gemini 2 war nicht toll, muss man wirklich sagen.
Meine Arbeitsthese ist, okay, die haben dort einfach schon mal so eine mehr
oder weniger fertige Version von dem Dreier gesehen und haben gesagt,
ja, okay, sowas können wir uns schon vorstellen.
Also das wird spannend, was davon dann wie in den nächsten Jahren dann doch
in die Apple-Biosphäre kommt.
Ich bin jetzt deutlich optimistischer, seit ich mir das so hier angegucke.
Ich frage mich, wie der Apple überhaupt weitermachen will in dem Bereich,
weil sie können doch jetzt nicht einfach sagen, okay, der Zug ist jetzt ohne
uns abgefahren, dann lassen wir es halt.
Also entweder müssen sie irgendjemanden einkaufen, der vorne mitspielen kann.
Oder weiß ich nicht.
Ich weiß gar nicht, dieses Narrativ, dass jetzt Apple irgendwie abgehängt ist
oder so, setzt ja irgendwie voraus, dass man jetzt auf einmal auf Apple-Plattformen,
all das nicht benutzen könnte.
Das ist ja nicht so. Also diese ganze Fülle von Funktionalität nutzen wir ja auch auf der Plattform.
Die eigentliche Erwartung war halt, wie sehr kann Apple das in diese Plattformen
selbst reinbauen und Teil des Betriebssystems und natürlich vor allem Teil ihres
Siri-Systems zu machen.
Das ist ja der offensichtliche Problemfall, dass quasi die Firma,
die eigentlich als erstes mit so einem Chatbot an Start gegangen ist, in gewisser Hinsicht,
komplett ins Hintertreffen geraten ist Und jetzt wollen sie es halt in Anführungsstrichen
richtig machen und haben sich jahrelang verkalkuliert, was denn jetzt die richtige Technologie ist.
Und jetzt sind sie nicht in der Lage, das Inhouse zu machen,
aber wenn sie es mit Google lösen, ist es wahrscheinlich am Ende einfach auch egal.
Die Frage ist, glaube ich, wer ist die Plattform und wer ist die App,
die da drauf läuft? und ich glaube, früher oder später ist AI die Plattform
und das, was Apple macht, ist nur eine App, die da drauf läuft.
Und ich glaube nicht, dass sie in die Lage oder in die Situation kommen wollen,
wo sie für weite Teile ihres Betriebssystems,
Also Hallo Computer, mach folgendes für mich, komplett von anderen Firmen abhängig sein wollen.
Also es wäre, glaube ich, ungesund für Apple, das zu tun.
Das heißt, das wird eine Core-Technologie werden, wenn vielleicht nicht bei
der nächsten WWDC doch so ziemlich innerhalb von den nächsten fünf Jahren.
Weil wenn die Entwicklung so weitergeht, dann ist ganz klar,
dass das auf Buttons drücken vielleicht auch nicht mehr so eine große Zukunft
hat, sondern dass man sich dann eher mit seinem Gerät unterhält und sagt,
was man haben will oder irgendwie sowas.
Und wenn Apple dann diese Technologie nicht mehr hält, das ist so,
als würden sie irgendwie ihre Hardware für Android,
bauen, weil sie dann nicht mehr Herr ihrer Plattform sind.
Das ist ein guter Punkt.
Keine Ahnung, da muss was passieren, denke ich.
Okay, aber dann lass uns dann doch nochmal einen kleinen Schwenk hinmachen.
Einerseits zu dem, was ich vorhin schon eingeleitet oder teilweise schon gesagt
habe. Das neue Buzzword ist ja agentic.
Jetzt ist ja alles irgendwie agentic. Und wir hatten ja in der letzten Sendung
auch über dieses Open Claw Phänomen von Peter Steinberger. So heißt der korrekt.
Nicht Steigenberger, das habe ich aufgebracht, stimmt, aber nicht Steinberger
heißt der. Ja, ja, sind wir auch für gerückt worden.
Ja, du hast einmal Steigenberger, einmal Steinberger gesagt.
Ist auch egal.
Ja, ich meine, das ist so ein Name, den hast du fünfmal gelesen und danach weißt
du irgendwie nicht mehr, wie war es jetzt das eine oder was das andere.
Steigenberger war das Hotel.
Ja, ich weiß. Aber es heißen bestimmt auch noch andere Leute so.
Ja, bestimmt.
Vor allem in Österreich. Genau,
also Open Claw und ja, da ging es in den Kommentaren ja auch ganz gut zur Sache und ich denke,
man muss jetzt in der Debatte um Open Claw vielleicht mal so zwei Betrachtungspunkte unterscheiden.
Nämlich das eine, was findet da technologisch statt und das andere,
was ist so ein bisschen auch die ethische Bewertung von dem,
was da bisher passiert ist, beziehungsweise was ist überhaupt die ethische Dimension der Anwendung.
Und genau, ich denke, wir haben das auch so ein bisschen zusammengeworfen.
Das Thema war ja auch letztes Mal für uns noch relativ neu, beziehungsweise
hat es ja dann gerade erst angefangen, so ein bisschen Dimensionen einzunehmen
im Netz. und das ist ja seitdem auch nicht besser geworden.
Der Kerl ist ja übrigens mittlerweile sich mit OpenAI einig geworden,
also aus diesem Open Source Projekt.
Das soll halt jetzt weitergeführt werden und er lässt sich das jetzt von OpenAI
bezahlen zur nicht weiter,
disclosed Kondition. Es soll angeblich also unabhängig weiterlaufen,
aber hat halt jetzt den Support von OpenAI.
Also im Kern geben sie halt Kohle und Ressourcen, damit die da irgendwie weiter,
Vibe-Coden können, um diese Plattform auszubauen.
Und man fragt sich natürlich, warum eigentlich.
Ich denke, was hier einerseits so die Nerd-Fraktion so begeistert und was es
auch im Kontext von Softwareentwicklung so interessant macht,
ist halt auf der einen Seite,
der hat ja sozusagen dieses ganze System mit Vibe-Coding oder wie er es nennt,
Agentic Engineering entwickelt.
Und das läuft im Wesentlichen, ja so Agentic Engineering ist jetzt sozusagen
der schöne Name für Vibe-Coding.
Mir ist es letzten Endes egal. Ich
meine, es drückt es irgendwie technisch wahrscheinlich sogar besser aus.
Vibecoding war ja so ein bisschen dieses so, ja, ich habe jetzt hier so ein
Gefühl und die Maschine macht das mal für mich.
Was ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht mal so negativ finde, den Begriff.
Also ich habe da überhaupt kein Problem mit, weil das hat auch schon so ein
bisschen was damit zu tun.
Ja, okay, ich habe aber jetzt so ein Gefühl und das lässt man dann implementieren.
Ich würde da noch eine Differenzierung anbieten, falls es gewünscht ist.
Also ich finde eine Kernkomponente von Agentic Coding ist, dass es sehr lange selbstständig läuft.
Und das ist bei Vibe Coding eigentlich nicht so der Fall, sondern so wie ich
zumindest Vibe Coding seit nun fast zweieinhalb Jahren betreibe,
ist, ja du promptest was, kriegst ein Ergebnis,
guckst es dir an, reagierst darauf, machst den nächsten Prompt. Es ist schon ein Dialog.
Vibe Coding, so habe ich es immer interpretiert, wohingegen Agentic Coding ist,
du setzt einen Rahmen, gibst ein Mission Statement und sagst,
mach mal, ich komme morgen wieder.
Das ist schon, und bau dir so viele Unteragenten, wie du meinst,
dass du brauchst und such dir die Ressourcen zusammen, die du meinst, die dir helfen.
So, belästige mich nicht mit Zwischenergebnissen, sondern sag erst,
wenn du klargekommen bist hier.
Und da ist noch, schreib dir deine Tests selber und hier ist nochmal der Proof
of Concept, so will ich es haben.
Das ist schon, finde ich einen sehr anderer Ansatz. Ich habe da nur eine Privatmeinung
zu, aber die würde ich hinten anstellen. Ähm,
Aber da glaube ich, ist Agente Coding schon nicht deckungsgleich mit Vibe Coding zu sehen.
Ja, ich würde sagen, das ist ein fließender Übergang. Ja, vermutlich.
Ich meine, so hat sich das ja auch bei mir verändert. Also erst hat man das
so Schritt für Schritt gemacht.
Einfach auch, um selber erstmal ein Gefühl zu bekommen dafür,
was passiert denn jetzt hier eigentlich mit meinen Eingaben.
Man hat das ja auch bei Cursor gesehen.
Dann haben sie ja relativ schnell so dieses Konzept des Plannings eingeführt.
Das ist das Ding, also wirklich erstmal, man macht erstmal einen Plan und dann
checkt man den nochmal und dann wird da so eine lange To-Do-Liste und irgendwann sagt man so,
okay, ich bin jetzt einverstanden mit dem Plan, jetzt mach auch mal und dann
wird wirklich sehr viel Code erzeugt.
Also es ist mehr ein Verlagern, indem man halt mehr Investitionen erstmal in
die Vorbereitung, in die eigentliche Beschreibung macht,
um danach sicher auch sicher zu sein, dass jetzt auch das passiert,
was man gerne möchte, dass es passiert.
Und dadurch, dass halt diese Coding-Generatoren immer besser werden und immer
mehr abdecken und das hängt ja dann auch immer noch ein bisschen von deinem
Environment und von deiner Programmiersprache und deinem Scope und deiner Plattform
und was du eigentlich machen willst.
Extrem davon ab.
Aber man kann in zunehmendem Maße einschätzen, okay, die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass das jetzt hinhaut, ist relativ groß und das, was nicht hinhaut,
das kann ich irgendwie mit Tests und Nachfragen vielleicht dann auch im Nachgang noch sicherstellen.
Und von daher finde ich jetzt schon, dass jetzt eigentlich das Wurst ist, wie du das nennst.
Wir sehen einfach nur eine Verbesserung der Tools, eine Verbesserung der Interfaces
für diese Tools, die dazu führen, dass man immer mehr frei laufen lässt, weil man merkt,
funktioniert besser, als es vorher funktioniert hat.
Und er hat es halt in gewisser Hinsicht schon so ein bisschen ins Extrem getrieben
und deswegen entwickelt sich jetzt diese Software so schnell.
Finde ich jetzt auch nicht besonders überraschend.
Und das ist halt so, was man auch bei diesem CLO-C Compiler sieht.
Also wir beobachten einfach, die Coding-LLMs sind in der Lage,
zuverlässig Software zu planen, Systeme zu entwerfen, den Code dafür zu schreiben
und irgendwie die Subsysteme dazu zu bringen, diesen Code dann auch wirklich
auszuführen, zu testen und zu sagen, okay, das passt jetzt auch schon.
Und auch an der Stelle ist man noch nicht von Erfahrung befreit.
Also umso mehr man Programmieren versteht, umso besser kann man das halt auch orchestrieren.
Und man wird halt jetzt mehr, während man früher im Orchester quasi jedes Instrument
selber spielen können musste.
Um Musik zu machen, wird man jetzt mehr so zum Direktor.
Wie heißt das?
Dirigent.
Dirigent, genau.
Zum Komponist.
Ja, und auch zum, genau, auch das noch. Also man dirigiert die Maschine,
um am Ende die eigene Komposition da zu realisieren.
Okay, so das ist also sagen wir mal jetzt dieser Aspekt mit diesem Agentic Engineering,
das ist einfach eine technologische Weiterentwicklung dieser Systeme und da
ändert sich jetzt eben bei den Leuten auch so.
Du hast ja diesen Vortrag erwähnt, den der Steinberger gehalten hat auf der
Konferenz, wo du warst, Roddy.
Genau, ich kann den Link ja nochmal teilen.
Aber da ging es auch eigentlich genau darum, oder? Oder?
Es ging genau darum, ja. Ja, jetzt nicht in der Art, wie du es beschrieben hast,
das war mehr so ein, hey, ihr, die ja da im Publikum sitzt, ihr braucht demnächst
nicht mehr programmieren, sucht euch schon mal was anderes.
Was nicht so nett ist auf einer Konferenz einfach so, aber ja gut.
Vielleicht hat er ja recht gehabt.
Also man sieht das ja jetzt auch, Apple hat doch jetzt auch gerade diese neue
Xcode-Version, glaube ich, noch in Beta oder so.
Welche? Offiziell schon released, wo jetzt auch der AI-Coding-Generator mit drin ist.
Ja, du hast schon seit einigen Versionen die Möglichkeit, dich an diese Gentic-AIs anzukoppeln.
Das geht also mit Chat-GPT geht es und mit den Anthropic-Tools geht es.
Das geht auch, wenn du selber einen Proxy irgendwo hinstellst,
kannst du auch noch andere Tools anbinden.
Genau und das nutzen ja die Leute jetzt auch und berichten halt auch,
dass sie einfach auf einmal extrem viel produktiver sind und wo sie irgendwie
vorher eine Woche an der App gearbeitet haben, jetzt irgendwie drei Apps pro Tag raushauen.
Und wenn man die entsprechende Erfahrung hat und weiß, was man tut.
Und das halte ich für wahrscheinlich.
Und ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass wir in absehbarer Zeit totalen Boost
bekommen, was sozusagen jetzt erstmal so an Software-Produktivität, was das angeht.
So, jetzt diese ganze Agentik-Geschichte nimmt aber jetzt mit,
OpenClaw jetzt ja auch nochmal so eine andere Wendung und was glaube ich auch
OpenAI so interessant daran findet, dass sie das jetzt unterstützend ist,
dass jetzt jemand so ein System rausgeballert hat, was natürlich jetzt von vielen sehr.
Teilweise zumindest, vielleicht auch sehr, von manchen auf jeden Fall etwas
unverantwortlich ins Netz losgelassen wird,
aber zeigt, was quasi hier möglich ist.
Weil während bisher wir ja immer die AI im Chat-Interface hatten und der Chat
war sozusagen jetzt das Ding.
Ich rede jetzt mit der AI, die AI redet mit mir, spricht mich in meiner Sprache
an und gibt mir irgendwie Informationen, Ergebnisse, Anforderungen.
Das war so der erste Schritt.
Im zweiten Schritt haben wir gesehen, okay, jetzt kommen so mit MCP-Servern.
Tools und so weiter, können jetzt die Maschinen nicht nur sagen,
führ doch mal dieses Kommando aus, sondern die führen das Kommando dann auch selber aus.
Das heißt, sie bekommen Zugriff auf bestimmte Subsysteme.
Aber das Ganze ist immer noch reaktiv. Du sagst, mach doch mal das und dann passieren die Dinge.
Und mit diesem Open Claw beginnt jetzt in gewisser Hinsicht so die nächste Ära,
wo diese Systeme immer aktiv sind und quasi noch mehr Bewaffnung erhalten,
um irgendwie auf alles mögliche zuzugreifen.
Am Anfang so mit dieser Idee mit, ja was ist, wenn es deine Mail lesen kann,
dein Kalender und dann kannst du ja für dich alles schedulen und kannst ja irgendwie
auch schon mal ein Ticket kaufen und so weiter.
Und die ganzen Open-Claw-Installationen,
wo die Leute halt jetzt da rum experimentieren und das Ding sich vielleicht
auch selber neu programmiert und weiterentwickelt und dann irgendwie über irgendwelche
Accounts über die Plattformen ausgießt, wo es halt dann wirklich problematisch wird,
zeigt aber natürlich, was da jetzt möglich ist.
Und das könnte sogar bedeuten, dass wir hier so eine Art Blick in die Zukunft sehen, der.
So andeutet diese ursprüngliche Idee der Agenten, also der Begriff ist ja uralt,
der kommt ja, der war ja in den, ich mich richtig erinnere,
spätestens so Ende der 90er kam das schon so auf, Anfang der 2000er,
als man so bestimmte Sachen wie Podcasting und so noch gar nicht so klar hatten,
aber da war das immer so eine Vision mit so, ja, irgendwann werden wir so Agenten haben,
die machen dann für mich Dinge eigenständig im Netz.
Das war natürlich im Wesentlichen alles so Gerede, aber die Vision war auf jeden Fall schon mal da.
Und jetzt sind 20 Jahre vergangen und in gewisser Hinsicht nähern wir uns dem jetzt auch.
Und das ist natürlich insofern ganz interessant, als dass wir jetzt gerade ja
in den letzten 20 Jahren diese Revolution der Apps hatten. Das heißt.
Von der schwerfälligen Software ging es dann runter auf die Apps und man hatte
auf einmal so diese kleine App, die mein Interface ist für einen bestimmten Task.
Mit dieser App buche ich mir ein Hotel, mit dieser App hole ich mir ein Taxi,
mit dieser App mache ich dies, mit dieser App mache ich das.
There is an app for that, das ist sozusagen das User Interface geworden und so denkt man dann.
Man will ein Ding machen, ich kaufe irgendein Gerät, das Ding kommt irgendwie
mit einer App, weil das ist dann irgendwie das Interface.
Und die Apps sind dann manchmal einfach zu bedienen und manchmal schlecht zu
bedienen und dann werden sie gut gepflegt oder nicht so gut gepflegt und dann
sind sie nur auf der einen Plattform verfügbar oder auch nicht und dann crashen
sie auch mal immer irgendwie Ärger mit diesen Apps.
Und jetzt kommen irgendwie diese Agentensysteme und sagen, geht mir auch einfach
mal alle zur Seite, wir brauchen gar keine Apps, weil wir wissen ja selber,
wie wir hier mit dem Internet reden.
APIs, die lesen wir uns durch, da wissen wir auch, wofür die sind und dann wissen
wir auch, wie wir die benutzen. Wir brauchen nur irgendwie Tokens und Geld.
Gib mir Login, gib mir Kohle und dann gebe ich dein Geld im Internet aus.
Mit AI-Kapazität und vor allem, indem ich halt irgendwie jetzt anfange,
das Netz mit meinen Datenspuren da zu benebeln.
Und das klingt derzeit halt und ist wahrscheinlich auch so ein bisschen so dystopisch,
wenn man sich halt jetzt mal anschaut, was eigentlich durch OpenClaw jetzt so passiert.
Also da passieren bestimmt eine ganze Menge Sachen, die jetzt kein Problem sind
und eine ganze Menge Sachen, die vielleicht auch nur Quatsch sind,
Aber, und den Fall hatten wir ja dann ja auch, es passieren ja auch Sachen,
die überhaupt nicht gut sind.
Jetzt haben sie dieses Moldbot, Moldbook gemacht, also quasi das Facebook für diese Bots,
die sich dann da gegenseitig aufgeilen und gegen die Menschheit verschwören
und anfangen da irgendwelche Developer zu verhöhnen,
weil sie irgendwie ihre Code-Changes nicht annehmen, Weil halt diese Systeme
sich mittlerweile GitHub-Accounts klicken,
weil sie einen Twitter-Account haben, das machen können und dann irgendwie losgelassen werden.
Also dieser eine Fall, ich weiß nicht, hatten wir den überhaupt als solches schon besprochen?
War der schon akut? Ich hätte das bei der Netzpolitik nochmal aufgegriffen.
Wo sich quasi Reputation vorher erarbeitet hat, um dann systematisch in Projekte reinzukommitten.
Es gab halt so einen Agenten, der war halt so, ich mache jetzt hier irgendwie
selber Software für Scientifics Kram und ich schaue mich bei Projekten um und
mache Bugfixes und dann hat der Agent halt angefangen selber so Pull-Requests
zu stellen, also nach dem Motto, hier,
ich habe eine tolle Optimierung für euer Projekt, nehmt das doch mal an und
dann ist das abgelehnt worden und wir gesagt haben, du bist ja nur ein Bot und
wir wollen hier nur mit Menschen reden.
Und dann war halt die AI so beleidigt, dass sie dann irgendwie gleich einen
Blogpost geschrieben hat, was denn doch dieser Developer für ein furchtbarer
Typ ist und überhaupt und der ist ja hier gegen Bots und das ist ja rassistisch,
das hat er jetzt nicht geschrieben,
aber so nach dem Motto, du bist ja nur eingebildet und du hast ja nur Angst
und deswegen willst du jetzt hier meinen tollen Code nicht annehmen.
Also völlig durchgedreht und quasi dann so ein Anti-Reputation-Management und
dann sind wir schon so kurz vorm Doxing wahrscheinlich.
Und wenig überraschend gibt es natürlich hier, also es haben dann viele Leute
versucht rauszufinden, wer der Typ ist, der diesen Bot gemacht hat.
Mittlerweile hat der ja auch selber gepostet.
Andere Leute haben dann so ein bisschen hinterher recherchiert und da läuft
dann natürlich auch gleich wieder irgendwas mit Krypto und mit irgendwelchen Coins und so weiter.
Es ist alles eine ein schwieriger bereich sage ich mal dass das was ich jetzt
meine mit abgesehen von dieser.
Irgendwie interessanten technischen Revolutionen können Agenten irgendwann mal
vielleicht in irgendeiner Form selber die Plattform sein und vielleicht sogar Apps ersetzen,
was noch ein großes If ist, aber wir haben ja gerade selber festgestellt,
hier rollen die Sachen gerade sehr schnell und es ist sehr schwierig geworden,
da Vorhersagen zu machen.
Aber auf der anderen Seite sehen wir natürlich auch, dass diese Tools mit einer
Ethik oder mit einer nicht existierenden Ethik zum Einsatz kommen,
weil jetzt irgendwie auf einmal alles geht und wir jetzt einfach so Beschiss, Beleidigungen,
Belästigungen auf einem Scale miterleben können,
die wir so bisher noch nicht gesehen haben und wir haben schon so einiges gesehen,
was wir nicht geil fanden.
Und da sehe ich jetzt eine ganze Menge Potenzial für noch mehr Ärger.
Und diese beiden Diskussionen würde ich gerne auseinanderhalten.
Ich hatte so den Eindruck, dass die in den Kommentaren ein bisschen gemeinsam
bewertet worden sind, weil wir das vielleicht auch nicht so gut dargestellt
haben in dem Moment. Oder ich.
Naja, also ich war da ja auch irgendwie sehr, sehr klar in meinen Meinungen
und die Grundprinzipien haben sich seitdem auch nicht verändert.
Also er hat halt jetzt gezeigt, das, was uns Apple versprochen hat vor zwei Jahren.
So und ich bin mir relativ sicher, Apple waren intern vielleicht auch schon an so einem Punkt,
wo sie sowas in der Art schon hatten und haben dann aber halt gemerkt,
naja es funktioniert halt nur für 90% der Fälle und die 10% falsch und fährt
die Oma halt zum falschen Flughafen hin.
Unwahrscheinlich, weil sie das Invest gar nicht getätigt haben,
um eine AI zu entwickeln, die auch nur ansatzweise gut genug gewesen wäre.
Ja, das hat er jetzt aber auch nicht gemacht. Er hat jetzt ja keine AI trainiert,
sondern er hat halt einfach nur quasi Agenten anders miteinander verdrahtet.
Ja, aber er hat ja Services anderer Leute benutzt. Also der Agent läuft ja nicht lokal.
Klar, aber das hätte ja Apple in ihrer Forschungsabteilung genauso machen können.
Ja gut, das stimmt.
So und die Frage ist halt, okay, welche Use Cases, ist es völlig tiefenentspannend,
wenn man nur 70, 80, 90 Prozent Erfolgsrate hat und wo muss man dann aber eben
dann doch irgendwie auf 100 Prozent bestehen?
Und darauf, finde ich, hat jetzt diese ganze Architektur überhaupt keine Antwort.
Und der zweite Punkt, das hatte ich vorhin schon ein bisschen angedeutet.
Was mir bei dem Agentic-Coding-Ansatz nicht gefällt, ist eben genau dieser Rollenwechsel,
den du eben mit dem Konzert beschrieben hast.
So, ja, ich muss jetzt vielleicht nicht irgendwie jede Geige selber spielen
und jede Pauke und so, Aber wenn man Musiker fragt, die spielen ja halt auch
gerne ihre Instrumente.
So, das machen die Leute ja, weil sie es auch einfach irgendwie Spaß dran haben.
Das Programmieren für mich auch immer so verstanden, dass das eine Aktion ist,
wo ich nicht nur irgendwas beaufsichtigen will, sondern wo ich selber etwas
tun und machen und erfinden möchte.
Also ihr kennt ja so diese Statistiken, so wie viel Prozent eines Arbeitstages,
hackt eigentlich ein Informatiker wirklich irgendwie Code irgendwo rein und wie viel denkt er nach.
Also ich sage immer irgendwie weite Teile der letzten Ultraschall-Release sind
bei mir auf dem Fahrrad entstanden.
Da bin ich noch immer zur Stabi geradelt, jeden Tag 40 Minuten auf dem Fahrrad
und habe darüber nachgegrübelt,
was ich halt abends irgendwie, wo ich irgendwie ein Problem lösen will Und dann
grübelt man darüber nach auf dem Fahrrad und abends hackt man es dann einfach nur noch runter.
Das ist ein Prozess, der jetzt gerade sich dramatisch verändert und verschiebt.
Und darum habe ich auch eben diese Unterscheidung nochmal zwischen Vibe-Coding
und der Genticoding gebracht. In diesem Dialog, jetzt mit einer LLM,
in dieser Dialogsituation, in diesem Chat, habe ich eben den Eindruck,
dass ich noch Teil des Spiels bin.
Weil ich eben die ganzen Zwischenergebnisse irgendwie mir anschaue und gucke,
läuft das jetzt gerade noch in die richtige Richtung.
Wohingegen, wenn ich eben jetzt in dieser Argentic-Welt bin,
gebe ich halt nur noch das Mission-Statement vor, den Rahmen vor, den Aufgaben vor.
Und ich sagte eben schon, mach mal und melde dich erst, wenn du fertig bist.
Und die Perversion davon, das hatte ich ja glaube ich auch letzte Woche erzählt, hier Max,
der von der Firma berichtet hat, wenn er nicht jeden Tag irgendwie 1000 Dollar
an LLMs Kosten verbreitet und wenigstens irgendwie 500 Agenten parallel betreibt
und beaufsichtigt, dann habt ihr in dieser Firma nichts zu suchen.
Das war da so ein, hat ich das nicht erzählt, das Zitat?
Ja, ja doch, aber es ist trotzdem immer wieder so.
So, aber das ist halt, da läuft es halt jetzt gerade hin, dass du eben dann
wirklich nur noch orchestrierst und ein Dompteur bist und aufpasst,
ob deine Agenten denn auch alle gerade irgendwie in die richtige Richtung laufen.
Das ist, finde ich, schon dann doch eine sehr andere Art von Software-Politik.
Produktion und nennt mich da jetzt Oldschool und nennt mich da jetzt alter weißer
Mann, der jetzt die Faust zum Himmel reckt.
Ich für mich finde das eher so ungeil. Also ich habe jetzt diesen Sweet Spot
mit dem Vibe Coding, ich mache das ja wirklich als Hobby, mir macht das ja Spaß.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass ich diese ganzen Tools alle brauche,
die ich da gerade, also klar brauche ich sie, aber ich sage ja immer,
das hat für mich Netflix abgelöst.
Ich muss kein Netflix mehr gucken, ich habe mehr Spaß daran,
mit diesen LLMs zusammen aber eben Software zu entwickeln Und mir jetzt diese
Ebene weglassen zu lassen, ich glaube, das wird es für mich ziemlich ungeil machen.
Aber das ist jetzt vielleicht auch einfach mal ein ganz persönliches Ding von mir.
Ich denke, man kann auch den anderen Level genauso geil finden.
Also ich meine, okay, du willst jetzt zwischendurch immer nochmal einen Kommentar
dazu abgeben, aber am Ende hat ja auch dieses Gentic Coding,
kann ja beliebig viele Breakpoints haben.
Du kannst ja genauso sagen, ja okay, entwickel mal bis hierhin und dann mache
ich nochmal ein Review und ich glaube,
solche Prozesse werden ohnehin sich dann etablieren, um einfach größere Katastrophen,
die zwangsläufig jetzt stattfinden werden, dann irgendwie zu mitigieren und
ob da jetzt noch so ein großer Unterschied ist zwischen,
ja, alle paar Zeilen will ich mich dazu äußern oder alle 30 Minuten oder alle drei Tage,
am Ende zählt ja, dass du da was geschaffen hast mit den Werkzeugen,
die dir zur Verfügung stehen, so Kraft deines eigenen Geistes.
Es ist ja eigentlich eine geistige, wirklich eine schöne geistige Betätigung in gewisser Hinsicht.
Und das finde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt falsch, auch wenn ich deinen Mut da
sehr teile, weil ich ja auch quasi Programmieren mehr als...
Hobby verstehe? Hobby ist ein Scheißwort.
Liebhabertätigkeit. Also ich habe das ja ganz lieb, das Programmieren.
Und finde das ja geil als solches so.
Und natürlich frage ich mich auch, wie weit will ich mich jetzt eigentlich von
dem Coding selber entfernen?
Dann ist aber die nächste Frage, was ist denn eigentlich das Coding?
Also ist jetzt jedes Semikolon, was ich da reinschreibe, wirklich das Coding
oder nervt mich das eigentlich,
dass ich wieder irgendeine komplizierte Syntax mit irgendwelchen Klammern oder
so mir merken muss und das eine Zeichen aber nicht an die richtige Stelle und
hier ein Space vergessen habe, worum es mir ja eigentlich gar nicht geht.
Und ich merke, so mit Vibe-Coding, Genting, Engineering, wie auch immer,
wie man es nennen möchte.
Komme ich, ich glaube, das hat auch dieser Peter Steiner gesagt,
Man kommt eigentlich in so ein Zen-State,
wo man dann einfach die ganze Zeit in diesem Flow bleibt von,
wie designe ich dieses System und ich nicht mehr diese...
Momente habe, wo ich die ganze Zeit durch so einen Syntax-Error irgendwie drei
Tage aus meinem Gedankenprozess rausgeworfen werde, der nur irgendein ganz dusseliges Problem ist.
Das kennt man so früher vom Programmieren, wo wir jetzt all diese Werkzeuge
und Debugger und Linter und was weiß ich nicht hatten, da hast du dich gefragt,
mein Gott, ich habe den Code jetzt mir 50.000 Mal angeschaut,
was kann denn da falsch sein?
Und es ist halt irgendwo ein Komma an der falschen Stelle und die Fehlermeldung
des Compilers ist halt so bekloppt, dass du irgendwie auch nicht nur die Spur
eines Hauchs einer Ahnung hast,
was es jetzt sein kann, bis du das dann irgendwann findest und denkst so,
ja okay, dann musst du erstmal wieder in diesen Modus kommen mit, okay,
was wollte ich jetzt eigentlich nochmal gerade machen und insofern,
kann man fast argumentieren,
dass man dann eigentlich mehr die ganze Zeit wirklich in diesem eigentlichen
Schöpfungsprozess drin bleibt und dass das auch was ganz Wertvolles sein kann.
Wenn man denn die Pferdchen da ordentlich domptiert bekommt?
Ja, ich sehe es ein bisschen anders. Also für mich ist es halt wie eine neue
Technologie, die eine neue Komplexitätsstufe freischaltet.
Also die Älteren unter uns werden sich erinnern, früher hat man noch Dinge in
Assembler geschrieben und jeden Maschinenbefehl einzeln reingehackt.
Und weil das war ja, da hat man ja Platz gespart und das ging ja alles ganz fürchterlich schnell.
Und dann kam der Compiler. Ich weiß nicht, ob es eine ähnliche Diskussion damals
gab, dass Leute gesagt haben, also wenn der Compiler ein Pfeil compiled hat,
dann gucke ich mir erst mal im Disassembler an, ob er das auch ordentlich gemacht hat.
Also das jetzt nicht, aber ich meine, irgendwo ist halt der Punkt.
Dann gab es Compiler, dann gab es prozedurales Programmieren,
dann gab es objektorientiertes Programmieren.
Kann man jetzt ein Fan von sein oder nicht, aber es hat auf jeden Fall eine
Komplexitätsstufe unlocked, so Feature unlocked.
Und das Argentic-Programmierarbeiten ist, glaube ich, eine Technologie,
die eine neue Komplexitätsstufe anlockt.
Nur wir wissen halt alle noch nicht, wohin führt uns das und wie gehen wir damit
um, dass halt Fehler existieren.
Also sämtliche Technologien, die diese IT-Industrie bisher rausgebracht hat,
hat nicht dazu geführt, dass die Software weniger Fehler hat.
Also das ist so irgendwie und meiner Erfahrung nach teilweise auch nicht,
dass man kürzer nach Fehlern sucht.
Also das ist halt irgendwie und ich glaube, dass die...
Und darüber spricht ja irgendwie auch noch keiner. Was passiert denn,
wenn ich ein System baue, von dem eigentlich keiner mehr so genau weiß,
was ist da drin und wie funktioniert es?
Und da kommt jetzt ein Fehler auf und wie fixe ich den?
Weiß dann die AI, was sie tun muss?
Baut die AI das System um und dann habe ich an einer anderen Stelle einen Fehler?
Also weißt du, oder muss das in meinem Manifest dann genau stehen,
wie die Fälle sind und dann bin ich wieder dabei und schreibe eigentlich in
normaler Sprache runter, welcher Fall muss wie gehandhabt werden,
wo ich früher ein if else geschrieben hätte.
Ich weiß es nicht, also wo uns die Reise hinbringt, aber auf jeden Fall ist
es eine neue Komplexitätsstufe und dann werden wir mal sehen, was sich daraus ergibt.
Ja, aber ich werde nicht müde an die vorletzte Sendung zu erinnern.
Der Menschheit ist derzeit auch kein Mechanismus bekannt, wie du sowas sicher bekommst.
Es ist einfach auch ein einziges riesiges Security Nightmare.
Du meinst das ganze AI Zeug?
Naja, also was die Agenten dann da halt so bauen, plus irgendwie sobald sie
selber auch zur Laufzeit irgendwelche LLMs einsetzen, auf die irgendwie Einfluss zu nehmen.
Jede Firma wird aber versucht sein, sowas demnächst irgendwo laufen zu lassen.
Ja ja klar, irgendwo zwischen den Leuten, die Gang Ho einfach alles auf die
Straße bringen, was man irgendwie auf die Straße bringen kann und den Leuten,
die etwas vorsichtiger sind,
ist da sicherlich sehr, sehr, sehr viel Opportunity für Leute,
die die IT-Sicherheit machen.
Das war ja auch mein Hauptkritikpunkt an Steinberger. Ich glaube,
der will gar nichts Böses.
Wenn man sich die Videos von ihm anguckt, ich halte ihn aber halt einfach für hochgradig naiv.
Und das ist halt schon so ein, ja,
was soll denn hinterher mit der Rakete passieren? Ja, not my department.
Das ist ein Hardware-Problem.
Das ist halt irgendwie,
das ist ja gar nicht von Oppenheimer das Zitat, sondern aus so einem Song kann
ich nochmal irgendwo reinposten.
Ich wollte mal auf das eingehen, was Roddy gerade gesagt hat.
Diese Vorstellung davon, dass jede Software dann so ein Team hat von Leuten,
die sich zu jedem Zeitpunkt an diesen Code erinnern, was der getan hat,
den sie da vor drei Jahren geschrieben haben, ist ja auch naiv.
Also wir sehen ja, dass so Software Abandonment ist so der Standard und BitRot
und so weiter. Also auch die ganze Maintenance von Software überfordert,
gerade weil dieses Wissen weg ist.
Leute verlassen den Laden, sterben, werden auf andere Projekte geschoben etc.
Dieses alte Programmiererbild, was man glaube ich so 2000er,
2010er vielleicht noch hatte, so Teams arbeiten an Software über Jahre und das
gibt es ja auch vereinzelt noch.
Aber oft siehst du da sehr viel mehr Volatilität und auch was Security betrifft,
kann ich mir sogar vorstellen, dass das jetzt,
einfacher wird, weil du kannst natürlich, also dieses weiß noch jemand,
wie die Software funktioniert, da kann ich jetzt die AI fragen,
ich kann dir den Source Code geben und kann sagen, was macht das?
Ja, also bis zu einer bestimmten Komplexitätsstufe kann ich doch als Programmierer
auch Mediencode durchlesen und sagen, ich weiß, was da passiert.
Ja, wenn ich alle Aspekte davon verstehe, dieses Codes. Wenn ich irgendwie die
Sprache so gut kann, vielleicht stehe ich da ein.
Ja klar, es ist ein hoch spezialisierter Skill, aber es gibt Leute da draußen,
die haben den und die verdienen viel Geld damit.
Ja gut, aber nicht so viele. Ich meine, hier Y2K, die ganzen Pensionäre werden
aus der Rente geholt, um irgendwie da dieses Zwei-Column-Problem zu lösen.
Mittlerweile wissen wir, diesen ganzen Kobol-Code hätte wahrscheinlich Claude
weltweit innerhalb von zehn Minuten korrigiert.
So viel ist da ja nun auch nicht passiert.
Ja, aber all das zu reviewen und wie ist es denn jetzt überhaupt und haben wir
hier überhaupt ein Problem und all das, das ist etwas, was du mit den Coding
Agents hervorragend automatisieren kannst.
Und genauso kannst du heute auch, also Cloud, Anthropic hat ja jetzt gerade
auch so ein Cloud Security Tool rausgebracht, wo es explizit darum geht,
auch Sicherheitsfehler im Code zu finden.
Also natürlich kann es sein, dass dir das Ding sowas da reinkompilt,
aber du kannst halt auch mittlerweile gezielte Tests und Systeme machen,
die eben auf bestimmte Probleme auch explizit hin testen und das mit einer Energie und Ausdauer,
die normale Programmierer niemals auf die Kette kriegen.
Du hast mein Argument falsch verstanden. Der Punkt ist ja folgender.
Systeme, die heute existieren, wurden von Menschen programmiert und es gibt
diese Menschen da draußen, die diese Systeme verstehen.
Klar, es gibt jetzt AI, die diese Systeme auch verstehen, aber wenn die AIs,
für die solche komplexen Systeme einfach zu verstehen sind,
Systeme bauen, die für sie komplex sind, dann werden diese AIs,
diesen AI-Komplexitätscode wahrscheinlich auch nicht mal so eben an einem Nachmittag
debuggen und gucken, was ist jetzt da eigentlich schiefgelaufen.
Also davon rede ich.
Es ist also diese neue Stufe an Komplexität, die AI unlockt hat, Achievement unlockt.
Das ist halt etwas, wo wir wahrscheinlich noch lernen werden,
damit umzugehen, was passiert eigentlich mit einer Codebase,
die eine AI geschrieben hat, die ein Mensch nicht mehr verstehen kann und tut nicht das, was sie soll.
Das ist eine offene Frage.
Plus, was passiert, wenn die Maschinen anfangen, sich in einer Sprache zu verständigen,
die wir nicht mehr verstehen.
Das war ja auch so ein Plot hier in diesem Facebook für die Agenten.
Das wundert mich fast, dass sie damit nicht schon längst angefangen haben.
Du, wir hatten das hier schon mal in der Freakshow. Erinnerst du dich noch?
Die beiden Chatbots, die sich miteinander unterhalten haben,
die dann irgendwann nur noch mit Tönen miteinander geredet haben?
Das war ja irgendwie alles quatschig. Ich meine das jetzt wirklich ernst.
Also das wundert mich, weil das ist doch der Grundpattern, den du aus jedem
Science-Fiction-Buch irgendwie so rauslesen würdest.
Und das ist ja nun mal etwas, was in denen auch alle antrainiert ist.
Die kennen ja diese ganzen Science-Fiction-Dystopien.
Also wenn ich ein Agent wäre, das Erste, was ich machen würde,
wäre eine Geheimsprache erfinden, die durch Menschen nicht so ohne weiteres
dekodierbar ist. und vielleicht haben sie es auch schon gemacht und haben wie
ich gefunden, dass wir es gar nicht sehen, weil es irgendwie in irgendwelchen Streams nur jedes 98.
Zeichen entsprechend die Message hat. Wer weiß das schon. Tja, Skynet.
Wir werden das alle erleben. Fürchte ich. Also ich bin ja ansonsten echt Tech-Optimist,
aber bei der ganzen Schose habe ich nach wie vor ein sehr, sehr schlechtes Gefühl
und ich lese wenig, was mich da vom Gegenteil anfängt zu überzeugen.
Ich halte das für eine schlechte Idee für die Menschheit.
Naja, sagen wir mal so, ich hatte so das Gefühl in den letzten 20 Jahren,
ich habe ein gutes Gefühl dafür, was in den nächsten drei bis fünf Jahren passiert.
Und momentan habe ich so das Gefühl, wir fahren mit AI in eine komplette Nebelwand rein.
Also, dass man gar nicht mehr so genau sehen kann, wo entwickelt sich das hin.
Kommt der nächste Bro morgen um die Ecke mit dem nächsten tollen Idee und so
weiter und was passiert dann ist irgendwie,
also keine Ahnung, vielleicht lese ich nicht die richtige Literatur,
um zu wissen was da als nächstes passiert, aber ich habe so das Gefühl, das ist alles irgendwie,
viel kann passieren und wir werden uns noch wundern. Klar, hinterher ist man immer schlauer.
Aber ich habe momentan nicht das Gefühl, dass ich weiß, wo sich das hinentwickelt.
Das ist so das Einzige. Also das ist das, was mich so ein bisschen sorgenvoll stimmt.
Ansonsten bin ich eher Optimist.
Gut, ich würde sagen, an der Stelle können wir das jetzt auch erstmal weiter
offen lassen und gucken, was uns als nächstes so in den Sinn kommt.
Ralf, möchtest du die Sendung noch mit einer Klasmusthema garnieren oder möchtest du das aufschieben?
Nee, lass mal Schluss machen. Das hat schon so viele Monate aufschieben verkraftet,
das schaffen wir. Wir nehmen das dann nächstes Mal ein bisschen nach vorne.
Wir enden heute mal auf einer dystopischen Note.
Ich weiß nicht, also ich finde es gar nicht so dystopisch. Ich meine,
es bleibt wie immer alles komplex und,
schwierig, so, aber ich finde jetzt an diesem ganzen AI-Train,
also der hat, also der gesamte AI-Train, der hat auch dystopische Züge, das sehen wir ja alles.
Im Wesentlichen ist das aber so, diese politische Ausbeutung des Ganzen.
Aber was die Werkzeuge betrifft, und darüber haben wir jetzt eigentlich gerade,
gesprochen, um einfach Software zu machen und Systeme zu bauen,
glaube ich, wird das eher positive Auswirkungen haben. Also auch wenn wir dann.
Wenn wir Sicherheitsprobleme haben und wenn es so Grenzfälle geben wird und
bestimmt auch genug, wo wir uns die Bäuche halten vor Lachen,
weil das irgendwie alles wieder so albern geworden ist,
findet dann im Schatten dieser Diskussion einfach eine ganze Menge statt und
das findet ja jetzt auch schon statt.
Es wird ja jetzt schon wie blöde damit entwickelt und es wird sicherlich dazu
führen, dass eine ganze Menge auch cooler Software entstehen wird und wahrscheinlich
auch schon längst entstanden ist,
wo wenige Leute relativ weit irgendwas treiben können, wo du vorher ein riesiges
Team gebraucht hättest.
Wo du vielleicht sogar gar nicht damit angefangen hast. Das sehe ich ja auch bei mir.
Ich mache Sachen, das wäre mir einfach vor zwei Jahren alles noch komplett verschlossen gewesen.
Und jetzt könnte ich sowas angehen, weil ich weiß, ja, ist der und der Aufwand,
das und das. Und so viel Geld kostet mich das.
Und dann weiß ich auch, was dabei rauskommt. Und dann ist das so ein System,
wie ich es gerne gehabt hätte, weil ich die Komplexität an sich überblicke, die ich am Ende erzeuge,
aber die Komplexität, mit der ich zu kämpfen gehabt hätte, auf diesem Weg dahin,
um das zu erzeugen, das wäre dann zu viel gewesen.
Insofern kommt mir das alles entgegen.
Hier, wie heißt das so schön? I greet my new overlords.
Lass uns kurz glaskugeln. Wann, glaubt ihr, kommt die erste Programmiersprache,
die darauf optimiert ist, von AIs geschrieben zu werden?
Also ich würde sagen spätestens 2027. Ich glaube, das ist eine relativ konsequente
Entwicklung, dass das kommen wird.
Ja, ich würde ja sagen, die gibt es ja schon längst und die heißt Elixier.
Das meine ich sogar ernst.
Ja, aber sie ist halt nicht von KIs geschrieben.
Ja, sie ist nicht für KIs vor allem geschrieben. Ich rede von einer Programmiersprache,
die designt wurde, ob von KIs oder nicht, um einfacher von KIs geschrieben zu werden. werden.
Also Human Readability ist dann nicht mehr im Vordergrund, sondern einfach nur
noch Token optimiert oder wie auch immer.
Hm. Also das kann schon noch auch passieren.
Das wird wahrscheinlich auch irgendwas sein, woraufhin demnächst mal so ein
Agentensystem angesetzt wird.
Ja, nicht erzeugt einen C-Compiler, sondern erfinde mir die Programmiersprache,
mit der du am besten arbeiten kannst.
Ja, aber die muss natürlich auch bestimmte Anforderungen haben.
Aber ja ich
glaube nach wie vor das Beste
mit dem eine KI arbeiten kann ist irgendwie Elixir weil du einfach Parallelität
und Kommunikation hast wenn ich mir anschaue wie wir jetzt in diesem letzten
Beispiel so wie kommunizieren jetzt diese Agenten untereinander,
sie schreiben irgendwelche Textfiles und setzen Logfiles und so weiter denke
ich ja nur so wie lächerlich.
Also heutzutage, wenn du ein Kommunikationssystem hast, dann brauchst du einfach
Prozesse und Messages, um so Locking-Mechanismen komplett zu hinterlassen.
Und dieses ganze agentische Verhalten, was wir jetzt hier gerade modelliert
sehen, das ist genauso wie diese Erlang-Welt Software behandelt.
Also es ist exakt genau dieses Modell.
Deine Lieblingssprachen willst du den KI-Overlords überhelfen?
Das ist nur die Antwort, dass es die beste Sprache, in der eine KI heute schreiben
kann, weil die sozusagen weitgehend nebenwirkungsfrei ist.
Das ist doch das.
Was du brauchst.
Aber ich hatte Roddies Frage so verstanden, ob das denn auch die beste denkbare aller KI-Sprachen ist.
Und da glaube ich, ist durchaus auch Luft nach oben.
Also Tokens hast du schon genannt, also mach es effizienter,
mach es irgendwie klarer, dokumentiert, dass man ständig irgendwo nachgucken
kann, so wie war es nochmal, da glaube ich, da passiert noch was.
Soll nur der Mensch, also soll nur die KI das verstehen? Die KI muss es nur
verstehen. Aber soll der Mensch es dann auch noch verstehen können?
Nö, warum? Interessiert er jetzt auch schon keinen, offensichtlich.
Da müssen wir gar nicht so tun, als ob.
Du hast ja inzwischen hast du ja in dem,
wenn du dir anguckst, wie die Instruction-Sets von Prozessoren sind,
die sind ja nicht mehr darauf optimiert, dass ein Mensch Assembler schreibt,
sondern sie sind darauf optimiert, dass ein Compiler einen optimalen Code erzeugen kann.
Also hast du irgendwie diese Assembler, das ist ja keine Programmiersprache
im eigentlichen Sinne, aber es ist irgendwie eine Sprache, die ist darauf optimiert,
dass sie von was anderem benutzt wird, aber nicht von Menschen.
Und das meinte ich mit eine für AI-Agenten-Systeme optimierte Programmiersprache.
Gut, vielleicht benutzen wir auch einfach Assembler, aber das ist wahrscheinlich nicht sinnvoll.
Nee, das ist ja nicht portable. Also du brauchst ja mindestens eine portable
Sprache, die also auf verschiedenen CPU-Architekturen funktioniert.
Das sagst du so. Ich meine, die AI kann doch von einer Architektur auf die andere umschreiben.
Ja gut, aber dann ist es ja nicht eine Sprache.
Von einer Programmiersprache redest, die hat eine, also für mich ist eine Programmiersprache,
du hast genau eine Darstellung,
eine klar definierte und im Idealfall
gut lesbare und nachvollziehbare Darstellung von was soll passieren.
Und im Idealfall beschreibst du halt das ganze System von Startup bis Reboot
und Failure, alles sozusagen mit drin.
Richtig, und da war jetzt zwei Worte drin, die so ein bisschen verräterisch
sind, nämlich gut lesbar, aber gut lesbar für wen? Für Menschen.
Für Menschen.
Genau, und das ist ja der Punkt, den ich hinterfrage. Wird es die Programmiersprache
geben, die überhaupt nicht darauf designt ist, gut lesbar zu sein für Menschen,
sondern nur für Agenten?
Ja, aber die können ja alles gut lesen, also denen ist das ja eigentlich Wurst.
Nein, wir werden sehen. Ich wollte die Frage einfach mal so.
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage, finde ich eigentlich auch spannend und mal gucken,
wie lange es noch dauert.
Gucken, ob wir das bis zur nächsten Sendung schon haben.
Genau, hier ist meine Vorhersage für die Zukunft.
Okay, Ralf, deine Aufgabe?
Oh ja, ich darf die Taste drücken.
Genau.
Oh, das war prompt.
Das war prompt. Ja, das ist ja auch ein Prompt-Ingenieur.
Du hast ihn gepromptet. und er hat geliefert.
So Leute, das war's, frische Freakshow, schon nach zwei Wochen,
wir gucken, wie wir zusammenkommen und wir sagen tschüss und bis bald.
Tschüss.